IS WEDNESDAY MARCH THIRTIETH.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WHICH MEANS
THAT IT'S MY SON EMMETT'S
BIRTHDAY. IT'S ALSO TIME FOR
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
NUMBER THREE. AND I WANT TO
WELCOME YOU ALL TO- ANOTHER ONE
OF OUR IMPORTANT COMMITTEE
HEARINGS SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS.
TODAY WE ARE RETURNING TO THE
TOPIC OF TRANSPORTATION WE'VE
TAKEN A BIT OF A HIATUS FOR A-
COUPLE OF WEEKS. WE ARE IN ROOM
ONE TWENTY SIX OF THE CAPITAL
THE PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY SOME OF. THE PALACE
AND SOME OF THEM ARE HERE- WE'RE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THIS HEARING AS WE ALWAYS
DO BOTH IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
ON THE PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBER
TO CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE ALSO
PRESENT ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET. THE
PHONE NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN THAT'S 877-692-8957
WITH THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE OF
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE ONE TWO SIX
AGAIN ONE THREE ONE. FIVE ONE
TWO SIX I'LL REPEAT THIS
INFORMATION AT THE END OF THE
HEARING KERR BEFORE A PUBLIC
COMMENT- NEAR THE END OF THE
HEARING. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB. A BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2099
THAT'S NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE
NINE TWO ZERO NINE NINE THE
STAFF MEMBER WILL BE AVAILABLE
TO ASSIST YOU. WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HEARING AND
YOU MAY SEND THAT TESTIMONY- TO
BUDGET SUB THREE THAT'S NUMERAL
THREE BUDGET SUB. THREE AT ASM.
M. AS IN MERRY DOT CA DOT GOV.
THE WILL. ACTUALLY IN ORDER WE
ARE A QUORUM YET CLOSE BUT NO
CIGAR. SO WE WILL- A BEGIN AS A-
SUB COMMITTEE A SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND THE FOR OUR ROLL CALL WE
WILL ALSO- PASSED THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR A PASS ON THAT UNTIL
LATER IN THE HEARING. SINCE WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM. AND BEGIN
ARE WE READY TO BEGIN WITH ISSUE
ONE ALL RIGHT WE WILL BEGIN WITH
ISSUE ONE AND HERE FROM THE-
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES IN
THE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. DO WE
HAVE FOR A MISTER QUANT THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR PRESIDENT.
AND ADMINISTRATION IT CALLOUSLY
A AVAILABLE. YES GOOD MORNING-
MISTER CHAIR MORE MEMBERS HELLO
MY NAME'S CARLOS WHAT I AM MEANT
TO BE DEPUTY SECRETARY BUDGET
MINISTRATION. CALIFORNIA STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY.
PERSONABLE I. WITH ME HERE I'M
NOT A CHIEF DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
BROWN TRYING TO CHAT AT THE SAME
AND SENIOR ADVISER JOBS GIVEN US
YOU TO HELP ANSWER QUESTIONS.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO SOME OF
THE LARGEST CARGO PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY. PART OF THE LARGEST
PARTS OF LONG BEACH MOVE ROUGHLY
35% OF ALL CONTAINERS IN THE
UNITED STATES. APPROXIMATELY 40%
OF US IMPORTS AND 25% OF THE
NATION'S EXPORTS TO THE SAN
PEDRO BAY. OUR REPORTERS. MAJOR
DISTRIBUTION CHALLENGES. SUCH AS
CONTAINER OVERCROWDING A
QUARTERFINALS. EQUIPMENT
SHORTAGES AND HISTORIC NOT A
PART OF US. UNIVISION DRIVERS AT
LEAST THIRTEEN INCLUDING A LACK
OF DETAIL CARVING CENTER PICKUP
SCHEDULE ABSOLUTELY AS
CANCELLATIONS AND I'M REPRESSED
NATIONS RAILROAD OPERATORS HAVE
ALSO BEEN IMPACTED BY A CERTAIN
CARD. SHOULD BE TELLS. THE
SUPPLY CHAIN BROWN ARE GOING TO
BUSINESS IN CALL OF CONSUMERS
AND BUSINESSES INTERNET
IMPACTING THE ENVIRONMENT. TO
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
UNPRECEDENTED INVESTMENTS AT THE
STATE LEVEL THE LEVELS AVAILABLE
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT IN
JOBS ACT TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
SUPPLY CHAIN. STRUCTURE
STRUCTURE INVESTMENT JOBS ACT
MAKES SEVENTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE FOR PARKS AND
WALKWAYS. FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE FOR FREIGHT RAIL. THE
REQUESTED ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENT OF ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS OVER TWO YEARS
TO LEVERAGE OUR FEDERAL FUNDING
TO UPGRADE OUR SUPPLY CHAIN
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT A MORE
EFFICIENT. SUSTAINABLE AND
RESILIENT GOODS MOVEMENT SYSTEM
THAT REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND CONSIDERS
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS TO
COMMUNITIES. MORE SPECIFICALLY
THE REQUESTED FUNDING WILL BE
USED A HIGH PRIORITY FOR RELATED
PROJECTS THAT INCREASE BECAUSE
MOVING PAST THE- HUNDRED ON
ROADWAYS AND CERTAIN PORTS AND
IMPORTANT ROLES INCLUDING REAL
REGARDING SANCTIONS. BRIDGET AND
ZERO EMISSION MODERNIZATION
PROJECTS. THIS MONEY WOULD BE
ALLOCATED BY COSTA SEVENTY. OF
THE FUNDING ORANGE IMPRESSION
PARTNERS SUPPORTING GOOD
MOVEMENT RELATED TO THE PARTS OF
ALABAMA BEACH. AND 30% OTHER
HIGH PRIORITY PROJECTS
SUPPORTING PARTS OF HIS MOVEMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE REST OF
THE STATE INCLUDING. ARTS WE
BELIEVE THIS ALLOCATION CLOSELY
ALIGNED WITH THE ACTUAL
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. AND
REFLECTS DOMINANT NATURE OF
BELLY AND LONG BEACH AND A LOT
OF SPORTS. THE WHITE HOUSE
MOVEMENT. ALSO WILL WORK WITH.
DEVELOP ARE OR- WELL THE
GUIDELINES ARE NOT YET CALCIUM
PRIOR INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
ALIGN WITH THE GOALS OUTLINED
THE ADMINISTRATION'S CLIMATE
ACTION PLAN FOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CALIFORNIA
FREIGHT MOBILITY PLAN INCLUDING
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS PROMOTING SOCIAL
EQUITY AND ENHANCING SAFETY.
THAT INCLUDES MY OVERVIEW OF THE
SUPPLY CHAIN RESILIENCY
IMPORTANT PROFESSION PROPOSAL
I'LL NOW TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE LEE SCOTT IDEA BEING
TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF GMP'S
PORTION OF THIS PROPOSAL.
CABALLERO CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBER SOMEBODY WAS THE START
SHE PUNCHED OFFICER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT MOTOR
VEHICLES- REPEATS BEARS ARE
DIRECTORS DEPARTMENT. I CAN'T
MAKE IT UP TO YOU TO TRUST THE
COMMITTEE RIGHT. I CAN PROVIDE
SUCCOR CORPORATE DEAL OF EACH OF
OUR COMPONENTS AND THEN ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
TO GIVE YOU HAVE A QUESTION A
PROPOSAL SUBMITTED BY THE SECTOR
TRANSPORTATION TO SUPPORT. THE
TOP LUXURY. MISTER SCOTT COULD
YOU PUT FOR ONE SECOND.
APLICATIVO UP A NOTCH IN THE
ROOM. WE'VE RETURNED TO A
SITUATION WHERE THE SOUND IS-
SUB PAR AGAIN. ALTHOUGH A LITTLE
CLOSER AS WELL WE'RE JUST THEIR
THEIR- MAKING SOME ADJUSTMENTS
HERE IN THE ROOM JUST PROP.
THANK YOU. IS THAT GONNA TAKE A
COUPLE MINUTES. OKAY THEY'RE
CALLING YOU YOU CAN PROCEED BUT-
JUST TRY TO KEEP YOUR VOICE UP
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE I DON'T
THINK THE PROBLEMS ON HERE AND
THE- OKAY NOT ALL ALL TALK
REALLY LOUD- IT'S DON'T DELUDE
US. ABOUT OKAY IT'S NOT GIVING
US REQUESTING A TOTAL OF FORTY
MILLION TWO AND A HALF
CALIFORNIA'S CAPACITY TO ISSUE A
COMMERCIAL DRIVER'S LICENSES IS
SIMPLY THIS FUNDING INCLUDES
READ A HALF MILLION AND FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TO TWENTY MILLION
AND TEN MILLION ANNUALLY- TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX TO FIND THE
THING COSTS ESTABLISH. DEDICATED
COMMERCIAL CENTERS IN THE
BAY AREA AND NORTHERN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. IN ADDITION THIS
PROPOSAL INCLUDES ONE POINT
FUNDING OF SIX BILLION IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE FISCAL YEAR THE
FUND OVERTIME ON SATURDAY. FOR
LICENSING REGISTRATION EXAMINERS
AND DOZENS ARE SUPPORT STAFF
WHICH WILL BE DIRECTED TO
OFFICES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT HAVE APPOINTMENT WAIT TIMES
IN EXCESS OF. THIRTY DAYS. IT
WILL ALSO FUND ASSOCIATED TRAVEL
COSTS FOR STAFF AND FACILITIES
BIRTH. WHAT THAT MISTER OUT
RAPIDLY ANSWER ANY PERTAINING TO
REQUEST. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS MR FONG- AND WE NEED
TO HEAR FROM LA- ALSO MAYBE.
THEY MIGHT ANSWER QUESTIONS SO.
YEAH SORRY ABOUT THAT WELCOME.
THANK YOU CHAIR EUNICE ROW AT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND WE HAVE SEVERAL COMMENTS ON
BOTH THAT PROPOSALS FOR THE
SUPPLY CHAIN INFRASTRUCTURE
ANTHER CAL SAYS WELL AS THE
PROPOSAL FOR THE COMMERCIAL
DRIVER'S LICENSES UNDER THE DMV
- THE AGENDA HOUSE SUMMARIZES
MOST OF OUR COMMENTS I'LL JUST
FOCUS ON SOME OF THE KEY ISSUES
WE RAISED. OUR WITH REGARDS TO
THE ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL FOR THIS.
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL UNDER
CONSTANT. THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER SEVERAL ISSUES
AND MODIFY THE PROPOSAL SO IT
BEST ADDRESSES ITS PRIORITIES.
FIRST THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT
TO CONSIDER THE ROLE OF THE
STATE- AS- AS ADMINISTRATION
MENTIONED THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
REPRESENT A SIGNIFICANT A ONE
TIME INCREASE IN STATE FUNDING
FOR GOODS MOVEMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE LEGISLATURE
WILL WANT TO CONSIDER WHAT THE
ROLE STATE'S ROLE IS IN
SUPPORTING- AND MAINTAINING
THESE TYPES OF INFRASTRUCTURE.
AS A GIVEN JUST A NUMBER OF
OTHER ENTITIES THAT ARE
INVOLVED- SUCH AS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PORT AUTHORITY IS IN
FOR A ROLL IT COMPANIES. AND IN
ADDITION THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER WHAT THE
PRIMARY GOALS OF THE FUNDING
SHOULD BE- IN ADDITION TO
INCREASING GOODS MOVEMENT
CAPACITY. THAT'S PROPOSAL IS
INTENDED TO MEET SEVERAL OTHER
GOALS- ACCORDING TO TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AT INCLUDING REDUCING
GHG ADMISSIONS- IN PROMOTING
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY- THE
LEGISLATURE WANT TO CONSIDER
WHETHER THE SCHOOLS REFLECT ITS
PRIORITIES I'M AND- GIVEN THE
LIMITED IMPLEMENTATION DETAILS
TO LET MINISTRATION HAS PROVIDED
IF ANY ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE FUNDING WILL BE
ALLOCATED TO BEST MEET. THESE
GOALS. AT THE LEGISLATURE MAY
ALSO WANT TO CONSIDER THE
PROGRAM THROUGH WHICH THE
FUNDING IS ALLOCATED THREO-
FUNDING IS CURRENTLY PROPOSED TO
BE ALLOCATED THROUGH A NEW
PROGRAM UNDER CAL STEP BY EITHER
EXISTING PROGRAMS FUND SIMILAR
PROJECTS. AND COULD BE USED TO
ALLOCATE THE PROPOSED FUNDING.
AT THE LEGISLATURE WILL WANT TO
CONSIDER THE MERITS AND TRADE
OFFS OF PROVIDING FUNDING FOR A
NEW OR EXISTING PROGRAM. FOR
EXAMPLE PROVIDING FUNDING
THROUGH AN EXISTING PROGRAM
MIGHT LEAD TO FASTER
IMPLEMENTATION- AT EVEN IF SOME
EXISTING GUIDELINES MAY. NEED TO
BE CHANGED BUT ALTERNATELY A NEW
PROGRAM MIGHT BE NEEDED IF AND
THE INTENDED GOALS OR THE TYPES
OF PROJECTS THAT ARE SHOULD BE
PRIORITISED DIFFER SIGNIFICANTLY
FROM THE EXISTING PROGRAM.
ANOTHER ISSUE TO CONSIDER IS THE
GEOGRAPHIC DISTRIBUTION OF THE
FUNDING AT AS PROPOSED 70% OF
THE FUNDING IS DEDICATED TO
PROJECTS AT THE PORTS OF LOS
ANGELES AND LONG BEACH. BECAUSE
THE MAJORITY OF THE GOODS
MOVEMENT IN THE STATE AB OCCURS
IN THIS REGION. HOWEVER THE
LEGISLATURE ALSO MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER THE NEEDS OF PORTS AND
PORT INFRASTRUCTURE STATEWIDE TO
ENSURE THE NEEDS OF SMALLER
INLAND PORTS ARE ALSO- MET WITH
THE AVAILABLE FUNDING- AND
FINALLY AT- DELICIOUS. THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
IT A REQUIREMENT CAL STATE TO
REPORT. THE FUNDING OUTCOMES AND
ON GOING NEEDS OF IN THE GOODS
MOVE INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION WOULD
HELP THE LEGISLATURE DETERMINE
WHETHER ANY ADDITIONAL STATE
FUNDING IS NECESSARY I'M IN THE
FUTURE- WITH REGARDS TO THE DMV
PROPOSAL- WE HAVE TWO
RECOMMENDATIONS- FIRST WE
RECOMMEND THE PROPOSAL BE FUNDED
THROUGH THE NBA AND INSTEAD OF
THE GENERAL FUND AT THE COSTS
ARE ASSOCIATED. AT BUT THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS PROPOSAL
ARE DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE
PROCESSING OF COMMERCIAL DRIVE
TESTS WHICH THE STATE COLLECTS A
FEE TO SUPPORT. AND SECOND WE
RECOMMEND- TO REQUIRE ONGOING
FUND REPORTING TO GET A BETTER
SENSE OF WHETHER INCREASED WAIT
TIMES FOR COMMERCIAL DRIVE TEST
WILL BE AN ONGOING OR ONE TIME
ISSUE- ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON
THE DEMAND FOR COMMERCIAL DRIVER
LICENSES WOULD ALLOW. THE
LEGISLATURE TO DETERMINE IF- ONE
ON GOING FUNDING FOR A
COMMERCIAL DRIVE TEST CENTRES IS
NEEDED BEYOND TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX. AND THAT CONCLUDES
MY COMMENTS WERE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE
ANYTHING TO HIDE. APPARENTLY
NOT- MR PONG. BUT I THINK THIS
CHAIR- IN WITH THE WITH THE
GUARDS TO THE FUNDING TO ADDRESS
THE SUPPLY CHAIN CONGESTION
CERTAINLY THERE'S A LOT OF-
INVESTMENT THAT IS GOING THROUGH
MULTIPLE AGENCIES CAN YOU SHED
SOME LIGHT ON HOW THE
COORDINATION IS WORKING WITHIN
THE AGENCIES WHO'S GONNA BE THE
AGENCY OR THE LEAD AGENCY TO
CONTACT THE STAKEHOLDERS SUPPLY
CHAIN TO ENSURE THAT THE
RESOURCES SPENT- IN A WAY THAT.
RELIEVES CONGESTION AND ACTUALLY
HARDENS IS A PROJECT. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION MR FONG. OF
SOME OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL REALLY INTO AFRICA ALSO
TO SERVE AS THE LEAD AGENCY IN
COORDINATING ISSUES RELATED TO
SUPPLY CHAIN IMPORT ANIMAL THE
NEXT ITEM ON OUR AGENDA RIGHT
NOW TO WILL BE DISCUSSING IS
ACTUAL ACTUALLY CONTAINS A
BROADER RESOURCE REQUESTS FROM
THE AGENCY- TO ESTABLISH A-
SUPPLY CHAIN AND- AFRAID POLICY.
OVERSIGHT TEAM AND SO- YOU KNOW
THE PURPOSE OF THAT IS REALLY TO
HELP COORDINATE BETTER
COORDINATE- YOU KNOW THE END
RESULT FRAZIER PLACING.ISSUES-
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION. THIS
US OF CAL'S IS THE LEAD AGENCY.
HOW DOES GOBIZ INTERACT WITH
THAT SAYS IT SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF
RESOURCES AND A LOT OF THE
POLICY DECISIONS ARE BEING GOING
TO COPE IS. HOW HOW IS THAT
COORDINATION OCCURRING. ONE
HUNDRED OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE-
GILES GYMNASTICS. SIR JOHNSON
NOT EASY ADVISER CALLAS DE THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SO WE MAKE
FOR LAST YEAR LISA LAST YEAR WE
REPORTED A VERY CLOSE IN THE
KOBE IS- WE'VE WORKED WITH THEM
ON THEIR SUPPLY CHAIN SUCCESS
INITIATIVE WE WERE PARTNER-
WOULD THAT WAS PUT. TOGETHER BY
GOBIZ IN CALLOUSED AND CSU LONG
BEACH IN THE PORT OF LONG BEACH
THE KIND OF EXPORT FROM POLICY
ISSUES WE ARE NOW IN THE PROCESS
THIS MONTH OF CERTAIN ABLE
STEPPING OUT AND KIND OF WORKING
ACCORDING ALREADY COORDINATING
WITH LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS GOVERNMENTS FRESNO
COG. ALL WILL BE WORKING WITH
MTC REPORT OF- PORT OF OAKLAND
AND IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA DO A
SERIES OF LISTENING SESSIONS TO
GET INPUT ON ON OUR TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND ALSO ADDITIONAL
INPUT ON DEVELOPING GUIDELINES
FOR PROGRAM SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE- SEE FIT TO- TO- TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL GOLD IS HAS
BEEN VERY INVOLVED WITH US IN
TERMS OF IN TERMS OF.
COORDINATING THESE LISTENING
SESSIONS THEY'VE BEEN PART OF
OUR KIND OF COMMITTEE TO- TO-
TO- TO. PUT TOGETHER THE H. AND
SO AND PARTY. TO GIVE US GIVEN
THE LISTINGS. IN WE WILL.
CONTINUE TO COORDINATE VERY
CLOSELY WITH THEM WITH THEM
THROUGHOUT- THROUGHOUT
THROUGHOUT TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF
ANY CRITERIA OR GUIDELINES. FOR
THIS PROGRAM SIR OKAY. SO JUST
TO BE CLEAR CALLOUS THAT IS THE
LEAD AGENCY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
SUPPLY CHAIN POLICIES FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION. YES OKAY- AND SO
IN IN IN A LOT OF THAT- THE
GOVERNOR I BELIEVE- WHAT HE DID
SIGN AN EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
ALLEVIATE THE SUPPLY CHAIN
CONGESTION THE CONGESTION AND
THEN HE IDENTIFIED. SURPLUS
PROPERTY- FOR ADDITIONAL
CONTAINER STORAGE- WHAT IS THE
LATEST ON THAT. CAN YOU CAN YOU
SHED SOME LIGHT ON THAT. SO
CERTAINLY DGS IS THE LEAD AGENCY
IN TERMS OF COORDINATING THE
ESTATE OWNED PROPERTIES FOR
CONTAINERS AS I UNDERSTAND WE
CAN FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR STAFF-
FOR MORE DETAILS BUT I THINK
THEY IDENTIFIED SIX- THERE USING
A THIRD PARTY- JUNKER AND
THEY'VE IDENTIFIED I THINK SIX
SIX STATE OWNED PROPERTIES- BUT
THAT'S ALL THE DETAIL I HAVE AT
THIS TIME BUT- WE CAN WE CAN
FOLLOW THE DGS. SO I HAVE TO SAY
THIS YOU AT THE PREVIOUS
QUESTION YOU SAID. YOU'RE THE
LEAD AGENCY ON SUPPLY CHAIN. YOU
JUST SAID NOW DGS IS THE LEAD
AGENCY ON THIS- CONTAINER
STORAGE- PROPOSAL TO ALLEVIATE
THE PLEDGING CONGESTION SO WHO
IS THE LEAD AGENCY. SO SIR DO
OUT OF THE- THROUGHOUT
DETERMINES. AFTER THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED EXECUTIVE ORDER AND
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE- THERE WAS A
MULTI AGENCY TASK FORCE THAT WAS
TASKED WITH KIND OF LOOKING AT
NEAR TERM. AND LONG TERM
OPERATIONAL ISSUES- THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HAD BEEN DOING
THE COORDINATION- THROUGH IT TO
A MULTI AGENCY TASK FORCE IN
WHICH CALTRANS HAD LEADERSHIP
ROLES RIGHT IN WHICH THAT HOUSE
THAT HAD A LEADERSHIP ROLE- BUT-
CERTAIN AGENCIES WITH DIFFERENT
SPECIALIZATIONS. WERE GIVEN
DIFFERENT- ASSIGNED SPECIFIC
RESPONSIBILITIESWITH REGARD TO-
WITH REGARD TO THE THROUGH THE
SECOND QUARTER GUARD SPECIFIC
FUNCTIONS AND STATE OWNED
PROPERTIES- WAS ASSIGNED TO A D.
G. S. JUST BECAUSE OF THEIR OF
THEIR- THE ROLE OF GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTING AND- ALLEN ST IN
STATE PROPERTIES. A SO THEN WHO
ARE KALISTO ISN'T. OF
COORDINATING ALL THIS IS IT IS
IT THE DIRECTOR. THOUGHTLESSNESS
THE SECRETARY'S BEEN ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN ALL THIS IS A HIDDEN
AND IS THE EXECUTIVE. MANAGEMENT
TEAM- THE UNDERSECRETARY MYSELF-
SO OKAY I'M I'M NOT I'M NOT
MAKING I'M NOT TRYING TO BE
DIFFICULT I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THAT I THINK THIS IS
THE CHALLENGE I THINK WITH THE
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUE IS THAT. WHEN
THERE'S A LOT AGENCIES INVOLVED
IN AYE I'LL AYE DEADLY STIPULATE
THAT BIG BIG THE CONCERN I HAVE
RIGHT NOW IS THAT AS YOU JUST
OUTLINED IN OUR INTERACTION IS
AT THE CORE NATION IS VERY
IMPORTANT. AND SO IF THE LEFT
AND THE RIGHT HANDER THAN WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AND SO IF CALCITE
IS THE LEAD AGENCY. AND THE
SECRETARY IS THE ONE
COORDINATING THEN EVERYTHING
SHOULD FLOW TO THAT. AGENCY SO
IF WERE TOUTING. A NO THERE IS
DEFINITELY A NEED FOR THESE THE
SURPLUS PROPERTY AND WE'RE
MAKING INVESTMENTS INLAND PORTS
AND WE'RE MAKING INVESTMENTS IN
THE PORT OF LA IN THE PORT OF
LONG BEACH. SOMEONE'S GONNA KNOW
AND COORDINATE ALL THAT AND SO
IT DGS IS NOW IN CHARGE OF THE
SURPLUS- LAND POLICY. AND A YEAR
IN CHARGE OF THE OF THE OF THE
INVESTMENTS IN THE PORT AND
GOBIZ IS NOW IN CHARGE OF-
ACCORDING TO THE- THE FREIGHT
AND THE EXPORT POLICY OF THE
STATE CALIFORNIA. IT'S GOING TO
FLOW SOMEWHERE. AND SO I'M JUST
ASKING WHO THE AIR TRAFFIC
CONTROLLER IS IF ALL THIS IS
HAPPENING BECAUSE WE'RE
INVESTING A LOT OF MONEY INTO
THIS AND I BELIEVE WE NEED TO
MAKE THOSE INVESTMENTS- NOW TO-
TO THE- PORT SPECIFIC PROJECTS-
HAVE. IS THERE ARE THOSE
PROJECTS FORTY OUTLINED DO YOU
HAVE A LIST OF PROJECTS THAT
ALREADY IN THE DOCKET WAITING TO
GO. WHAT ARE THOSE PROJECTS. SO
SIR- WE WHAT THE WAY WE WOULDN'T
GO ABOUT AS WE TRIED TO PUT OUT
A CALL FOR PROJECTS AS SOON AS
WE WERE AWARDED FUNDING- WHY ARE
WE ANTICIPATED THAT A NUMBER OF
PROJECTS THAT WOULD COME
FORWARD- WOULD PROBABLY BE IN
THE CALIFORNIA FREIGHT MOBILITY
PLAN. WHICH IS A PLAN THAT
OUTLINES VARIOUS PROJECTS FOR A
FOR A FEDERAL INVESTMENT. BUT IN
ADDITION TO THAT AND WERE AGAIN
ABOUT TO EMBARK ON A NUMBER OF
LISTENING SESSIONS WHERE WITH.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PARTNERS AND WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THEY ARE BAY
MORTY TAKEN WOMEN WE KNOW THAT
THEY'VE ALREADY TAKEN A CLOSE
LOOK AT OUR TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE- THE GOALS THAT. WE'VE
OUTLINED IN OUR TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE- AS WELL AS THE NOTICES
OF FUNDING OPPORTUNITY THEM THAT
APPETITE FOR BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BY U. S. DOT FOR
VARIOUS GRANT PROGRAMS. THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO LEVERAGE AND-
THEY'VE ALREADY STARTED THINKING
THROUGH AND IDENTIFYING TYPE
PROJECTS THAT THEY MAY WANT TO
COME FORWARD. AND BEEN PUT
FORWARD AS- AS CANDIDATES FOR
FUNDING SO THIS TYPE OF WHAT WE
DON'T HAVE A LIST OF PROJECTS WE
WOULD PUT OUT A CALL FOR
PROJECTS. OFFER COMPETITIVE FOR
COMPETITIVE BID BUT- BUT SAID
THIS TYPE OF THINKING IN THE
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS THAT MIGHT
ALIGN WITH THESE GOALS AS WELL
AS FEDERAL PROGRAMS HAVE SIMILAR
ALREADY BEING DEVELOPED BY SOME
OF THE MAJOR STAKE WASN'T
PUTTING THE POINTS AVAILABLE.
OKAY SO YOU'RE SO THEY'RE GOING
TO HAVE A CALL FOR PROJECTS AND
THEN DEVELOP THAT LIST- THAT
CORRECT. YES SIR OKAY- IN TERMS
OF THE- DATA PORTAL- I THINK
THERE'S THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME. FOR GO VISIT DEVELOP
THAT STATEWIDE DATA PORTAL- THAT
IS COMPATIBLE WITH THE EXISTING
TERMINAL OPERATOR PLATFORMS. SO
HOW DOES THAT INTERACT WITH
WHAT. WHAT YOU'RE DOING. ALL THE
FIRST SOMETHING LIKE IT ALWAYS
AN ALTOGETHER A LITTLE SHOT OF
THAT SO GO VISIT BE THE LEAD ON
DEVELOPING THAT PROGRAM AND
THAT- AND THAT- YOU KNOW
PROCUREMENT OR WHATEVER THEY
WOULD DO THE ONLY THING THAT I
WOULD SAY IS THAT THERE ARE
MULTIPLE EFFORTS THAT THEY CAN
KIND OF LOOK AT THE- TOP WITH GO
BIZ AND COORDINATING WITH THEM
WE WERE ALL WATCHING VARIOUS
FEDERAL EFFORTS THAT ARE GOING
ON AROUND THIS I THINK THERE WAS
A- A U. S. T. O. C. PROPOSAL OUT
BLANK ON THE NAME RIGHT NOW OR
SORRY A- THE PILOT PROGRAM THAT
WAS PUT TOGETHER. A COUPLE OF
WEEKS AGO- THE FEDERAL MARITIME
COMMISSION IS DOING AND I'M
GOING SORT OF FACT FINDING INTO
OF DATA FOR NATION AND SHARING
SO IT'S SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN
WATCHING IT SOMETHING GO
BUSINESS BEEN WATCHING WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT IT WITH THEM
SHARING INFORMATION- BUT AGAIN
GOMEZ WOULD BE OF THE LEAD ON
SORT OF ANY TYPE OF. INFORMATION
SHARING OR PROCUREMENTS OR
ANYTHING THAT WOULD KALRA GO ON. WITH THAT WITH THAT- WITH THAT
PROPOSAL. OKAY THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT- WE HAD- THIS
DISCUSSION IN THE SELECT BOARD'S
COMMITTEE- AT THIS PLATFORM IS
CRITICAL. TO CONNECTING ALL THE
PORTS IT HAS TO BE
INTEROPERABLE- WE NEED FOR A CAR
WELL AS I A FRAMEWORK IN PLACE
SO THAT EVERYONE USES IT. WE GOT
INCLUDE- THE RAIL OPERATORS IN
THE TRUCKING OPERATORS TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS ACTUALLY- GOOD
COORDINATION AND FOLLOW. SO THAT
WE CAN RELIEVE CONGESTION AT THE
PORTS IN. AND MOVE GOODS TO
WHERE IT NEEDS TO GO AND TRACK
THINGS IN REAL TIME- YOU KNOW
YOU'RE USING PHRASES LIKE.
KOBE'S IS THE LEAD IN. AND
AGAIN- I'M I'M- USING YOUR- YOUR
VERNACULAR. IS THAT IF CAL STATE
IS THE LEAD AGENCY. THEN YOU
SHOULD KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING- IF
GOBIZ IS THE LEAD AND- MY AND
EVERYTHING I'M SEEING IS THAT
THE- DIRECTOR OF GO BASIS BEEN
THE PUBLIC FACE OF THE SUPPLY
CHAIN CONGESTION- ISSUE. AND SO.
IF I'M I'M GETTING MIXED SIGNALS
HERE. OF WHO IS ACTUALLY IN
CHARGE- AND AGAIN- MY I AM
DURING THE ADMINISTRATION YOU.
TO DEVELOP THAT'S- THAT
STRUCTURE- SO THAT WHEN WE DO
INVEST. THESE RESOURCES INTO THE
SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS. WHICH HAS
TO BE RESOLVED. THAT THAT.
OCCURS I GUESS MY QUESTION TO
THE L. A. O. IS- YOU IT IN. IN
EUROPE. THAT A LOT OF THESE- THE
INVESTMENTS ARE GOING TO- THAT
ANYMORE DETAILS TO ENSURE THAT
IN IN THE LONG RUN THE SHORT RUN
THAT WE HAVE SOME CHALLENGES
THAT THAT MAY NEED TO- TO BE
FLESHED OUT. HOW IS THE
COORDINATION RIGHT NOW WITHIN
THE SUPPLY CHAIN WITH A
STRUCTURE WITHIN ADMINISTRATION
. I SURE THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION I AM UNITS ARE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. I
THINK IT'S A LOT OF IT IS AN
INFLUX AND THEY THINK THAT'S IN
PART WHY THEY'RE THERE IS KIND
OF THE ADDITIONAL CASH PROPOSAL
FOR UNDER KALISTO TWO FOR THE
FREIGHT POLICY TEAM AND SO. AND
IT DOES SEEM THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE SOME DETERMINATIONS MADE TO
COURTNEY- FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION SIDE AS WELL
ABOUT WHO IS. FACILITATING ALL
OF THE DIFFERENT ENTITIES. HAVE
YOU LOOKED AT THE- THE SURPLUS-
DAN PROPOSAL DO YOU HAVE ANY.
GUIDANCE OR- INPUT ON THAT.
WHICH I PURPOSE THERE THERE WAS
A BUT THERE'S OUT THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER TO- THAT IDENTIFIED
SURPLUS PROPERTY FOR ADDITIONAL
CONTAINER STORAGE HAVE YOU
GOTTEN A CHANCE TO LOOK AT THAT.
AT I WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK TO
YOUR OFFICE ON THAT ONE A
QUESTION OKAY YOUR FIRST BOB
POINT- THAT YOU INDICATED IN
YOUR TESTIMONY IS THAT YOU KNOW
WE HAVE ALLEN WHAT THE STATE
ROLE IS. DO YOU HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION AND WHAT SHOULD
THE STATES WILL BE IN TERMS OF
THE PORT INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPLY
CHAIN CHALLENGES. I MEAN I DON'T
THINK IT'S A IT'S A MATTER OF IT
HOW IT RANKS IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES STRAIGHT SO
HISTORICALLY THE STATE HAS NOT
PLAYED A LARGE ROLE IN
SUPPORTING- INFRASTRUCTURE SO.
INCREASING AND STATE THAT ROLE
BY PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING
WOULD BE SHOWING KIND OF HOW
IMPORTANT SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES
ARE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
CURRENTLY OKAY. OF MY LAST POINT
INTO IT- THE DECALS- IF YOU
COULD PROVIDE ME AN UPDATE ON.
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THE
SURPLUS PROPERTY AT B. THAT
WOULD BE REALLY GREAT AND OF
COURSE IF YOU COULD DEVELOP OR
GIVE PROVIDE ME WITH. THE
LATEST- ACTIONS THAT YOU'VE
TAKEN ON THE SUPPLY CHAIN-
CONGESTION ISSUE I WOULD PUSH
APPRECIATE AN UPDATE. ON THAT.
AS WELL AND WITH THAT I'LL TURN
IT BACK OVER THE- THANK YOU MR
FONG- LET ME- ASK A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION ON THE- THE ISSUE OF
THE LOCATION OF. A CONTAINERS
AND THAT A DETERMINATION OF
SITES- THE THAT WAS DISCUSSED
PREVIOUSLY- HOW ARE YOU GOING
TO- OR IS THERE A PLAN TO AVOID.
LOCATING ALL OF THESE SITES
ADJACENT TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WHICH HAS- UP IN
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
HEARING ABOUT FOR QUITE SOME
TIME- IN THE- AFTERMATH OF THE-
OF PORK EMERGENCY THAT- EMERGE
DURING THE- PANDEMIC- WE KNOW
THAT LOCATIONS HAD TO BE FOUND.
IMMEDIATELY AND QUICKLY FOR-
AFTER ALL THESE ACCESS
CONTAINERS BUT NOW WE HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME TO THINK
ABOUT IT- AND THINK THIS THROUGH
CAREFULLY- HOW ARE YOU GOING
ABOUT DOING THAT. SO AGAIN BUT
CERTAIN YOU NEED YES OUT ILLEGAL
WE HAVE BEEN IN COMMUNICATION
WITH WITH THEM ON THIS BASED ON
WHAT I'VE BEEN TOLD BY THE G. S.
THEY'RE ENTERING INTO- ONE YEAR
LEASES AND THEIR MEETING MONTHLY
WITH THEIR CONTRACT THE THIRD
PART PARTY OPERATOR JUNKER. JUST
RESOLVED- THE TWO DIDN'T RESOLVE
ANY ISSUES THAT MIGHT ARISE OR
TO MONITOR WHAT'S GOING ON A
MIGHT ARISE WITH THE WITH THE
SIZING SELECTED- AND AS I
UNDERSTAND IT AND AGAIN WE WILL
BEGIN CONCORD NAY WITH THE G. S.
AND COME UP WITH A RESPONSE OR
GET ADDITIONAL DATA- BUT THE
SIDES THAT WERE SELECTED. SOME
OF THEM ARE FAIRGROUNDS OR SOME
OF THEM ARE FAIRLY FAIRLY REMOTE
OR ALREADY HEAVILY TRAFFIC
TRAFFIC FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND
BUT WE CAN WE CAN CERTAINLY
COORDINATE WITH DGS TO TRYING
GET A BETTER RESPONSE. I
ABSOLUTELY THINK THAT YOU SHOULD
pBE DOING THAT- THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE RECEIVED A LOT OF
FEEDBACK ON AND- I WOULD THINK
THAT- YOU'VE PROBABLY HEARD SOME
OF THAT TOO AND- AGAIN- THE-
JUST- RELATING BACK TO- OF MR
FONG. SAID- COMMENTS. OUR OUR
OUR OUR- IT IS QUESTION. ASK
HAVE YOU OR SHOULD WE BASS IT OF
. THE LEAD AGENCY WE WILL
COORDINATE AND GET BACK TO YOU.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT. THE
OF PROPOSAL ADDRESSES LONG TERM
INFRASTRUCTURE- DOES THE
PROPOSAL ADDRESS IMMEDIATE
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES AS WELL. SO
SERVE UNDER EXECUTIVE- ORDER AND
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE- THERE WAS A
MULTI- INTERGOVERNMENTAL TASK
FORCE THAT ADDRESS BOTH SHORT
TERM AND- A NUMBER OF SHORT TERM
STEPS YOU WOULD YOU WOULD
MENTION STATE OWNED FACILITIES
FOR CONTAINER YARDS AND THEIR
NUMBER OF OTHER SHORT TERM
ACTIONS THAT THAT THAT THE STATE
TOOK- ANYTHING CAN TO CONTINUING
TO TAKE. INCLUDING INCREASING
CAPACITY I THINK BMB BASICALLY
DOUBLE THE CAPACITY FOR
COMMERCIAL DRIVER'S LICENSES IN
THE SHORT TERM- THERE BEEN
INCREASES OF CALTRANS IT
INCREASED- TRUCK WAITS FOR
SHE'LL CONTAINERS FROM PORTS TO
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS SO THESE
ARE EXAMPLES OF- THE KINDS OF
SHORT TERM ACTIONS THAT THE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS. TAKEN
UNDER THE EXECUTIVE ORDER. SO I
AM THERE'S ENOUGH OF METRICS-
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT LIKE HOW
MANY SHIPS ARE IN TRANSIT HOW
MANY HERE ANCHORED- OFF OF- OF
THE PORTS HW MANY CONTAINERS
ARE SITTING EMPTY- YOU KNOW
THINGS LIKE THAT IS THERE A- A
WEBSITE THAT ONE CAN GO TO- VIEW
THOSE. METRICS AND HOW THEY'RE
CHANGING IN REAL TIME IT. SEEMS
TO ME THAT THAT WAS THE VERY
USEFUL. ALSO I KNOW THAT THE
WATER SO WE HAVE BEEN TRACKING
THAT TYPE OF DATA AND OF COURSE
AND THINGS LIKE THAT THE- SHIPS
AT ANCHOR OUTSIDE THE SAN PEDRO
BAY HAVE GONE DOWN DRAMATICALLY
SINCE THE FALL I CAN BLAST
CINEMATICS I SAW WAS. FROM THE
DOZENS THAT WE WERE SEEING THAT
WE'RE SEEING LAST FALL TO. YOUR
ADAM TWO WEEKS AGO I THINK WAS
LIKE FOUR FOUR SHIPS ANCHORED
THERE BUT ALL THE POLICIES OF
AND PUT IN PLACE TO SORT OF-
SLOW STEAMING TIME ETCETERA BUT-
A LOT OF THAT SO WHY DON'T WE
SEE METRICS LIKE THAT WE TRACK
METRICS LIKE THAT I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THE STATE IS
PUTTING OUT A PUBLIC. I HAVE A
PUBLIC PORTAL AND I KNOW THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THROUGH THE
WHITE HOUSE SUPPLY CHAIN DOT
TASK FORCE HAS BEEN I THINK
EITHER BI WEEKLY OR MONTHLY BEEN
PUTTING OUT SOME OF THE
STATISTICS THERE HAVE BEEN THERE
HAS BEEN A- SIGNIFICANT DROP IN-
CONTAINERS. UNDER CONTAINERS AT
THE PORTS OF LA AND LONG BEACH
HAVE BEEN TRACKED SO I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE PUBLIC FACING WEBSITES
OR BLOGS PARTICULAR ON THE
FEDERAL SIDE THEY'RE SORT
TRACKING THESE METRICS- AND THEN
AND WE'VE BEEN WE'VE BEEN ALSO.
THE TRUMP TRACKING CERTAIN
THINGS AS WELL AND MAY BE. ABLE
TO PROVIDE YOU SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION. THANK YOU AND THEN-
HAVE. FOR THE- DA- WHAT ARE THE-
WHAT IS THE A CURRENT BACKLOG
FOR A COMMERCIAL DRIVER'S
LICENSE. LICENSES AND- IS THIS
JUST SORT OF GENERALLY SPREAD
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. OR THEY
CONCENTRATED IN CERTAIN AREAS-
CHAIRMAN OF THIS IS US STEVE
GARDEN DEPARTMENT MOTOR VEHICLES
DIRECTOR IT MORE OUT EIGHT GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU FOR HAVING US
HERE. YEAH THE DISTRIBUTION IS
ACROSS THE STATE BUT I WILL SAY
THAT WE HAVE FOR WILL CALLMEGA
CENTERS THAT ARE YOU KNOW THREE
WHICH ARE LOCATED IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THEY DO MOST OF THE
TESTING SO EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
BACKLOG HAD AT VARIOUS CENTERS.
YEAH MOST OF THE OPPORTUNITY IS
DOWN IN THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AREA RANGING FROM CARL FONTANA
TO GARDENIA AS TO OF COURSE UP
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND FRESNO
AND BAKERSFIELD AREA AS WELL. SO
THE DISTRIBUTION IS ACROSS THE
STATE ALTHOUGH MOST OF THEM SAY
FOR NORTH LA ARE YOU WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS AND WE'RE WORKING
VERY AGGRESSIVELY WITH OVERTIME
AND STAFF REDISTRIBUTION AND
REALLY THE QUESTIONS WITH THE
TRUCKING COMPANIES TO KEEP THOSE
NUMBERS- YOU'LL UNDER CONTROL
AND WE HAVE TO GET YOU
SPECIFICS. HOUSES BY REGION
WHICH I THINK WE PUBLISH AB I
WILL MAKE SURE AGAINST YOUR
STAFF. THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS MISTER. SMITH AND THEN
MR PATTERSON. ALL RIGHT IF YOU
MIND MISTER SMITH MISTER PATTON
HAS A FULL UP ON. FOR YOU MISTER
JORDAN- I LIKE I'D LIKE TO. HAVE
THE NUMBERS OF THE BACKLOGS IN
FRESNO. PLEASE YES SIR I CAN
COMPLETE. RIGHT MISTER SMITH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN
REGARDS TO THE ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE SPORT.
IT'S A SEVENTY THIRTY SPLIT. OUT
OF THAT THIRTY PERCENT. SO IT'S
GOING TO THE REST OF THE STATE
BUT IT DOES SAY INLAND PORT AND
I WAS WONDERING IF THERE'S A SET
ASIDE A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE GOING
TO INLAND PORTS. I THINK I USE
THAT IS COMPETITIVE BIDDING. SO
I WANNA MAKE SURE THE INLAND
PORTS CAN BE COMPETITIVE TO
OAKLAND OR OTHER COASTAL
COMMUNITIES UP FOR THOSE
PROJECTS ELECTIONS. AND CAN YOU
CLARIFY. SO SIR- I DON'T THINK
IT'S A SPECIFIC SET ASIDE FOR
INLAND PORTS BUT WE'RE ACTIVELY-
THEY CAN BE WOULD COME IN THE
3230% FROM THE REST OF THE STATE
AND WE'RE ACTIVELY. TALKING WITH
WITH STAKEHOLDERS IN A KIND OF
PUT FORWARD CONCEPTS RENDON
FORTS INCLUDING- FRESNO THE
FRESNO COG- AND WE'RE GOING TO
BE HAVING UP. A LISTENING
SESSION IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WITH FRESNO COG. SORT OF TALK
ABOUT THIS CONCEPT IN ANY OTHER
CONCEPTS TO COME FORWARD- IN IN
IN THAT IN THAT REGION. YOU MAKE
SURE OF MY STAFF IS AWARE OF
THOSE MEETINGS SO WE CAN BE A
PART OF IT BECAUSE WE HAVE A BIG
PROJECT IN MY DISTRICT. THE DAY
SPENT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. GOING
FORWARD AND WE NEED SOME MORE A
LITTLE BIT MORE MONEY TO FINISH
UP THE PROJECT. YES SIR THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WELL I THINK
WE'RE GONNA. MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO NOW. AND BEFORE WE DO
OF MISTER BENNETT AS A QUESTION
JEFF AND I WILL TAKE ROLE AND
THEN MOVE ON THE ISSUE TODAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JUST JUST
ONE QUICK QUESTION I. IT THAT
THIS QUESTION THAT. CERTAINLY
RELATE TO THE ENERGY COMMISSION
ANOTHER'S- BUT- I JUST WANTED TO
GET YOUR PERSPECTIVE IN TERMS OF
THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED BY THE PORCH. ABOUT
WHETHER THE ELECTRICAL GRID CAN
HANDLE- AND HOW FAST IT CAN BE.
ABLE TO HANDLE ALTHOUGH THE
ELECTRIFICATION NEEDS OF THE
PORTS IN TERMS OF IF
INFRASTRUCTURE HAVE ANY INSIGHTS
ON THAT I KNOW THERE ARE OTHERS
THAT ARE. THANKS SIGNIFICANT
ROLES IN THIS QUESTION. WE
ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER
FOR THAT- IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE
BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO GET BACK TO
YOU IN YOUR STUFF. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL TAKE ROLE AND
THEN WE HAVE- THE A VOTE ON THE
CALENDAR. HELLO HERE SENATE.
FRIEDMAN MULLIN PATTERSON AIR
RIVAS SMITH THERE. WE HAVE A
ONLY ONE VOTE ONLY ISSUE TODAY
BUT TO- WE CAN VOTE ON THAT. IS
OUR MOTION. THANK YOU LOCAL WHEN
HI SENATE FRIEDMAN ONE PATTERSON
RIVAS SMITH. THANK YOU NOW ON TO
ISSUE. TO I BELIEVE- DEPUTY
DIRECTOR QUITE YOU'RE GONNA- OF
PRESENT ON THAT IS THAT CORRECT
. YES SIR- SEPARATIST REPUBLICAN
ALSO REQUEST THREE POSITIONS IN
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT TWO
MILLION ON GOING TO ESTABLISH AN
AGENCY LEVEL FREE POLICY TEAM AT
BASELINE BUDGET FOR
TRANSPORTATION RESEARCH PROJECTS
AND THE SUPPORT INCREASE RENT
COSTS- BRIEFLY GO OVER EACH
COMPONENT OF OUR PROPOSAL
BEGINNING WITH THE REQUEST TO
ESTABLISH AN AGENCY LEVEL THREE.
TEAM AGENCY LEVEL RESOURCES ARE
NECESSARY TO OVERSEE AND
COORDINATE FRAME POLICY ACROSS
THE STATE. EXISTING STRUCTURE
FOR QUALITY OVERSIGHT IS
FRAGMENTED AND INCLUDES SEVERAL
STATE AGENCIES INCLUDING
CALTRANS BILL BASED CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD EACH WITH
DIFFERENT RESPONSIBILITIES
RELATED AFRAID POLICY OVERSIGHT.
UNDER THE CURRENT STRUCTURE THE
STATE IS NOT HAVING OVERSIGHT
AGENCY RECORDED A COMPREHENSIVE
RESPONSE TO ADDRESS. EMERGING
FREIGHT INDUSTRY ISSUES. THE
PROPOSAL ESTABLISH AFRAID PAUL
TEAM TO STRATEGIC LEAVING.
MINISTRY CALL DEVELOP. THE
SUPPORTER NOT MAKE HIM. NEST
SENATE BILL HOW MULTI MODAL
THREE. SECTOR THESE RESOURCES
WILL PLACE ROLE IN WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE LOCAL STAY
FEDERAL AND SECTOR TO ADDRESS
URGENT AND EMERGING ISSUES
AFFECTING THE PHRASE SECTORS
APPOINTING. THE NEXT IN LINE OF
THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES A REQUEST
TO ESTABLISH AN ANNUAL
TRANSPORTATION RESEARCH BY A
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
BURKE ALSO CONNECT TO CONDUCT
HIGH PRIORITY TRANSPORTATION
RESEARCH PROJECTS.
TRANSPORTATION SEARCHES CRITICAL
INFORMED TRANSPORTATION POLICY.
BECAUSE IT IS NOT CURRENTLY HAVE
A BUDGET FOR RESEARCH AND MUST
RELY ON ITS DEPARTMENTS TO
CONTRIBUTE FUNDING TO CONDUCT
AGENCY LED RESEARCH PROJECTS.
LIMITED FUNDING AVAILABLE. THIS
FUNDING IS NECESSARY TO PROVIDE
ACOSTA WITH READILY AVAILABLE
RESOURCES TO CONDUCT RESEARCH
NECESSARY TO MITIGATE URGENT AND
EMERGING ISSUES AFFECTING THE
SUPPLY CHAIN THE FULL BILL
LEGISLATIVE REQUIREMENTS AND
SUPPORT ADMINISTRATIONS
PRIORITIES. FILE COMPONENTS
PROPOSAL INCLUDES A REQUEST FOR
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THE FUNDING
INCREASE RENT COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH HOUSES RELOCATION THE
GENERAL BUILDING. THOUSANDS WORK
OF THE DEPARTMENT GENERAL
SERVICES. A LEASE FOR A NEW
OFFICE SPACE. CURRENTLY WE
ANTICIPATE MOVING INTO OUR NEW
OFFICE SPACE BY JUNE OF THIS
YEAR. AT THE TIME I HOMES ARE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
RELATED TO THIS PROPOSAL. THANK
YOU ALEJO MISS ROW TO HAVE
COMMENTS. AT YES THAT UNITS ROAD
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WE HAVE NO ISSUES WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IT'S BEEN
PUBLIC DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
NOTHING TO ADD HERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THEIR
QUESTIONS MR FONG. I THANK YOU
AS CHAIR I HATE TO SOUND LIKE A
BROKEN RECORD BUT- WITH THIS NEW
PROPOSAL THERE IS A FREE
COORDINATOR AND GOBIZ SO HOW
DOES THAT HOW DO THOSE TWO
INTERACT. THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES WOULD WORK TO
COORDINATE ALL OF THE ISSUES
ACROSS ALL THE AGENCIES THAT
HAVE ANY SORT OF ROLE IN
OVERSEEING THE FREIGHT RIGHT NOW
ALL SEE AND STATE. SO- YOU KNOW
WHEN WE BELIEVE IN THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES WELL
SUITED TO FILL THIS ROLE AS THE
AGENCY RESPONSIBLE FOR
COORDINATING ALL THE OVERSIGHT
FOR TRANSPORTATION ISSUES. SO IS
THERE DUPLICATION OR- WOMAN
WOULD YOU JUST. WOULD WOULD YOU
ROLL THE GOBIZ POSITION INTO
THIS. INTO THIS- FRAMEWORK OR
INTO THIS- THIS ENTITY SERVER
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
COORDINATE VERY CLOSELY WITH
KOBE'S AND WE'VE HAD A VERY
STRONG PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM WE
FEEL I GO BACK I MEAN CLEARLY WE
WOULD NEED THAT THEY BRING
DIFFERENT THINGS TO THE TABLE
THAT WE WOULD WANT TO HAVE TO
INCLUDE THEM IN ON YOU KNOW
THINGS WE'RE DOING WITH OUR
COURT WAY FOR NATION FOR EXAMPLE
OF RELATIONSHIPS I MEAN I THINK
IT'S SPRING TO CAL STATE HAS IS
THAT WE OVERSEE DEPARTMENTS. THE
DIRECTLY OPERATED SECTIONS OF
THE SUPPLY CHAIN INCLUDING
CALTRANS CALIFORNIA PARTNER
TRANSPORTATION OPERATE STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM WHICH IS THE
BACKBONE YOU HAVE A DEPARTMENT
OF VEHICLES WHICH IS HERE WITH
US TODAY WHICH DOES A LOT OF
LICENSING REGULATION OF A
VARIOUS ASPECTS OF THE SUPPLY
CHAIN SO THAT I THINK WE'RE WELL
POSITIONED TO KIND OF HAVE THIS
TYPE OF ROLE BUT THEN GOBIZ ALSO
HAS RELATIONSHIPS WITH PRIVATE
SECTOR BUSINESSES RETAILERS FOR
EXAMPLE I MEAN BIG VCOS
RETAILERS- YOU KNOW WE NEED
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS AND THEY
DEAL WITH THEM ON ON A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT- IN A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT VENUES NOT JUST NOT
JUST A SUPPLY CHAIN SO. WE WOULD
CONTINUE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH GO
BIZ AS WE HAVE A FOR THE LAST
YEAR OR SO AND- AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM IN
VALUE IN A PARTNERSHIP. OKAY MY
LOOK I NOT AS A- I. THAT THIS I
. IT IS NECESSARY I'M JUST. WITH
THIS NEW STRUCTURE I MEAN HOW IS
THERE GONNA BE BETTER
COORDINATION. I COULD JUST SAY I
DON'T REMEMBER JUST OF MY
EXPERIENCE I FEEL LIKE THERE'S
BEEN BETTER COORDINATION IN THE
LAST AND THE LAST YEAR THAT
WE'VE BEEN FOCUSING ON THIS ON
THIS CRISIS. WE WOULD HAVE MORE
STAFF AND RESOURCES TO BRING TO
BEAR TO SUPPORT THINGS THAT WE
WANTED TO DO A PARTNERSHIP THE
BILL IS A GOOD EXAMPLE TIED TO
GET EXACT SPECIFIC EXAMPLES. THE
SUPPLY CHAIN SUCCESS INITIALLY
BUT WE CO SPONSORED THE BILL
BECAUSE WE- WE NEEDED FUNDING.
YEAH WE DID WE REQUESTING THIS
RESEARCH FUNDING TO SUPPLYING TO
SUPPORT INITIATIVES LIKE THAT
WHICH WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
SUPPORT- QUICKLY OF YOUR
EXISTING BUDGET. WE JUST
EMBARKED ON A- A- YEAR LONG YOUR
HOUSE LONG STUDYING AGRICULTURAL
TRUCKING- WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
UP WITH BERKELEY AND UNIVERSITY
OF PENNSYLVANIA AND WHICH KOBE
IS A CO SPONSOR TO THIS
RESEARCH- BUT WE WEREN'T ABLE TO
FIND A FULL SCALE BETWEEN HAVE
THE FUNDING. BUT I GUESS IN BOTH
EXAMPLES THIS WILL BE AN EXAMPLE
OF HAVING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
FOR JOINT WORK WHERE WE WOULDN'T
WORK WITH PARTNER AGENCIES LIKE
GOAL IS- IN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD SO
AGAIN THIS ADDITIONAL CAPACITY
AND RESOURCES. WILL HELP US TO
WORK IN AN INTERAGENCY LEVEL IN
SUPPORT OF INTERAGENCY RESEARCH
AND OTHER AND OTHER. AND OTHER
AND OTHER ITEMS. NOW I WANTED TO
BRING UP SOMETHING THAT YOU
MENTIONED YOU CHAIR OF COURSE IT
I THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA TO
HAVE A- A PUBLIC FACING- REAL
TIME CHART OR OUR- WEBSITE THAT
ALLOWS. FOLKS TO KNOW HOW MANY
SHIPS RIDING IN THEM WHAT WHAT
THE CONGESTION IS IN THE PORT
WHAT WAS THE NUMBER THAT YOU HAD
OF THE CONGESTION. AT THE PORT
OF LA AND LONG BEACH. I MISSED-THAT. SO I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE I GOT THAT. I SO I I'VE
SEEN. MATH WITH THE DIFFERENT
MEASURES BEING YOU I MEAN I IT'S
STACK HANGER. LOITERING LIVE
SAUCE METRICS THAT IDEAL CLEAR
WE WILL BE WAS ALL. NEWS IN THE
FALL. OF BOY ANKH WAS IN THE
DOES IT. I'D SEEN SOME- THAT
MEASURE SAYING IF DOWN UNDER.
TEN I. IMAGES OF MY- BUT
INCLUDES- A LOT OF- AND- IN IN
LONGWELL CONTAIN. AT THE POINTS
OUT OF LA IN LONG BEACH OR THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS. DECLINE
OKAY. I HAVE BEEN FROM FROM THIS
MERCHANTS SAYS THAT THEY TWENTY
NINE SHIPS. AND THEN OF COURSE
THERE ARE TWENTY NINE MORE
SHIPS. THAT ARE- LOAD RATING OFF
THAT FURTHER OUT TWENTY SIX- TO
THE TWENTY CONTAINERSHIPS ARE
THREE INCLUDES THREE
CONTAINERSHIPS OFF THE PORT. AND
THEN THERE'S TWENTY SIX
VOLUNTARILY SLOWING THEIR SPEED-
HE SAID YEAH I'M TRYING TO. MAKE
THE ISSUE I GUESS IS THAT. WHY
ARE THERE DIFFERENT NUMBERS. IF
EVERYONE IS TRACKING THE SAME
THING I GUESS IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO UNDERSTAND LIKE WHAT THE
ACTUAL CONGESTION IS IT'S NOT
LIKE WE ARE MISS COUNTING IT
SHIPS OFF THE COAST OF
CALIFORNIA. WELL AND I DON'T
WANT TO SUGGEST CERTAIN THE
CONGESTION THAT THE SUPPLY CHAIN
CONGESTION ISSUE IS UNSOLVED-
I'M JUST SAYING THAT THE MEANT
THAT LOOKING AT VARIOUS METRICS
THERE- THERE HAVE BEEN.
INDICATORS OF IMPROVEMENT AND
THAT COULD BE THE OTHER
DISCREPANCIES IN HOW WE'RE
DEFINING AN ANCHOR OR OR SLOW
STEAMING OR OR OR WHAT HAVE YOU-
BUT WE CAN CIRCLE BACK TO YOUR
STAFF TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
THAT- THAT- THE NEW UNDERSTAND
THE METRICS WERE WERE WERE
DESCRIBING. RIGHT AT THE VERY
THANK YOU. M. A. GIVE THAT WAS
OF THE POINTS I WAS TRYING TO
MAKE GIRL. IS THAT THE SITUATION
IS. DYNAMIC IT CHANGES ON A
DAILY BASIS- AND FOR SOME. GOOD
REASONS I'M SURE- IN FACT I
THINK IT'S SALUTARY THAT- WE'VE-
CHANGE THE DYNAMIC SO THAT-
FEWER SHIPS ARE SIMPLY ANCHORING
AND RUNNING THEIR ENGINES THEIR
DIESEL ENGINES IN THE PORT WHICH
WAS AFFECTING COASTAL CITIES-
AND- WE'VE DONE THAT BY SLOWING
DOWN THE- OF TRANSPORTATION BUT
THAT DOESN'T. WAIT WE HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING BECAUSE- ONE MIGHT
ASSUME BY THE FACT THAT THERE'S
FEWER SHIPS IN THE PORT THAT THE
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUE HAS BEEN
ADDRESSED IN SOME FASHION AND-
THAT'S NOT REALLY WHAT YOU WOULD
NOT NECESSARILY READ INTO THAT.
SO A MEANS OF GETTING THAT
INFORMATION ON A DYNAMIC BASIS
WOULD BE GREAT. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS MISTER BENNETT. THANK
YOU IN I AM I APPRECIATE IN THE
NEED FOR THIS AND IN TERMS OF
CREATING IT- WHEN YOU HAVE
VARIOUS AGENCIES ALL HAVING
PARTS OF THE PROBLEM IT IS GREAT
TO HAVE COORDINATION MY QUESTION
IS TWO FOLD ONE WILL THIS BE AN
N. A TEAM THAT ACTUALLY TAKES
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF ME AS A
AND SAY WHAT IS IT WILL THIS
TEAM BE SORT OF IN THE
LEADERSHIP POSITION THAT AY YOU
MENTIONED ADDITIONAL RESOURCES-
WHAT I BOARD WANT TO HAVE HAPPEN
IS TWO YEARS FROM NOW HAVE SAY.
OKAY WHAT'S GOING ON AND WE
STILL SAY THERE'S NO ONE ONE
PLACE IN CHARGE WHERE WE CAN SAY
WHO IS THE ULTIMATE COORDINATOR
OF THIS- AS YOU GO FORWARD IN
THE SECOND HALF OF THE QUESTION
IS DOES THIS COORDINATION DEAL
WITH FREIGHT POLICY ONLY OR DOES
IT ALSO INCLUDE ALL OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE CHANGES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE TAKING PLACE ON THE
PORCH WILL THIS TEAM BE BE THE
COORDINATOR OF THAT ALSO. THANK
YOU. FRAZIER ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M
YES I VISIBLE WOULD ESTABLISH IN
THE TEAM AND HOUSE THAT TO BE
THE LEAD ON ALL OF THE FREIGHT
ISSUES IN THE STATE SO WE WOULD
BE THE UNIT THAT WOULD BE
CONTACTED WITH ANY QUESTIONS AND
WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
RESPONDING TO ANY ANY REQUESTS
BY THE LEGISLATURE OR OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS- AS FAR AS THE
SECOND QUESTION. IS CONCERNED.
IT'S ONE. OF THE SENATE YOU WERE
THE SECOND. POLICE ARE. IT IS
WHAT WILL THE TEAM BE THE LEAD
ON HAULER OR ALL WHEN OF ALL OF
THE INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT NEED TO
TAKE PLACE AT THE PORTS THAT WE
HAVE ALL THESE VARIOUS STATE
AGENCIES YOU KNOW CARB IS
INVOLVED YOU KNOW OF A BUSINESS-
CALTRANS INVOLVED TO GO BIZ
EVERYBODY IS ALSO INVOLVED IN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
THAT HAVE TAKE PLACE OF THE
PORTS WILL THIS TEAM BE THE LEAD
ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS ALSO. IT IS LIKE AN
ALTERNATE OVER TO OF I CALL THE
G. DEPUTY SAID. OR RELIGION ON
CHINA'S. YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT A QUESTION SIR- OUR
AGENCY HAS- A NUMBER OF
DEPARTMENTS THAT HAVE.
INVOLVEMENT IN PROJECTS THAT
THAT THAT SERVE THE CHORDS. AND
SO WE CERTAINLY HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE YOU KNOW DIRECTLY
OR AGENCY THAT IS. WORKING
TOGETHER. WITH THE COURT
INVESTMENTS. IS THERE ARE OTHER
STATE AGENTS THAT IN. IN
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL. THE
THING THAT- REALLY BREAK FROM
OUR AGENCY BECAUSE THAT A LOT OF
THAT FEDERAL FUNDING THAT WE ARE
SEEING IS IN THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES ON THE FEDERAL SIDE.
AND WE ARE WE HAVE A VERY STRONG
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM AGAIN
WOULD BE HELPING TO COORDINATE
THE PURSUE THE FEDERAL FUNDING-
TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN APPLYING
MONEY TO SOME OF THOSE IN
PROJECTS AND SO. THAT IS ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT I'M THAT WE SEE
THIS EVALUATE HAPPENING. ON THAT
BET THAT THE TEAM HERE AT THE
AGENCY. WOULD THE TEAM BE THE
LEAD ON ASIA STRUCTURE PROJECTS
ADDED THAT IN QUITE CATCH THAT
IN THE ANSWERS TEAM TO BE THE
LEADER WORKING WITH. OTHER
AGENCIES BUT NOT IN THE LEAD.
YEAH I WAS SO. WITH REGARD TO
THE- ONES IN THE I BELIEVE IS
YES I WE WOULDN'T WE WOULDN'T.
BECAUSE THE REST. FUNDING THE
MAJOR SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR
WOULD BE COMING THROUGH THE
HOUSE. AND ALLOW OF OUR- OUT A
LOT OF HOW WE BE A WAR WITH
WORKING WITH THE LOCAL PARK TO
AWARD FUNDING FOR TO DELIVER
FIVE. AND ALSO LET ADDITION
FEDERAL I WOULD SAY WE WOULD BE
THE LEAD IN THAT AND ALSO
BECAUSE WE ARE OUTRAGEOUS
INVOLVED DEVELOPING THE STATE
FRIEDMAN AT THESTATE FAIR PLAN
I WOULD SAY MORE SO THAN THE
OTHER AGENCY YES WE WOULD WE
WOULD BE IN THE LEAD ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE COMPONENT OF THIS
. I'M NOT SURE. COMPLETED ON THE
BUT THANK YOU. MISTER PATTERSON
. BUT WITH THE FRESNO CALL GOT
INVOLVED IN THE INLAND PORT
PLANNING AND OUR REGION I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY KEEP ME
INFORMED OF THOSE MEETINGS AND
I'D LIKE TO BE A PART OF THOSE.
AT INVOLVED. THANK YOU SIR.
GREAT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. AND I THINK WE CAN
MOVE ON TO- ISSUE. THREE FIRST
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION.
HELLO MISTER CHAIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS IS A KEY FUNCTION ARE
CALTRANS WAS AFTER MY COMING
THROUGH OKAY. IT'S A LITTLE BIT
THE SOUND IS A LITTLE BIT BLOODY
. OKAY LET'S TRY THIS AGAIN MY
APOLOGIES FOR THAT MISTER CHAIR
FAMILY MEMBERS I KEEP DUNCAN
CALTRANS BUDGET OFFICER CAN
OCCUR BUT- MUCH BETTER THANK YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH HI THIS
IS- THE CLEAN CALIFORNIA'S
BECAUSE A REQUEST FOR A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR- THIS
ISN'T IT IN ADDITION TO THE
CURRENT R. ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLAR TOTAL FUNDING THAT'S
INCLUDED IN THE CLEAN CALIFORNIA
EFFORT. I'VE BEEN CALIFORNIA
AFTER THE INITIAL PROPOSAL WAS
FOR ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS- WHICH
INCLUDED A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ARE. TO LOCAL GRANTS FOR
DRESSING LETTER NEEDS ODD IT
WHAT WAS IT- EVENTUALLY APPROVED
CAN PROVIDED FUNDING FOR THE
FIRST TWO YEARS OF THAT OVERALL
THREE YEAR PLAN SO THIS IS JUST
IN ADDED THIS PROPOSAL IS
INTENDED TO PROVIDE AFTER YOUR
FUNDING. THANK YOU. MISTER
JIMENEZ YOU HAVE A REPORT FROM
THE ALEJO YES- GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FRANK MENACE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THE
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED MILLION IN
BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE FOR THE
GAME CALIFORNIA LOCAL GRANT
PROGRAM AS YOU RECALL AS PART OF
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
PACKAGE THE LATEST LEGISLATURE
APPROVED A HUNDRED NINETY SIX
MILLION IN BOTH THE CURRENT YEAR
AND BUDGET YEAR FOR THE LOCAL
GRANT PROGRAM. EDITION OF THE
BUDGET PACKAGE INCLUDED BUDGET
TRAILER LEGISLATION WHICH
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT TO
REPORT ON TWO YEARS OF
PROGRAMMATIC OUTCOMES WE FIND
THAT PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IN BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE
BEFORE OUTCOME DATA IS AVAILABLE
IS PREMATURE- BASED ON TWO YEARS
REPORT OUTCOMES THE MINISTRATION
COULD REQUEST THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING PROPOSED AS PART OF THE
BUDGET PROCESS- FOR THAT YEAR-
HAVE TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
. JAMES MORE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. NOTHING BAD AT THIS
TIME TO HAVE TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. WELL PERHAPS WE
CONDUCT A START BY ASKING YOU TO
RESPOND TO THE L. A. O.'S
COMMENT- THAT. WE SHOULDN'T FIND
THIS THIS YEAR BECAUSE IT'S
ALREADY FUNDING IN PLACE. FROM
THE PRIOR A BUDGET YEAR YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THE SUCCESS
DEPARTMENT- JUST RECENTLY
ANNOUNCED THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO- AWARD ALMOST TWO HUNDRED
NINETY SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
LOCAL GRANT- LOCAL GRANTS TO
LOCAL AGENCIES WITH A 100% OF
THAT DEDICATED TO UNDERSERVED
AND UNDERREPRESENTED.
COMMUNITIES IT THIS- HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR- REQUEST WOULD BE
INTENDED TO ENHANCE THAT ALREADY
SUCCESSFUL EFFORT WE DO
UNDERSTAND WE DO WE DO INTEND TO
CONTINUE TO REPORT THE SUCCESSES
OF THE OF THIS. INITIATIVE- OVER
THE NEXT YEAR. AND I WITH THE
EXISTING FUNDS HOW ARE YOU
MEASURING SUCCESS. ALL RIGHT NOW
SO IT JUST FOR A QUICK- STATUS
REPORT THROUGH FEBRUARY THE
DEPARTMENT WAS ABLE TO COLLECT
ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND I CUBIC YARDS OF
LITTER- FOR COMPARISON PURPOSES
ON AVERAGE WE ARE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND- WHO TURNED
EIGHTY THOUSAND CUBIC YARDS A
LETTER BEING PICKED UP FOR
ENTIRE YEAR BUT ARE WE
REPRESENTED A COMPOUND. OF A
GREAT INCREASE OF ALMOST 40%
OVER OUR TRADITIONAL- EFFORTS-
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT- CALTRANS
FORCES WERE ABLE TO HIRE OVER
SIX HUNDRED NEW TEAM MEMBERS
MANY OF THOSE POSITIONS ARE
ENTRY LEVEL- CLASSIFICATIONS
WHICH PROVIDES GREAT JOBS JOB
TRAINING AND PROMOTIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES ESPECIALLY IN
TIMES OF ECONOMIC HARDSHIP TO BE
ABLE TO BRING PEOPLE ON BOARD
AND I TO PROVIDE. EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AS PART OF THAT
EFFORT WE WERE ALSO ABLE TO
INCREASE VOLUNTEERISM I HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO- INCREASE- OUR
ADOPT A HIGHWAY PROGRAM AND WE
DID YOU ERMITS FOR OVER FOUR
HUNDRED NEW ADOPT A HIGHWAY
SITES YOU ARE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM- AS WELL AS BEING ABLE TO
ADVANCE- IT OUR ADVANCED MANY OF
OUR PROJECT DELIVERY EFFORTS-
FOR THE- AWARD- OF OVER- ALMOST
A HUNDRED TWENTY SIX STATE
BEAUTIFICATION PROJECTS. WITH
ABOUT 98% OF THOSE BENEFITING
UNDER CERTAIN THE STORK WEEKS
GOOD COMMUNITIES SO OVERALL WITH
WE'VE BEEN HITTING THE GROUND
RUNNING FOR THE FIRST EIGHT
MONTHS AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
TO DELIVER MORE ON THAT THIS
BIBLE AFTER. THAT IT'S GOOD TO
HEAR- I AM SURE YOU AGREE WITH
ME THAT- CLEANING UP THE
EXISTING LETTERS ONLY HALF THE
BATTLE- WHAT. ARE WE DOING TO-
PREVENT. ADDITIONAL FROM PILAR
UP AND HOW DO WE CONVINCE BATES
. IN BREAKS MY- WHEN I SEE
PEOPLE FOR GARBAGE OUT THERE
WHEN- AS- YOU KNOW IT'S THAT FAR
TOO OFTEN. BOB WHAT ARE WE DOING
TO PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING.
WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT OUR
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGNS TO
RAISE AWARENESS THE DRIVING
PUBLIC OR JUST- USES OF OUR OFF
OF OUR TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IT
JUST IT PLEASE BE AWARE THAT.
ARE NOT LITERATE- AS WELL AS
WORKING LAW ENFORCEMENT
PARTNERS- IT TO. GET TO MONITOR
AND HAS- WE AT LETTER- EMPLOYERS
ARE CAUGHT TO BE ABLE TO- BY
THOSE LAWS ABOUT. THE BY BUT
THAT KIND OF THE GENERAL INTO
RIGHT NOW WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
WORK WITH A PUBLIC A- I'M A
LITTLE THE STATE LAW TO JUST
AWARE. IN AN ATTACK THIS MADE
WHAT'S THE BUZZ FOR THE PUBLIC.
CAMPAIGN I. DON'T HAVE THAT
READILY AVAILABLE BUT I WILL
HAVE I WILL. SPEAK I WILL HAVE.
TO GET THAT FOR YOU. ANY SENSE
OF. OF HOW THE ORDER OF
MAGNITUDE- THAT IT- IS WITHIN
THE OVERALL BUDGET. I CAN JUMP
IN HERE- JAMES OR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO- THIS
IS A THREE YEAR PROGRAM SO OVER
THE THREE YEARS FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS- IS SPECIFICALLY
DEDICATED TO THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION PART OF THIS PROGRAM.
AND I I'D LIKE TO GET MORE
DETAILS ON WHAT THAT PROGRAM
ACTUALLY ENTAILS AND TO HOW IT
HOW IT'S BEEN DEVELOPED IN. WHAT
WHAT THE MESSAGING IS ON.
ABSOLUTELY CAN WORK AT THEIR
OFFICE. TO GET THAT INFORMATION
THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN IF OU
HAVE A QUESTION YEAH I'M
WONDERING- WHAT MATCH IF THERE'S
ANY METRICS BEING USED TO
EVALUATE THE PROGRAM AND- IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW WHERE THESE
ROADS LOOK LIKE YOU KNOW SIX
MONTHS LATER AND THE REASON I
ASK BECAUSE I AM ALSO WONDERING
HOW MUCH OF THE PROGRAM FUNDS
ARE GOING TO THINGS LIKE SIGNAGE
ON PUBLIC ART AND HOW MUCH IS
GOING TO ACTUAL. CLEANUP THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE QUESTION I
TYPICALLY IN THE SPRING AND IT
IS ABOUT THIS TIME WHERE THE-
OUR MAINTENANCE THE- MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM. BEGINS OUR LEVEL OF
SERVICE EVALUATIONS WERE ABLE TO
GO OUT TO THOSE ROADWAYS WERE
WE'RE- CURRENTLY PROVIDING
LITTER CLEANUPS- AS WELL AS
MEMBERS OF THE MAINTENANCE
OPERATION SO WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF EVALUATING THAT NOW.
ON AND WE CAN REPORT- REPORT
THOSE RESULTS IN THE COMING
MONTHS. AND THE SPLIT BETWEEN
SIGNAGE- PUBLIC ART.
BEAUTIFICATION VERSES. OF THE
REMOVAL AND- HAZARD REMOVAL.
OVERALL I BELIEVE THE TOTAL
AMOUNT I DON'T HAVE THE EXACT
DOLLARS AND FOR ME I BELIEVE THE
BEAUTIFICATION PROGRAM IS ABOUT
A HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY FOR BEAUTIFICATION
PROJECTS- WITH ROUGHLY A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WAS INITIALLY
BUDGETED FOR THE LOCAL PROGRAM
GRANT AND THE REMAINING
DEDICATED TO OUR MAINTENANCE-
DIRECTLY- ACTIVITIES WHICH
INCLUDES PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGNS- IN OTHER ASSOCIATE
WITH WILL LATENCIES CLEAN UP
DAYS. AND SUCH THINGS. THIS
REGION IS MORE- FROM FINANCE- SO
IT IN THE ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS APPROVED. OR
FIVE HUNDRED ABOUT HALF MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT LESS THAN HALF OF THE
MONEY IS FOR CAN BE USED FOR THE
BEAUTIFICATION PROJECTS THAT I'M
LIKE MISTER DUNCAN WAS SAYING.
NOT JUST PICKING UP THE TRASH
BUT REALLY TRANSFORMING SOME OF
THESE AREAS. I'M THE ONE ONE
PART OF THE PROPOSAL- INITIALLY
LAST YEAR THAT. WAS REJECTED BY
THE LEGISLATURE WAS THE SPECIFIC
PART GRANTS AND SO THAT IS NOT
PART OF THE PROGRAM BUT- LIKE I
SAID BEFORE THERE ARE. A LOT
ABOUT HALF THE FUNDS USED. FOR
BEAUTIFICATION PROJECTS. MY
GUESS IS IN THE AND I'D LOVE TO
HEAR BACK FROM LMAO. AFTER
HEARING THE ARGUMENTS. ALL RIGHT
LET'S OF OFFICIAL ARE QUESTIONS
FIRST NOVEL GO BACK TO ALEJO- IS
RIVAS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
YOU KNOW I SUPPORT- OF
CONTINUING YOU KNOW THE FUNDING-
FOR MORE HIGHWAY BEAUTIFICATION-
AND LITTER REMOVAL IN MY
DISTRICT OF THIS IS THE NUMBER
ONE CALL THAT WE GET IN MY
DISTRICT OFFICE FROM
CONSTITUENTS ARE COMPLAINTS
ABOUT LITTER ON OUR HIGHWAYS- IN
THE DISTRICT. AND ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE'VE BEEN HAVING
OUR WHEN A HOMELESS ENCAMPMENT
IS RELOCATED OR- THE
INDIVIDUALS- LEAVE UP A CERTAIN
AREA ON THE HIGHWAY THEY LEAVE
YOU KNOW LITTER BEHIND IT- AND
I'D LIKE TO ASK WHAT YOU KNOW. A
LOT OF TIMES THOSE ARE THE
NUMBER ONE COMPLAINT THAT I'M
GETTING AND MY OFFICE- YOU KNOW
IS STILL HAVING CHALLENGES- WITH
COMMUNICATIONS WITH CALTRANS AND
AT THAT ARE IN OUR DISTRICT- WE
REPORT THEM WE EXPECT UPDATES
SOMETIMES THOSE UPDATES ARE
PROVIDED TO ANOTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICE INSTEAD OF MY
OFFICE. WHILE WE ARE THE ONES
THAT HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THESE
CASES WE WANT TO PARTNER WITH
CALTRANS THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME AND MY CONSTITUENTS AND I
EXPECT THAT COMMUNICATION WHEN
WE ARE TRYING TO HELP AND
PARTNER- TO GET RID OF THIS
LITTER ON THE HIGHWAYS SO MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS. UP YOU KNOW
WHAT ARE WE DOING WHEN. THERE IS
LITERALIST OVER AFTER A HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENT IS RELOCATED BOB YOU
KNOW WE MY DISTRICT TEAM REPORTS
THEM TO CALTRANS- AND WE EXPECT
TO HEAR YOU KNOW AN UPDATE OF
WHEN THOSE WILL BE CLEANED UP OR
WHAT CAN WE DO BETTER. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M ON
MY SINCERE APOLOGIES FOR THE
LIMITED COMMUNICATIONS BUT
YOU'RE NOT OFFICES RECEIVED I
WHEN IT COMES TO OUR THE
HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS ARE CLEAN
UP EFFORTS WE DO HAVE DEDICATED
HOMELESS ENCAMPMENT OF
COORDINATORS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE PLANNING EFFORTS WHEN IT
COMES TO OUR REMOVAL OF HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS AND ALSO THE
COORDINATION. FOR AFTER ALMOST
EXAMINES ARE MOVED- THE
INHABITANTS WERE MOVED AND
CLEANING UP AFTER- CLEANING UP
AFTER THAT THE HOMES AND
CAMCORDERS RESPONSE FOR
COORDINATING AND COMMUNICATING
THOSE EFFORTS- I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO CHECK IN AND FIND OUT WHAT
WERE THOSE COMMUNICATION
BREAKDOWNS- MATE MAY BE
OCCURRING. I THANK YOU I WANT I
FEEL THAT YOU NEED FUNDING FOR.
YOU KNOW HIGHWAY LITTER REMOVAL
AND AS A MEMBER OF THIS BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE I HAVE BEEN IN
SUPPORT OF THAT- BUT I ALSO- YOU
KNOW EXPECT TO GET UPDATES FOR.
THEIR COMMUNICATIONS FROM YOUR
LOCAL TEAM TO MY DISTICT TEAM
AND INSTEAD OF IT GOING
SOMEWHERE ELSE UNFORTUNATELY
STORIES LIKE THIS MAKE THE MEDIA
IN LOS ANGELES- AND- YOU KNOW
WE- WE- ARE WORKING WITH IT AND
I WANT MY CONSTITUENTS TO KNOW
THAT WE- ARE UPDATING THEM AND
SO WE DO EXPECT. THESE UPDATES
SO THANK YOU AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO. BETTER PARTNERING AND
WORKING WITH CALTRANS. L. A. O.
DID YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS- NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
BUT IF- ASSEMBLY MORE FRIEDMAN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO REPEAT YOUR
QUESTION HAPPY TO ANSWER. HE'S
JUST AFTER HEARING THE-
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE REQUEST
I'M WONDERING IF YOU STILL STAND
BY YOUR- RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE
DENY. WEST YES SO LAST YEAR'S-
BUDGET TRAILER LEGISLATION-
REQUIRED THEIR APARTMENT TO
REPORT AS PART OF THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET PROCESS AND NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET PROCESS- PROGRAMMATIC
OUTCOMES THAT INCLUDE HOW MUCH
LITTER WAS COLLECTED-
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE LOCAL GRANT
PROGRAM THE DEPARTMENT STILL IN
THE PROCESS OF- IMPLEMENTING
THOSE PROJECTS HANDING OUT MONEY
TO LOCALS AND ACTUALLY DOING.
THE LITTER CLEANUP AND
BEAUTIFICATION SO DURING THIS
YEAR'S- REPORTING REQUIREMENT
THOSE METRICS ARE PRELIMINARY
BECAUSE THE PROJECTS HAVE BEEN
COMPLETED YET- SINCE THIS-
BUDGET PROPOSALS FOR BUDGET YEAR
PLUS ONE HAVING THAT SECOND YEAR
PROGRAMMATIC OUTCOMES WILL BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE DATA ON WHAT
WAS ACTUALLY CLEANED UP IN THE
PROJECTS THAT WERE ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTED AND COMPLETED WHICH
WOULD PUT THE LEGISLATURE IN
ABOUT IT BETTER POSITION AND
BUDGET YOUR PLUS ONE. I'M TO
WEIGH THE METRICS ON WHETHER AND
I AM A THIRTY YEAR FUNDING IS
WARRANTED FOR THE LOCAL GRANT
PROGRAM. AND IT MIGHT TO GIVE US
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON HOW WE
MIGHT WANT TO- TARGET THE USE OF
THAT FUNDING WOULD NOT. YES OF
COURSE ANY- OUTCOMES THAT COME
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE THAT
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
OVERSIGHT AND TO CHANGE THE
PROGRAM AS NEEDED. ALL RIGHT
WELL THANK YOU. LET'S MOVE ON
TO- ISSUE NUMBER FOR FLEET
REPLACEMENT. THE INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AGAIN I KEEP DOWN CAN CALTRANS
BUDGET OFFICER I BUT THIS
PROPOSAL APARTMENT- IS
REQUESTING ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR
TWO YEARS IN THE STATE HIGHWAY
COUNTY BEGIN REPLACING OUR AGING
- WE ARE EQUIPMENT AS WELL AS
INSTALLS REMISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FAST CHARGING
STATIONS ARE TO SUPPORT THIS
DEPARTMENT PLEASE OVERALL THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN A COMPLETE
THAT TOTALED ABOUT TWELVE
THOUSAND UNITS- INTENDED TO
SUPPORT OUR MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATION PROJECT DELIVERING
PLANNING A MODEL EFFORTS OF THIS
TWELVE THOUSAND UNITS WE ARE
ROUGHLY EIGHTY THOUSAND PIECES
OF THOSE EQUIPMENT CURRENTLY
MEET OR EXCEED OUR REPLACEMENT
CRITERIA- DISTRICT REQUEST FOR
THIS FUNDING OVER THE FIRST TWO
YEARS. IN THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF
A MULTI YEAR EFFORT- WE'RE
LOOKING CHU I REPLACED- THIS
AGING AND AGING EQUIPMENT ARE
THE PRIMARY FOCUS ISN'T LOOKING
AT ROUGHLY ANYWHERE FROM ONE
THOUSAND TO ONE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED VEHICLES BEING REPLACED
EACH OF THESE FIRST TWO YEARS
WITH THE FOCUS BEING ON ELECTRIC
VEHICLE AND YOUR EMISSION
VEHICLES WITHIN OUR PASSENGERS
PLEASE AS WELL AS A LOOKING AT
AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGIES WITH WHAT
WITH THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY.
EQUIPMENT OPERATIONS OR
EQUIPMENT AVAILABILITY- THE BEST
PART ABOUT IT IS WE'RE LOOKING
EVEN IF WE'RE LOOKING TO REPLACE
WITH EXISTING GAS AND DIESEL
THOSE ARE MODERN AND CLEAN-
CLEAN EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES SO
THEY OFFERED IS. TO GET ONE OF
OUR OLDEST THE FIRST. THANK L.
L. THANK YOU MAN IS AT THE
LEGISLATIVE OFFICE- NO CONCERNS
FROM OUR OFFICE ON THIS PROPOSAL
. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. JAMES
MORE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTHING TO ADD NOW BUT
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU- A QUICK QUESTION- A GIVEN
THE FACT THAT- THERE ARE- A
SIGNIFICANT SUPPLY CONSTRAINTS-
IN THE- VEHICLE MARKET. HOWELL
HOW DO YOU PROPOSE TO- WORK
WITHOUT CONSTRAINT. THANK THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTIONS OR SHARE-
WE- ARE WE I RECOGNIZE THAT THAT
IS A RISK- THAT AS PART OF THIS
OVERARCHING PLAN WE HAVE BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH OUR VENDORS- THE
EQUIPMENT SUPPLIERS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THAT THE SUCCESS OF THIS
PROPOSAL CAN BE MADE I INITIAL-
INITIAL RESPONSES DISTINGUISHED
THEY THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO MEET
OUR ARE REQUESTING OR PROPOSAL
NEEDS ABA WILL CONTINUE TO
MONITOR THAT BUT- AT THIS POINT
IN TIME WE STILL ARE. QUITE
CONFIDENT IN BEING ABLE TO
INCORPORATE THIS PLAN BEFORE AND
WILL CONTINUE TO EVALUATE FOR
THE FIRST TWO YEARS AND REPORT
BACK TO THE- TO THE LEGISLATURE-
FOR OUR RESOURCES FOR-
CONTINUING THIS EFFORT IN YEARS
THREE AND BEYOND. THANK YOU ARE
AYE AYE WOULD BE VERY CONCERNED-
IF THE- STATE'S CLEAN AIR
VEHICLE. PROGRAM WERE TO HAVE A
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE ABILITY
OF CONSUMERS TO- TO OBTAIN THOSE
VEHICLES OR MAKE IT
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE EXPENSIVE FOR
CONSUMERS IS THAT. SOMETHING
THAT CAN BE. QUANTIFIED CAN THE
STATE'S PROGRAM BE- FOR LACK OF
A BETTER EXPRESSION- THROTTLED-
IN A IN A WAY THAT- GOOD PROVIDE
FOR LESS PRESSURE ON THE OVERALL
MARKET ECONOMIC PRESSURE. YEAH
THAT IS PART OF THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION MISTER CHAIR THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT ARE PART OF
THAT OUR DISCUSSIONS WERE HAVING
WITH THE VENDORS IN THE VEHICLE-AND- CLINTON MANY FACTORS IS A
THEY'RE PRODUCING BASED ON THE
I. HEAVY DUTY- OR INDUSTRIAL
NEEDS AS COMPARED TO THE
EVERYDAY CONSUMER- INITIAL.
INITIAL CONVERSATION INCLUDED
ARE NOT GOING TO BE IMPACTS BUT
WILL CONTINUE TO EVALUATE THAT
I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY SPECIFIC
METRICS- THAT WE HAVE WITHIN
CALTRANS WILL BE HAPPY TO CHECK
IN WITH THE TEAM AS WELL AS
REJECT THE PARMESAN SERVICES TO
SEE IF HE GOT LIKE THAT MAY BE
AVAILABLE. WELL GIVEN THAT THERE
IS A- EXTREME LIMITATION ON
SUPPLY IT'S HARD FOR ME TO
IMAGINE THAT THERE'S NOT AND- A
FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT IMPACT- A
GIVEN THE BUYING POWER OF THE
STATE- SO I'D APPRECIATE.
GETTING SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON THAT. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. THE BROWN. I CURIOUS
ABOUT. IMPLEMENT AT THE HEAVY
DUTY- SIDE OF IT YOU YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOU MAY BE GOING
WITH CLEANER DIESEL- AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD- AND I KNOW THAT THE
WHOLE INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE- FORCE
ABSENT HEAVY DUTIES IS STILL
EVOLVING BUT WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
THE HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES THAT YOU
PLAN ON REPLACING ARE YOU
PLANNING ON REPLACING WITH SAYS
. RIGHT NOW THE OF THE THANKS
FOR THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
I'M SORRY- YEAH RIGHT NOW THE
INITIAL PLAN AS PART OF THE
FIRST TWO YEAR EFFORT THE FOCUS
FOR THE HEAVY DUTY IS ON THE
DIESEL- DIESEL EMISSION OR
DIESEL ARE DRIVEN VEHICLES- AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT YEARS THREE AND
BEYOND AS- BEING THE PRIMARY
FOCUS. AS WE WORK WITH THE
VENDORS AND THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF D. B. INTO THE HEAVY DUTY-
RIGHT NOW IT'S LOOKING AT A
COUPLE YEARS OUT BEFORE THAT
THAT TECHNOLOGY IS READILY
AVAILABLE IN THAT IT WOULD BE IN
THE HEAVY DUTY AREA. FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE SUCH A SUCH
LARGE PURCHASES KNOWS HAVE KNOWS
AND PURCHASES IN THE HEAVY DUTY
AREA THE NEXT TWO YEARS. CUT
BACK ON THE MARKET. YES THANK
YOU. ADDITIONAL S. SO YOU'RE
HAVE ANY HEAVY DO THOSE OF THE
HAVE CURRENT. FILE THAT NOT THAT
I'M AWARE OF NO. THE MY QUESTION
IS IF TRACK IT IN THE FUTURE
BECAUSE THE DIESEL POWER SWEEPER
COST NEARLY SAY THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. A NEW ELECTRIC
SWEEPERS GO TO COST SIX HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND BUT I'D LIKE
SOME UPDATE FOR MAINTENANCE
BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE A DIESEL.
SWEEPER CAN RUN ALL DAY LONG YOU
JUST FILL IT BACK UP BUT
ELECTRIC SWEEPER OR BOTH THE
HEAVY DUTY TRUCK HOW MUCH TIME
ARE YOU GOING TO BE ABLE TO RUN
THAT VEHICLE DURING THE DAY AS
WE MOVE FORWARD INTO THIS OF.
ELECTRIC FUTURE THAT WE'RE GOING
TO TRY TO PUSH IN CALIFORNIA BUT
I WOULD LIKE SOME COMPARISON AND
MAINTENANCE AND COST AS WE GO
THROUGH THIS BECAUSE STARTED
TWICE AS MUCH COST BUT IT MAYBE
YOU GET HALF AS MUCH TIME AS
THIS YEAR'S. SO WHILE AN EYE ON
IT WE MOVE FOR THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION ASSEMBLY WILL
DEFINITELY BE MONITORING THAT
AND WE CAN. INCLUDE THAT IN OUR
IN OUR LATER YOUR QUESTIONS YOU
CAN SEE IT IN CORPORATE THIS.
AGGRESSIVE THE PUBLIC YOU CAN
PLAN. FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR IN THE
SAME THING IN MY- OR CHARGING
STATION I'D LIKE TOA WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO A LACK. CHARGING
VEHICLES TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
THE CHARGERS AT THE SITE AND NOT
BY THE VEHICLES AND NOT HAVE THE
CHARGE OF THE COORDINATED. TO
MOVING FORWARD AND YOU MIGHT
ALREADY HAVE SOME SITES MAYBE
THEY GET THE ELECTRIC VEHICLES
VERSUS A SITE THAT DOESN'T HAVE
A CHARGER. AND HOPEFULLY THAT'S
COORDINATED- WITH THE DIFFERENT
STATE AGENCIES. TO MAKE SURE WE
DON'T BUY A FLEET OF VEHICLES
AND DON'T HAVE ENOUGH CHARGING.
AND MY COLLEAGUE TALKED ABOUT IT
EARLIER THE INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT
WE NEED IN THE STATE. TO GO TO
OF. ALL ELECTRIC SO WE GOT TO
WATCH AT AND SLOWLY GET THERE
NOT JUST FLIP THE SWITCH. AND
THINK WE'RE ALL GOING TO COLLECT
TOMORROW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GREAT IF THERE IS NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE THE INTERESTINGLY
NAMED OFFICE OF UNMANNED
AIRCRAFT SYSTEMS. INTERESTED
THANK. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AGAIN KEEP TALKING
CALTRAIN BUDGET OFFICER A GOOD
MORNING- THIS REQUEST BY THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUEST FROM AN
INCREASE OF TWO POSITIONS AND
FOUR HUNDRED FOURTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE HIGHWAY CAL TO
ESTABLISH THE UNMANNED ORION
PERSON AIRCRAFT SYSTEM A PROGRAM
FROM THE BURGERS DRONES- THE
DRONES OR UAS ARE POWERFUL TOOL
THAT'S REVOLUTIONIZING A LOT OF
OUR FIELD WORK OR INCORPORATING
INTO MANY OF OUR MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS EFFORTS AS WELL AS
OUR PROJECT DELIVERY- AS WE
CONTINUE TO EVALUATE THE USE OF
DRONES AND INCORPORATE THAT INTO
OUR DEPARTMENTAL OPERATIONS.
THERE IS A DIRE NEED OR THERE IS
A NEED TO ENSURE THAT WORK
PROPERLY TRAINING WILL PROBABLY
INVENTORYING AND TRACKING THE
USE OFTHESE DRUMS ESPECIALLY-
WITHIN THE HIGHWAY SYSTEM- SO
THIS- THESE RESOURCESARE
INTENDED TO SET UP THIS NEW
PROGRAM WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
AND WILL CONTINUE TO EVALUATE
THE INCREASED USE. OF DRONES AND
OUR OVERALL OPERATIONS. I'M
AVAIL TWENTY YOU KNOW HOW. THANK
YOU HELLO. I UNITS RODILLA THEY
FAIL OFFICE WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL. AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. JAMES
MORE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SOMETHING THAT BUT HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU- DO YOU HAVE- FOLKS WITHIN
YOUR OFFICE TO ADDRESS PRIVACY
ISSUES THAT- UP PERIODICALLY
COME UP VOTE WITH RESPECTIVE
DRONES. YES THAT IS PART OF THE
STANDING UP OF THIS NEW PROGRAM
IS TO BE ABLE TO TRUST- PART OF
THAT EFFORT AS IT IS ALWAYS THE
OPPORTUNITY OR THE RISK OF
PRIVACY CONCERNS- THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO EVALUATE WE'RE WORKING
WITH OUR LEGAL DIVISION AS WELL
SO THAT'S PART OF THIS OVERALL-
AND DUG OUT WE HAVE- DRONES THAT
ARE USED IN OTHER DEPARTMENTS
LIKE BECAUSE- OF. FOR EXAMPLE
CAL FIRE- IS THERE ANY EFFORT
TO. COORDINATE WITH OTHER
AGENCIES. TO INCREASE
EFFICIENCIES. YES WE DO WE DO
HAVE A REGULAR INTERACTIONS WITH
THE OTHER STATE AGENCIES AS WELL
AS LOCAL OUR LOCAL AGENCIES WHEN
IT COMES TO THE COURT EFFORTS
OF- OF THE DRONE TECHNOLOGY
INTEGRATION OF DRONES INTO OVER
OVER ALL OPERATIONS I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT AT THE DISTRICT
LEVEL WE DO HAVE THAT
COORDINATION AS WELL AS OTHER
STATE AGENCIES. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. ISSUE NUMBER
SIX IS A PEDESTRIAN AND
BICYCLIST SAFETY INVESTIGATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS P. DUNCAN
CALTRANS BUDGET OFFICER I'M FOR
THIS REQUEST IS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING TWELVE
FULL TIME PERMANENT POSITIONS
AND RESOURCES OF JUST UNDER TWO
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT TO
FUND THE PEDESTRIAN AND
BICYCLIST SAFETY INVESTIGATION
FOR GRAFT- A AS WE KNOW IT
UNFORTUNATELY EVERY YEAR ABOUT
THREE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED%
INDIVIDUALS DYNAMIC CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM BOTH STATE
AND LOCAL NETWORKS. THAT AVERAGE
ABOUT TEN DEATHS PER YEAR OF
WHICH ABOUT THREE ARE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE USERS WHICH ARE
PEOPLE THAT WALK AND BIKE ARE
THESE DEDICATED RESOURCES WILL
PRODUCE APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED ADDITIONAL FAKE
INVESTIGATIONS ARE CONDUCTED IN
HIGH COLLUSION AND OBSTRUCTION
LOCATION AND THIS IS CAN I
SPECIFICALLY FOR INCIDENTS
INVOLVING BICYCLE BICYCLISTS AND
PEDESTRIANS. IT THIS PURPOSE THE
RESULT OF THE THESE
INVESTIGATIONS MAY RESULT AND
WHETHER IT'S MAJOR MAINTENANCE-
EFFORTS TO BE ABLE TO ENHANCE
SAFETY FOR THE ARE THE FOR THE
BY CONTENT USERS AS WELL AS
POTENTIAL PROJECTS IN THE STATE
HIGHWAY OPERATIONS PROTECTION
PROGRAM DEALING CORPORATE
ENGINEERING DESIGN ADJUSTMENTS
TO INCREASE EIGHTY FOUR FOUR OF
FOUR APPLICATION AND USERS-
WITHOUT AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
ALEJO. THANK YOU YOUR UNITS FOR
THE LEGISLATIVE AND OFICE WE
HAVE CONCERN TO THIS PURPOSE
THANK YOU DEPART OF FINAL.
BENJAMIN POLITY PARTNER FIND-
NOTHING TO ADD TO. EVIDENCE OR
QUESTIONS THAT YOU THIS AN AN
ISSUE OF A GREAT CONCERN
OBVIOUS- THE- STATISTICS WE WERE
PROVIDED TO IN THE MATERIAL I
THINK ONLY. TAKE US THROUGH
TWENTY NINETEEN- OF BUT MY
RECOLLECTION IS THAT- THE- OF.
PEDESTRIAN DEATHS HAD DUG- FOR
MOST OF THOSE FIVE YEARS BENNETT
AN EXTREMELY HIGH LEVEL-
BICYCLIST. DEATHS INCREASED FOR.
I THINK THE LAST FOUR YEARS WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHERE THERE WAS A-
LITTLE DIP- DO WE HAVE-
STATISTICS FOR TWENTY TWENTY-
AND DO WE KNOW WHAT THE NUMBERS
ARE LOOKING LIKE FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. I THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION MISTER CHAIR I DESPITE
HAVING OTHER IN SOME OF THE DATA
FOR TWENTY TWENTY- WITHIN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS WE DON'T
HAVE THAT READILY AVAILABLE AT
THIS TIME. RIGHT THANK YOU
HOPEFULLY WILL HAVE THAT- BY THE
TIME- BUT WE SEE YOU AGAIN-
AFTER MAY REVISE- BUT AGAIN THIS
IS A- AREA OF GREAT CONCERN- WE
KNOW THAT THE NUMBER OF- OF
PEDESTRIANS ARE INCREASING- WE
WANT TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO USE
OUR STREETS. AND THE OF COURSE-
BICYCLISTS AS WELL ARE ON THE
INCREASE AND THAT MAY BE PART OF
WHAT'S DRIVING THESE NUMBERS BUT
IT WOULD BE INTERESTING TO KNOW
WHETHER IT IS- DRIVER BEHAVIOR
IN ATTENTION BY ADMIN THERE'S
LOTS OF OTHER THINGS THAT MIGHT
BE CONTRIBUTING TO THIS- IN
INCREASED NUMBERS AND TO- ONCE
WE UNDERSTAND THAT WE CAN- A
BETTER ADDRESS WHAT THE- THE
BETTER JUST PREVENTIVE MEASURES.
MS FRIEDMAN. YEAH I GUESS IT'S
NOT A QUESTION SO MUCH AS A
COMMENT I COMPLETELYAGREE WITH
THE CHAIR AND I APPRECIATE YOUR-
PUTTING A- EMPHASIS ON THIS
PARTICULAR ITEM AND THIS IS
REALLY A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AT
THIS POINT. AND IT'S ALSO
SOMETHING THAT IS- TOUCHING A
LOT OF OTHER REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUES ON YOU KNOW EQUITY
ISSUES- BECAUSE YOU KNOW A LOT
OF PEOPLE WHO CYCLE AROUND DO SO
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD A CAR
THIS IS THE PRIMARY MODE OF
TRANSPORTATION PEOPLE ARE
WALKING. THE SAME REASON THERE'S
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS BECAUSE
BESIDES YOU KNOW GETTING HIT BY
A CAR IS NOT HEALTHY FOR YOU BUT
IF YOU'RE FREE TO GO OUT AND
RIDE YOUR BIKE OR WALK- OF
COURSE IT'S A LOT LESS HEALTHY I
MEAN I. FOR ONE AM AFRAID TO LET
MY OWN DAUGHTER RIDE HER BIKE IN
MY NEIGHBORHOOD BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE SIDEWALKS AND I'M NERVOUS
ABOUT HER BEING ON THE STREET.
AND THAT'S NOT FAIR TO HER SHE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO RIDE A BIKE IN
THE STREET LIKE. SO MANY OF US
DID WHEN WE WERE GROWING UP-
BESIDES TRYING TO GET TO THE
ROOT CAUSE OF WHAT'S BEHIND
THESE. THESE TRAGEDIES I WOULD
ALSO THROUGH- ADD TO THAT THE-
SOME UNDERSTANDING AT SOME POINT
I KNOW THIS PROBABLY ISN'T THE
RIGHT PLACE BUT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IT. THESE INCIDENTS
ARE HANDLED BY PROSECUTORS
INCLUDE- I'VE HEARD FEEDBACK
FROM THE BICYCLE COMMUNITY
PARTICULARLY THAT MANY TIMES
THINGS THAT REALLY SHOULD BE.
PROSECUTED AS- RECKLESS DROPS.
OR SOME SORT OF VEHICLE
INFRACTION OR NOT THAT IT'S
CHALKED UP TO
THE BEHAVIOR OF THE CYCLIST OR
THE BEHAVIOR OF THE DRIVER BUT
THERE'S A REASON WHY THIS
HAPPENED JUST AS THE MOST
ASTEROID FALLS IN THE SKY AND
CAUSES THIS OR A TREE FALLS ON
SOMEONE THAT'S AN ACCIDENT. BUT
A TRAFFIC ACCIDENT IS NOT
ACTUALLY AN ACCIDENT SOMETHING
WENT WRONG IF WE DON'T LOOK AT
WHAT THAT IS WE'RE NEVER GOING
TO BE ABLE TO SOLVE FOR IT. SO
I'LL JUST PUT IT THAT YOU KNOW
WE DON'T WE DON'T SAY WHEN THEIR
PLANE CRASHES LIKE HEY JUST AN
ACCIDENT THESE THINGS HAPPEN
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON WE REALLY
INVESTIGATE IT A LOT MORE PEOPLE
KILLED. IN CAR CRASHES IN BY
PLANE CRASHES AND YET WE SORT OF
JUST SAID HEY THAT'S JUST
COLLATERAL DAMAGE IS THE WAY IT
IS SO I THINK WE NEED A LOT MORE
FOCUS ON THIS AND I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER IT'S- MAKING A BUDGETARY
BUT ALSO POLICY BUT I JUST
WANTED TO. I TWENTY THREE MY
PIECE ON THIS THIS BIT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS AND OF COURSE THAT'S
WHAT THIS FUNDING IS ALL ABOUT
IS- CONDUCTING SAFETY
INVESTIGATIONS ON- AT SOME POINT
WE SHOULD HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING
WHETHER- WE'RE ACTUALLY.
INVESTING ENOUGH MONEY IN
INVESTIGATIONS LIKE THIS AND
WHETHER WE SHOULD BE DOING MORE
MISTER BENNETT. JUST JUST TO
FOLLOW UP ON THAT IT IS A
SPECIFIC QUESTION AND THAT IS
WE'RE GOING TO THE
INVESTIGATIONS HOW WILL THE
INVESTIGATIONS BE INCORPORATED
INTO THE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
GRANTS THAT ARE OUT THERE TO
DEAL WITH THE ISSUE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I WHEN IT COMES
TO THE RESULTS OF THESE- THESE
INVESTIGATIONS THAT WE WANT
OTHER ON THE HIGHWAY SYSTEM
THAT'S WHAT THE DEPARTMENT ABLE
TO INCORPORATE I- CHANGES. AS
PART OF THE SHOP IS THAT HOW WE
OPERATIONS PROTECTION PROGRAM SO
THEY'RE ALREADY THERE WAS A
PROJECT THAT WE CAN PROGRAM AN
IMMEDIATE IMPLEMENT TO ADDRESS.
ANY SAFETY MEASURES TO- TO
ENSURE SAFETY FOR THE USERS WERE
ALSO ABLE TO SHARE THE RESULTS
WITH OUR LOCAL AGENCY PARTNERS
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM- THAT THE
MINISTRY OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. THE
BULK OF THOSE- AS A PROJECT THAT
ARE AWARDED OR PROGRAMS THAT
PROGRAMS ARE APPLIED FOR BY
LOCAL AGENCIES SO THAT'S PART OF
WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO PARTNER WITH
LOCAL AGENCIES WHEN IT COMES TO.
PROJECT THAT MAY BE ON THE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM CAPTION DISABLED
INCORPORATE IDENTIFY SPECIFIC
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED. A BOAT
BICYCLISTS AND PEDESTRIAN MEETS
THE LOCAL AGENCIES WILL BE ABLE
TO ACCESS ALL OF THAT DATA AND
SAY APPLY FOR THEIR GRANTS X.
CENTER. SEX WE WORK CLOSELY AT
THE DISTRICT LEVEL WORKING WITH
OUR LOCAL AGENCY PARTNERS THERE
IS SOME PLACE THAT. THEY CAN
ACCESS THIS DATA. THERE SIMPLE
WE CAN. THEM NOT A- HEALTHY
SYSTEM AVAILABLE WHERE THEY CAN
THE DATA BUT THEY CAN BE ACQUIRE
THE INFORMATION FROM OUR-
CONTACT. WITH WANNA FIND A WAY
TO MAKE THAT DATA. POST AT DATA
SOMEWHERE SO THAT THE PUBLIC HAS
ACCESS TO IT SO THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE ACCESS SHOULD
IF EVERYBODY HAS TO GO TO YOU
AND ASK. OKAY WE'RE GETTING
READY TO DO A GRANT ON THIS WHAT
IS THAT WHAT IS A SAFETY DATA.
THAT DOESN'T. DOESN'T STRIKE ME
AS AS OF AS EFFICIENT SO I JUST
WOULD OFFER THAT AS POTENTIAL
SUGGESTIONS THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. THANK YOU I MISS
FRIEDMAN YEAH I'M SORRY I THINK
I LOST MY THREAD A LITTLE WHEN I
WAS TALKING ABOUT ONE OF THE I
THINK WHAT I'M ASKING FOR IS IF
IT THAT WE HAVE IF WEHAVE DATA
THAT SAYS THAT FOR INSTANCE A
VEHICLE VEHICLES THE DRIVERS
WERE AT FAULT AND SOME OF THESE
INCIDENTS I THINK IT WOULD ALSO
BE HELPFUL TO FIND OUT HOW MANY
OF THOSE RESULTED IN SOME SORT
OF- AS SOME SORT OF EITHER
CRIMINAL CHARGE OR OR INFRACTION
CHARGE FOR THE DRIVER BECAUSE
THIS IS A COMMON COMPLAINT THAT
I'VE GOTTEN FROM THE BICYCLE
COMMUNITY THAT. THE DRIVER WAS
AT FAULT HIT A CYCLIST AND
NOTHING'S DONE- BECAUSE IT'S
JUST CONSIDERED LIKE HEY YOU
KNOW IT'S AN ACCIDENT OR OR EVEN
SOMETIMES LAW ENFORCEMENT NOT
UNDERSTANDING WHO IS REALLY AT
FAULT AND THAT YOU KNOW KNOW
THAT THERE WAS A RESPONSIBILITY
TO NOT HIT THE PRO ATHLETE YOU
KNOW BE MORE FOR THE DRIVER AND
SO THERE'S THE FEEL THAT THERE'S
NOT ENOUGH ENFORCEMENT OF THE
RULES THAT ARE MEANT TO KEEP
THEM SAFE AND SO BE GOOD IN THE
DATA TO ALSO SAY. IF THERE WERE
20% OF THE TIMES WHERE THE
VEHICLE WAS FOUND TO BE AT FAULT
WITH A COLLISION HOW OFTEN DID
THOSE RESULT IN SOME SORT OF
ENFORCEMENT ACTION AGAINST THAT
DRIVER SO THAT'S ALL I'M
SUGGESTING. THANK YOU SIMILAR WE
HAPPEN TO GO BACK TO THE PROGRAM
AND SEE IF THEY HAVE THAT
INFORMATION AS PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION BUT THEY- HAVE
TAKEN PLACE. AND TO SEE IF THE
THERE ARE RESULTS WE CAN
IDENTIFY WHERE WERE- DRIVERS.
MAY HAVE BEEN PROSECUTED OR IN
THAT REGARDS. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE SEVEN- YOU'VE GOT SOME OF
TECHNOLOGY BCPS IF YOU COULD
SUMMARIZE THOSE PORTS THAT BE
GREAT. RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AGAIN KEEP
YAKKING CALTRANS BUDGET OFFICER-
ISSUE SEVEN I INCLUDES FIVE
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGY OUR
PROPOSALS ARE TO SUPPORT OUR
DEPARTMENT'S OPERATIONS. ARE THE
FIRST IS THAT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS TO UPGRADE THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM THE ADVANTAGE OF
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT SYSTEM IN
THAT REGARD. CURRENTLY THE
CURRENT SYSTEM WHAT THE
IMPLEMENTED IN JULY OF TWENTY
TEN AS A COMMERCIAL OFF THE
SHELF ENTERPRISE RESOURCE
PLANNING SYSTEM CAPTAIN COULD
NOT UPGRADED SYSTEM SINCE TWENTY
TEN AND SINCE THEN THE- THE
ENTERPRISE. RESOURCE PLANNING A
VENDOR AT LEAST SIX VERSIONS
SOURCE SIX UPDATES TO THE SYSTEM
SINCE THEN WE HAVEN'T BEEN
EFFECTIVE ENOUGH TO THINK THAT-
THIS REQUEST WILL- IT WILL ALLOW
US TO BE ABLE TO UPGRADE THE
SYSTEM SO CAN CAN. TO BE
SUPPORTED WE'RE RECENTLY
NOTIFIED BY THE END OF THE DAY
AT BASED ON THE CURRENT SYSTEM
THAT WERE OUR VERSION OF WHAT
WORKING OUT BUT- YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE SUPPORTERS THIS EVER BY THE
RESOURCES HELP US. TO AN EFFORT
TO IT AND I BURGEONING CAN BE
SUPPORTED BY THE- BUT MOVING
FORWARD- THE STAFF UPPER. PART
OF THIS- IS OUR THREE HUNDRED OR
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE STATE
HOW WE COUNT FOR ENTERPRISE DATA
GOVERNANCE TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS-
THIS IS PART OF AN I. D. PROJECT
IN THIS IS. TO COMPLETE A
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE STAGE
THREE. FOR THIS PROJECT- THAT
SUMMER TO DISCUSS I WAS ASKED
EARLIER- WE'RE LOOKING AT AN
ENTERPRISE APPROACH WITHIN
CALTRANS DOPT CONSISTENT AND
COMPREHENSIVE PRACTICES HOW DATA
GOVERNED AND MANAGED WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT. RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
LOT OF INDIVIDUAL SYSTEMS ARE
WHERE A LOT OF THIS DATA WE HAVE
A LOT OF DATA AVAILABLE TO US TO
BE ABLE TO EMIGRATE AND MORE OF
AN ENTERPRISE APPROACH DEVELOP
DRAW THAT DATA TOGETHER. FOR
FISSION OPERATIONAL AND OPPER-
EFFICIENT TRANSPORTATION
DECISIONS. TO BE MADE. THE THIRD
- PROPOSE IS PART OF AN AND DATA
- IT'S THAT PROVIDE. BY OVER.
MULTIPLE YEARS. AND SIX FOR THIS
TO A DATA STORAGE FOR. IN
DALLAS. NEED OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS. IT I WOULD THE PASSAGE OF
SENATE BILL ONE IN SEVENTY
EIGHTEEN WELL AS WITH. RECENT OF
THE- BACKING AND JOB ACT ARE
THERE ARE IT WOULD IT YOU CAN TO
DELIVER A MORE. ON AND BASIS.
AND CURRENT I T. AND PER IS NOT
ABLE SUPPORT THE THEY HAVE
AMOUNT OF DATA BECOMING
AVAILABLE TO US THESE RESOURCES
WILL HELP TO- NEEDED DATA- STILL
CAPACITY THAT. DATA TO ABLE TO
HAVE TO ALL OF OUR PRO. AS WELL
AS FOR A FROM TO- AT AS AS WE
LOOK AT THAT POTENTIAL SECURITY
BREACHES THAT HAPPENED THAT WE
HEAR ABOUT A TRUCK NEWS- THE
NEXT. I KEEP OPPOSE TECHNO FOR
IS FOR ART. WHICH IS OUR OUT
THIS NETWORK I AM IS FIRST
SECURITY IN HIM. THIS PROVIDES A
FINE OVER MORE YEAR AND TWENTY
PERMANENT POSITION FOR BOTH ARE
TRAFFIC OPERATIONS CENTER I. T.
TEAM. I TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE- IT. ESTABLISH
SECURITY ARE PROTECTION- ARE
TALKING IT. IS THE SYSTEM THAT
OPERATES WERE ABLE TO TRACK THE
OPERATIONS ACROSS THE STATE WHEN
IT COMES OUR STATE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AND FROM
THE MAJORITY THAT THAT IT
MANAGED TO OUR REGIONAL TRAFFIC
MANAGEMENT CENTERS- THIS FUNDING
WILL HELP US TO ENSURE- HAVE THE
NECESSARY SECURITY. TO A TWO- IN
ATTEMPT TO A THAT NO DATA SIX
BREACH- MAGIC. BACK HOWEVER THEN
I'M SURE START THAT-
AVAILABILITY FOR YOU MIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT-
SUMMARY. HE CAN BE A LITTLE MORE
DETAIL THAN X. BUT- MISTER
JIMENEZ DOES DO YOU HAVE A AND A
COMMENTS. A BANK MANAGER THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE
DON'T RAISE ANY CONCERNS WITH
ANY OF THE PROPOSALS THAT ARE
BEING HEARD UNDER THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU AND THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. PUBLIC DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTHING TO ADD WHICH CAN
ANSWER QUESTIONS HERE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
UP QUESTIONS SEEING NONE THANK
YOU- FOR YOUR PRESENTATION ON
THIS ITEM WE HAVE FOR ONE MORE
ITEM FOR MISTER DUNCAN TO.
PRESENT ON AND THAT IS- ISSUE H.
THE ROAD USAGE CHARGE PILOT
SAID- I- I AM- BEFORE A- YOU-
MAKE EUROPE PRESENTATION THAT I
WAS EXPECTING THAT WE WOULD BE
WELCOMING THE NEW- SECRETARY OF
TRANSPORTATION AND- AT THIS
HEARING BUT- I KNOW HE'S GOT A
LOT OF THINGS TO DO SINCE HE'S-
JUST RECENTLY STARTED BUT WE DO
WANT TO- WELCOME- THE NEW
SECRETARY AND TO LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING HIM PROBABLY- IN MAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FAMILY
MEMBERS AGAIN YES I KEEP TALKING
CALTRANS BUDGET OFFICER AND THIS
WILL BE A LOT OF FOLKS WHO NEED
TO HEAR FROM YOU TODAY- THIS
PROPOSAL IS FOR A SIX MILLION
DOLLARS OVER TWO YEARS. I WHICH
INCLUDES FUNDING FOR SIX
POSITION AND OPERATING EXPENSES
OUR CONSULTANTS ARE TO SUPPORT
THE DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS IN
IMPLEMENTING. S. B. SENATE BILL
THREE THREE NINE FOR THE ROAD
CHARGE REVENUE PILOT. THE
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES OUR%
RESOURCES FOR THE DEPARTMENT
MOTOR VEHICLES WHICH IS A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE SEVENTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND ONE TWO
YEAR LIMITED TERM POSITION. AS
WELL AS TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION THE
SUPPORT CONSULTANT EFFORTS ARE
TO ALSO SUPPORT THIS OUTGROW
CHARGE- PILOT. I AM YOU KNOW-
THE CALIFORNIA'S A FORMAL STUDY
OF THE ROAD CHARGE TAXES AND
BEGAN IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE
PASSAGE OF SENATE BILL. TEN
SEVENTY SEVEN I WHICH ARE
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY TO RUN A
STATEWIDE PILOT TO TEST THE
FEASIBILITY OF CHARGING A FEE
FOR MILES HOW OLD. ARE THE AT
THIS INITIAL ROAD CHARGE PILOT.
STUDY HAVE FIVE THOUSAND
VEHICLES AND COVERED AND I NINE
MONTH PERIOD- THE RESULT IN A
PILOT LARGE APPROVED. THE A
LARGE TAX PROGRAM WHAT'S
FEASIBLE BUT FINAL REPORT NOTED
KEY AREAS- FOR THE RESOURCE THAT
WE NEEDED TO INSURE DRIVER PAUL
JOBBER PRIVACY. DATA SECURITY AS
WELL AS EFFORTS TO PREVENT TAX
BROUGHT. CALTRANS IS CONTINUE TO
EXPLORE AND COOPERATION AND
COLLABORATION WITH A CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY AS WELL AS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION. COMMISSION AND
OUR OTHER. PARTNERS FOR
POSSIBILITY THE USER EXPERIENCE
BY INTEGRATING A COLLECTION OF
ROAD CHARGES WITHIN VARIOUS
BUSINESS MODELS WHETHER THAT'S
PAYING AT THE PUMP WHEN I A
DRIVER MAY BE PAYING- FILLING UP
WITH GAS. GAS DIESEL OR EVEN
ELECTRIC VEHICLE OR AN
ALTERNATIVE FUEL INFRASTRUCTURE
CHARGING. LOCATIONS PAYING AS
WELL WHEN THE DRIVER I
REGISTERING THE VEHICLE PAYING
ONE- IT WHEN IT CAME DOWN
TRANSPLANT. THERE'S A VARIETY OF
ANNECTENS THAT WERE THAT HAVE
BEEN LOOK AT. I THE PASSAGE OF
TIME BILL THREE MANAGED. CAL
STICK TRANSPORTATION DAMPEN A
PILOT THAT ACCESS CHIU DIFFERENT
MADRE SOUTH. AND COLLECT ROADS
READ INTO FUNDS BUT I WHY THIS
IS A- UP WITH CAL. D. AND
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION I AM A
SIX THE PILOT INCLUDE A TEST OF
OVER REVENUE. K. ARE OUR
AGENCIES. I WOULD THAT'D BE THE
L. PRETTY MUCH YOU HAVE. THANK
YOU MISTER. IN THE- ALLEY-
COMMON. RECOMMENDED AT THE
LEGISLATIVE OFFICE- HAD NO WITH
THIS PROPOSAL. AND THE
DEPARTMENT. J. MORE WITH THE
PEOPLE OF FINANCE- NOTHING TO
ADD AT THIS BUT TO DANCE
QUESTIONS THANK YOU- I'VE GOT
ONE AND- IF I HAVE THIS
CORRECTLY- THE- ANALYSIS
ESTIMATED THAT THE CTC WOULD
NEED FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE TIME BUT
THERE'S ONLY OF A TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND THAT IS- REQUESTED
WISER DISCREPANCY THERE. I
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION MISTER
CHAIR- PART OF THE- IS WHENEVER
THE- INITIAL ANALYSIS IS JUST
IDENTIFYING THE DIFFERENT ROLES
RESPONSIBILITIES AND BEING ABLE
TO PROVIDE THE SUPPORT NEEDED-
IF THAT THE FUNDING THAT'S BEING
REQUESTED AS PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. IF
THERE IS ADDITIONAL RESOURCE
NEEDS ORDER SOME ATER THAT
WOULD BE NEEDED THAT THEY'VE
IDENTIFIED TO BE ABLE TO HELP
SUPPORT THIS OVERALL HAVE AN
AVERAGE THE DEPARTMENT WILL BE
THERE TO HELP SUPPORT THAT AND-
MAKE SURE THOSE RESOURCES. ARE
MADE AVAILABLE AS PART OF THIS
EFFORT. SO ARE YOU SAYING THAT
THE C. T. HAS OF. TO THE TO. TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND THAT'S THE
LOCAL. ALL BECAUSE YOUNG THAT
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR LUNCH AND
FINANCE AT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION- YES YOU'RE CORRECT
WHEN THE BILL WAS GOING THROUGH
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WE
HAD IDENTIFIED A HIGHER LEVEL OF
RESOURCES- WHAT THE PROPOSED
AMOUNT OF FUNDING IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WILL STILL BE
ABLE TO COMPLETE- A REASONABLE
AMOUNT OF RESEARCH AND PRODUCE-
AN INDICATIONS THAT WERE
REQUIRED TO MAKE UNDER THE
STATUTE. FOR THE PILOT PROGRAM-
HOWEVER OUR ABILITY TO CONDUCT
THE MORE EXTENSIVE RESEARCH WE
INITIALLY ENVISIONED WILL BE-
SOMEWHAT LIMITED SO FOR EXAMPLE
WE WON'T BE ABLE TO VIEW
SURVEILLANCE NUMBER OF OTHER
STATES OR CONDUCT MARKET
RESEARCH OR DO SOME OF. THOSE
ACTIVITIES THAT WE HAD- YOU KNOW
ORIGINALLY AND WHEN THE WAS
GOING THE CROSS BUT WILL BE ABLE
TO. THE REQUIRED RECOMMENDATIONS. OKAY A HUB I'VE. WHAT WHAT IS
THE- HEN LET ME ASK WHAT THE
RATIONALE IS- FOR- AT SINCE
SINCE THESE FUNDS DID HAVE A
SPECIFIC PURPOSE WHAT'S THE
RATIONALE FOR NOT- ARE
REQUESTING THEM. MISTER DUNCAN I
GUESS THAT WOULD BE TO YOU ARE
PROTECTED FINANCE. NO IT THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
CHECK IT NEEDS THE CONTINUED
COLLABORATION WITH THE- CALTRANS
AND THE CALIFORNIA HAS DISMISSED
WHEN IT COMES TO WORK- AS MR
GOLOVKIN MENTION THE ADDITIONAL
RESEARCH AND OTHER ITEMS THAT
ARE BEING INITIALLY- BOB WHAT WE
SHOULD BE PART OF IT WE DO PLAN
TO TRY TO INCORPORATE THAT INTO
THE OVER ARCHING- PROPOSAL- IT
WITHIN THE RESOURCE THAT ARE
BEING REQUESTED- IT. WILL BE
ABLE TO UTILIZE SOME OF THE
RESOURCE IDENTIFIED TO CALTRANS
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT SOME. OF
THE EFFORTS BY THE COMMISSION.
AT SUCKS OF UNUSUAL TO. SEE LESS
MONEY RICK. THAT AND- A-
ANTICIPATED- WHEN IT COMES TO-
OUR PROCESS IS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT- SO I DON'T PUSH
TOO HARD ON THIS BUT- WILL- ASK
OUR STAFF TO TAKE A CLOSE LOOK
AT THE- AT THIS AS WE- APPROACH
MAY REVISED. ARE THERE ANY-
QUESTIONS. IT IS NOT QUESTIONS
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO- CLICK MISTER DUNCAN- THAT'S
YOUR LAST- YES YOU'RE PROBABLY-
YOU'RE GRATEFUL THAT THAT'S YOUR
LAST ITEM ON THIS- ON THIS
AGENDA. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
YEAH THANK YOU FOR YOUR SEATS-
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON NOW TO
ISSUE NINE AND THAT'S- OF THE-
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION'S
ISSUE. IMPLEMENTATION OF SB SIX
SEVENTY ONE. YEAH THE MORNING
TERRIBLE IN MY MEMBERS I'M
HOPELESSLY SKI DEPUTY CHARACTER
FROM LEGISLATURE AND FINANCES
CONCEIT C. OTHER PROGRAMS BEFORE
YOU IS OUR- FOR RESEARCH.
REBECCA TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISION OF SAN BILL SEVEN ONE
MY SENATOR GONZALEZ. WHICH WAS
INTO LAW BY THE GOVERNOR IT'S
PAST. THIS REQUIRES THE
COMMISSION TO THE A CLEAN
FREIGHT CORRIDOR IN ADDITION I
THOUGHT. FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
THAT IDENTIFY RIGHT CORRIDOR IN
IN. NEED TO. THE OF MEETING AND
HEAVY DUTY COMMERCIAL YEAH. WELL
CONSIDERING THE POTENTIAL FOR
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS CHARGING.
STRUCTURING THE- YES REDUCTION
ROAD SAFETY AND EMBARKS ON THE
BRINK. THE BILL WOULD ALSO THE
EVERY BOARD AND ENERGY TO FROM
CORPORATE THE SS FINDINGS AND-
IN CITIES AND PROGRAM GUIDELINES
DOCUMENTS RELATED TO FREIGHT AND
- KNOWLEDGE. HI AND THANK- THAT
WOULD INCLUDE THE COMMISSION
STRAIGHT AND PROGRAM WHICH FUNDS
RIGHT PROJECTS INCLUDING ACCORDS. WITH THE- WHERE DID YOU
EARLIER ON HIS WALK. CHIU THE SB
SIX SEVEN ONE OF THAT IS REQUEST
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND RESOURCES
FROM A RECOUNT PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION ACCOUNT. TO HIRE
TO LIMITED TERM POSITIONS AND
EXECUTE A ONE TIME CONSULTING
CONTRACT. THE REQUESTED
CONSULTANT WILL PROVIDE THE
NEEDED- ZERO VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE AND PERFORM THE
RESEARCH AND DATA ANALYSIS
NECESSARY TO DROPPED A RING
REPORT. WHICH YOU ARE LIMITED
TERM POSITIONS WITH MANAGING
OVERSEE THE CONSULTING CONTRACTS
CREATE THE ASSESSMENT- WILL
COORDINATE WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES AND THE PRIVATE ACTION
ACADEMIC SECTORS- INCLUDING
CONVENING WORK GROUPS. AND
REVIEW THE CONSULTANT FINDINGS
NUMBER AFTER COURT. AND WITHOUT
HAVING TO CHECK IN QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU LMAO I'M THANK YOU
MINUTES AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE HAD NO
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. BENJAMIN
WITH BERMAN FINANCE- NOTHING
DOWN AT THIS TIME THANK YOU AND-
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT- THERE'S-
SIMILAR DISCREPANCY HERE BETWEEN
WHAT WAS- IDENTIFIED THE- IN-
THE APPROPRIATIONS ANALYSIS AND
WHAT IS ACTUALLY BEING REQUESTED
HERE. AND SO PERHAPS WE'LL JUST
ASKED AFTER TAKE A OF- BUT STAFF
TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AT THE- AT AND
ANNUS LOOK AT THE AT AT THAT
ISSUE. ARE THERE ANY QUESTION
MISTER BENNETT. OF EACH YEAR.
I'M THE DO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION IS WHO I'M ASKING A
QUESTION OF- JUSTICE REQUEST IS
GOING TO PROVIDE ENOUGH
RESOURCES TO ACCOMPLISH THE
GOALS OF SB SEVEN SIX SEVENTY
ONE- ARE THINGS GOING TO BE LEFT
THAT- STILL ARE ARE- NOT CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED BECAUSE OF LACK OF
RESOURCES. WE FEEL LIKE WE CAN
HANDLE ALL OF THE GOALS OF SB
SIX SEVENTY ONE WITH WITH THIS
FUNDING REQUEST. SELL WILL BE
ABLE TO PRODUCE THE ASSESSMENT
AS REQUIRED TO GO WILL BE-
SOMEWHAT MORE LIMITED THAN WHAT
MEETS BURGEONING DESIGNED ONE.
THE RESPONSIBILITIES. PROCESS
I'M SURE I JUST HAD TOM THAT
COULD YOU COULD YOU SHOULD YOU
TRY AGAIN YOUR- BASS WAS REAL-
JUST YEAH. RIGHT OUR WEALTH BE
ABLE TO PRODUCE THE ASSASSIN
WITH THIS LEVEL OF RESOURCES.
BUT THE SCOPE WILL BE SOMEWHAT
MORE LIMITED- THEN WE DIVERSE
LAND VISION- UP WHEN WE GET THE
FISCAL ANALYSIS WHEN THE BILL IS
GONE BRING IN A FIGHT WHERE THE
SCOPE WILL BE. YASAKA OF IT.
YEAH BUT WHAT PART WILL BE DEBT
. RIGHT A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES%
WHERE WE MAY BE MORE LIMITED-
WOULD BE IN RESEARCHING THE USE
OF MICROGAMING CRANKS AND
BATTERY OPTIMIZATION NOT
CHARGING STATIONS- RESEARCHING
THE RESALE VALUE OF ELECTRIC
BATTERIES- AS WELL AS THAT THAT
IMPACTS OUR- AT LEAST OPTIONS
AND RESELL OPTIONS TRUCKS-
RESEARCHING WAYS TO MORE
PROACTIVELY CREATE- BUT- CHECK
TRANSMISSION. AND TRANSMISSION
AND DISTRIBUTION LINES. HAVE
MORE LIMITATIONS ON THE-
TRUNCATA MOVEMENT THAT WERE ABLE
TO JUST WANNA BE CLEAR AGAIN
TURN IT DOES TO THE THINGS THAT
YOU WILL NOT BE DOING THEN THE
REPORT. PERHAPS HE PROBABLY
LIMITED OR OR DOING MUCH LESS
THE ORIGINAL. THANK YOU AND
SECOND TO THEIR TEACHERS NOPE.
POSITION HERE TO- DEAL WITH THE
ISSUE OF COORDINATING WITH OTHER
AGENCIES. ON ON THE UPDATE IN
THE REVIEW OF THE ASSESSMENT TO.
HOW DO YOU AND DISSIPATE
COORDINATING WITH EVERYBODY
WITHOUT A PERMANENT POSITION.
SEVERAL THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES
LIMITED TERM RESOURCES LAW WHICH
WILL HELP WITH THE COORDINATION
OF THE ASSESSMENT- WITHOUT.
PERMANENTE PERMANENT POSITION
WOULD HELP ENSURE THAT SORT OF
OVER THE LONGER TERM THAT THE
ASSESSMENT'S FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE BEING
INCORPORATED INTO VARIOUS
FUNDING PROGRAMS- LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS WHICH IS WHAT'S
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET REALLY
THE ONLY BE ABLE TO WORK ON THE
ASSESSMENT UNTIL IT'S CONCLUDED-
WHERE IS A PERMANENT POSITION
WOULD ALLOW FOR THE MORE ON
GOING. WORK THAT'S NEAT- YOU AT
JUST WON'T POINT TO POINT OUT-
I'VE ENTERED AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY TWO- WITH THE GOAL OF
TRYING TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE. AN
INVESTMENT IN THE MINIMUM AMOUNT
OF THE- INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED
FOR HYDROGEN- TO HELP- ALONG
WITH OTHERS AND VEHICLES- SO
THAT HYDROGEN AND BATTERY
TECHNOLOGY ARE BOTH COMPETITIVE-
AND- HELP US CLEAN UP THREE
QUARTERS. AS WE MOVE FORWARD SO-
I'VE HOPED IT WILL BE ABLE TO-
CONSIDER- WAS A MINIMAL AMOUNT
OF HYDROGEN. FUELING STATIONS
NECESSARY TO CREATE THAT
BACKBONE- LONG THE FREE
QUARTERS- SERVICING THE PORCH IN
THE THREE QUARTERS ALSO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SO. SB SIX
SEVENTY ONE WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
BY THE GOVERNOR AND CALLS FOR-
AND I DON'T RECALL THE SPECIFICS
OF IT FRANKLY BT CALLS FOR AS
ALL BILLS DO- CERTAIN CATEGORIES
OF- OF ACTIVITIES AND ACTIONS
BUT IT. SOUNDS LIKE- THE
COMMISSION IS ONLY IMPLEMENTED
SOME OF THOSE INSTEAD OF ALL OF
THOSE. WHY WITH THE COMMISSION
ONLY BE PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTING
SOMETHING THAT HAS PASSED
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE AND-
DULY SIGNED INTO LAW BY THE
GOVERNOR. OR MAYBE I'M WRONG
ASSUMPTION. YEAH WILL WILL I
THINK WHAT THE FUNDING PROPOSED
WILL STILL BE ABLE TO COMPLETE
THE COR ASPECTS OF THE
ASSESSMENT I THINK IT'S MORE
SOME OF THE- ADDITIONAL RESEARCH
THAT WE HAD ORIGINALLY HOPED TO
DELIVER ALL SIX MORE LIMITATIONS
WITH THE FUNDING PROPOSED. THAT
THAT TELLS ME WHAT YOU'RE DOING
THAT DOESN'T TELL ME WHY YOU'RE
NOT ASKING. FOR FUNDING FOR ALL
OF THE. I GUESS THE QUESTION IS
WHY ARE YOU- OKAY YEAH MY MOM
DOESN'T ABOUT FINDING A THAT'S
FOR PRESIDENT. DEPARTMENT
FINANCE DO YOU HAVE- ANYTHING
THAT ADD ON THAT WITH IN
RESPONSE TO MY QUESTION. BOB
BENJAMIN POLLAK BERMAN FAN YES-
WORKING THROUGH THE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL REVIEWING THE
TRANSFER AGENCY- THIS THIS WAS
THE FUNDING LEVEL THAT AFTER
REVIEWING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AGENCY AND THE-
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION THIS
WAS THE FUNDING LEVEL THAT. WAS
DETERMINED BASED ON ALL THIS.
WELL LIKE I REALIZE THIS IS THE
FUNDING LEVEL- BUT YOU'RE NOT
BEING RESPONSIVE TO MY QUESTION
WHICH IS WHY YOU NOT FUNDING-
EVERYTHING THAT'S CALLED FOR IN
THIS LEGISLATION. I WOULD SAY
THAT THE THIS LEVEL WHAT'S
PROPOSED BASED ON THE FACT THAT
THERE WOULD BE SUFFICIENT TO
ADDRESS THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL. AGAIN I'M GONNA THROW BACK
TO OUR OF A HIGHLY QUALIFIED
STAFF FOR FURTHER ANALYSIS
HEADING INTO- THE MAY REVISE AND
- I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT- WHEN
WE DO PASSED LEGISLATION AND IT
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR- THAT-
DUE RESPECT BE GIVEN TO THE
ENTIRE TO THE ALLEGES OF THE
LEGISLATION. NOT JUST BITS AND
PIECES OF IT BOB THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE A LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
THAT'S WHY WE WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION WE GET FEEDBACK
FREQUENTLY BEFORE LEGISLATION IS
PASSED BUT ONCE IT'S BEEN SIGNED
. LIKE THAT'S THE- OF THE LAW OF
CALIFORNIA- AND THE INTENTION OF
THAT LAW- A SHOULD BE ADHERED TO
BUT- AND UP ABOUT THAT I THINK
WE CAN MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT ITEM.
WHICH IS GOING TO BE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL SO THAT'S ITEMS
TEN THROUGH SIXTEEN. AND I
BELIEVE WE HAVE- COMMISSIONER
RAY AND- ASSISTANT CHIEF ALVAREZ
. HERE TO PRESENT. THIRTY ONE.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME'S AMANDA
REYES YOU JUST HEARD I'M TO
COMMISSIONER TO CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
DISCUSS THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL'S BUDGET PROPOSALS. ALL
OF THESE PROPOSALS THEY WERE
GOING TO PRESENT TODAY ARE VERY
CRUCIAL TO OUR MISSION OF
PROVIDING THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
SAFETY SERVICES SECURITY TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS. WITH ME TODAY IS-
ASSISTANT CHIEF MIKE ALVAREZ
HE'S MY SPECIAL REPRESENTATIVE
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND AS ALWAYS
I WELCOME AND WE WELCOME ANY
DISCUSSIONS OR QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. GREAT YOU HAVE- ANY
PRESENTATION MAKE ON- ISSUE TOWN
THE- SPECIFICS OF THE CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROPOSALS. YES WAS IT
YOUR IDEA- THIS YEAR C. H. P. IS
PROPOSING NINE CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS YOUR BECAUSE- IT WAS A
TIME I'LL BE PRESENTING A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF EACH REQUEST THE
GREAT. THANK YOU AND AS
BACKGROUND I JUST LIVE IN THE
BACKGROUND THE CHP HAS A TOTAL
OF A HUNDRED ELEVEN DIFFERENT
OFFICES THROUGHOUT THE STATE. A
TWO THOUSAND NINE WE REQUESTED
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES TO COMPLETE A REVIEW OF
OUR AREA OFFICES FOR VARIOUS
ISSUES INCLUDING SIZE TO. IT ADA
COMPLIANCE AND THE CONDITION OF
OUR AGENTS STRUCTURES. EACH OF
THESE OFFICES UP FOR DISCUSSION
TODAY RIGHT UNIFIED AND
PRIORITIZE BY THE C. H. P. AND
D. G. S. AS NEEDING IMMEDIATE
REPLACEMENT BASED ON THE SIZE
MAKE AN ADA COMPLIANCE CONCERNS.
THE FIRST ONE IS THE ANTELOPE
VALLEY AREA OFFICE REPLACEMENT-
AND- SORRY SIR- THAT IS. OF THE-
LOWER RESERVE. THIS FACILITY
OPEN IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
AND IS ONE OF THE MOST
UNDERSIZED THESE P. OFFICES IN
THE STATE AND DOES NOT MEET THE
TODAY'S SEISMIC CRITERIA FOR
STATE BUILDINGS SO WE ARE
REQUESTING ONE POINT ONE MILLION
SEVEN HUNDRED AND NINETY SEVEN
THOUSAND FROM THE GENERALFUND
TO COMPLETE THE ACQUISITION
PHASE OF THE DESIGN BUILD
PROJECT. SECOND OFFICE IS THE
BARSTOW OFFICE OF WHICH IS WHICH
OPENED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
THE CURRENT BUILDING IS NOT IN
COMPLIANCE WITH SEISMIC CRITERIA
AND IS SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERSIZED
AS WELL WE'RE REQUESTING THREE
MILLION. THREE MILLION EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO COMPLETE THE
ACQUISITION PHASE OF THIS
PROJECT. UNEX GOLD RUN AND WE
REQUESTED TWO MILLION ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN THOUSAND
FROM THE GENERAL FUND FOR THE
PERFORMANCE CRITERIA PHASE OF
THIS OFFICE REPLACEMENT. THE
CURRENT OFFICE OPENED IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR AND THE
FACILITY NOW HAS NUMBER
STRUCTURAL DEFICIENCIES AND HAS
EXPERIENCED NOTICEABLE MASS
IMPROVEMENT. MASS MOVEMENT I'M
SORRY OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS. LOS VAMOS IS NEXT ARE WE
REQUESTING TWO MILLION FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND
FROM THE GENERAL FUND FOR THE
ACQUISITION PHASE OF THE LOST
BATTLES AREA OFFICE THE EXISTING
FACILITY OPENED IN NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE IS UNDERSIZED AND
NEEDS PROGRAM HELP BAD. THE
FACILITY ALSO DOES NOT MEET THE
SEISMIC CRITERIA REQUIRED FOR
STATE OWNED BUILDINGS.
PORTERVILLE ARE REQUESTING ONE
POINT ONE MILLION TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO THOUSAND FROM THE
GENERAL FUND FOR THE ACQUISITION
PHASE REPORTER BILL EVERY OFFICE
REPLACEMENT OFFICE OPENED IN
NINETEEN SIXTY AND IS ONE OF THE
OLDEST AND MOST UNDERSIZED
OFFICES IN THE STATE ALSO DOES
NOT MEET THE SEISMIC CRITERIA.
REDDING AS AN OFFICE REPLACEMENT
PROJECT IS ENTERING AN
ACQUISITION PHASE AND WE'RE
REQUESTING ONE MILLION SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
COMPLETE THIS FACE. OUR OFFICE
OPENED IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
AND IS ALSO OLD UNDERSIZED AND
DOES NOT MEET SEISMIC CRITERIA.
NEXT ONE IS A TRACY OFFICE- AND
THE TRACY OFFICE WHERE. FIVE
MILLION FORTY TO SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND FROM THE MOTOR VEHICLE
COUNT FOR THE RELOCATION OF THE
NEW TRACY AREA OFFICE FOLLOWING
THE COMPLETION OF THE PROJECT
THAT STARTED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES A ONE TIME
FUNDING OF ONE MILLION NINE
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO. THOUSAND FOR
MOVING COSTS AND THREE MILLION
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND FOUR PRO RATED RENTAL
COSTS IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
ONGOING RENTAL COSTS WOULD BE
FOUR MILLION TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND IN THE YEARS
MOVING FORWARD. AND WITH THIS
PROPOSAL WE ANTICIPATE OCCUPYING
THE NEW FACILITY IN THE FALL OF
THIS YEAR. AND THE NEXT IS A
STATEWIDE PLANNING IN SIGHT
IDENTIFICATION IN ADDITION TO
THE PROJECTS DISCUSS WE'RE
REQUESTING ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
IDENTIFY SUITABLE PARCELS FOR
REPLACING UP TO FIVE ADDITIONAL
FIELD OFFICES AND TO DEVELOP
CITES STUDIES FOR THESE PARCELS
. THE PROPOSAL- WILL TO COMPLETE
ADVANCE PLANNING AND PERFORM
SITE SEARCHES FOR ADDITIONAL
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS
PREVIOUSLY IDENTIFIED AND
PRIORITIZED BY THE CHP AND DGS.
THE NEXT ONE IS FOR OUR JEEPERS
WHO LIVE I THINK PEAK TOWER ARE
FINALLY FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY- CP
BECAUSE FIVE MILLION FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND FROM
THE GENERAL FUND FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION PHASE OF THE C. H.
P. ENHANCE RADIO SYSTEM AT THE
LEVIATHAN IN THE VITAMIN E. AND
THIS REQUEST IS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE OUR ABILITY TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE CHEAPEST
PROJECT TO ADDRESS DETERIORATING
RADIO COMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND TO IMPROVE
INTER OPERABILITY AMONG VARIOUS
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES. AND THAT
A THIRD WILL COMPLETE OUR CAL
POLY REQUEST AND APOSS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'LL HEAR FROM- LA- MISSOURI.
AT THANK YOU JERRY UNITS HER
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH
THESE PROPOSALS ACUTE AS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS TO HAVE. LANCASTER PART
OF FINANCE NO CONCERNS. I
THOUGHT THANK YOU- MISTER
BENNETT YOU'RE THE ONLY MEMBER
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. HI TO
HEARING GOD NO QUESTIONS AND I
DON'T HAVE ANY- WE WILL MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AND
THAT'S- INCREASE FUNDING FOR
RECRUITMENT ADVERTISING ALL THAT
LIKE- EVERYONE ELSE YOU'RE
HAVING. SOME CHALLENGES AND- IN
THE RECRUITMENT PROCESS. YES SIR
WE ARE AND FOR THAT REASON NOW
TO SEIZE P. IS REQUESTING TWO
MILLION ANNUALLY FROM THE MOTOR
VEHICLE COUNT BUT THREE YEARS TO
SUPPORT OUR RECRUITMENT EFFORTS.
ARE THIS FUNDING WILL SUPPORT
THE INCREASED COST OF
ADVERTISING CAMPAIGNS IT WOULD
EXPAND THE SCOPE OF OUR
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS AND IMPROVE
THE DIVERSITY INCLUSIVENESS WHEN
WERE ADVERTISING. AT THE SEIZE
P. WHERE WE'RE COMMITTED CLEARLY
TO IDENTIFYING THE HIGHEST
QUALITY CANDIDATES WITH DIVERSE
LANGUAGE SKILLS AND CULTURAL
COMPETENCIES AND PEOPLE WHO
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA AND ITS
DIVERSE DEMOGRAPHIC MAKE UP
HOWEVER AS WE ALL AWARENESS YOU
JUST MENTION. THE RECRUITMENT OF
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL
HAS BEEN DECLINING ON A NATIONAL
LEVEL AND UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE
NOT IMMUNE TO THIS TREND SO MANY
FOR EFFORTS TO RECRUIT HIRE AND
RETAIN OFFICERS IS CRITICAL TO
PUBLIC SAFETY. AND ADVERTISING
TO THE PUBLIC IS THE FIRST STEP
IN THIS RECRUITMENT PROCESS SO
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE THE
C. H. P. WITH THE NECESSARY
FUNDING TO ENGAGE ADVERTISING
EXPERTISE DIGITAL AND PROGRAM
PROGRAMMATIC. MARKETING AND A
SECONDARY ADVERTISING TO REMAIN
COMPETITIVE IN AN UNPRECEDENTED
EVER CHANGING MARKETPLACE. AND I
SHOULD NOTE THAT THIS PROPOSAL
IS BUILT ON SOUND EXPERIENCE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN WE TESTED A
STATEWIDE- DIGITAL MARKETING
CAMPAIGN WITH OUTSTANDING
RESULTS ENDING DECEMBER TWENTY
NINETEEN AT THE ONSET OF THE
CAMPAIGN TO SEIZE P. RECEIVED
EIGHT HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE
APPLICATIONS. THIS NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS INCREASED
INCREMENTALLY MONTH OVER MONTH
DURING THE CAMPAIGN WHICH ENDED
WITH NEARLY SIXTEEN UNDER
APPLICATIONS RECEIVED IN JUNE OF
TWENTY TWENTY. HOWEVER I HAD
CHANGES TO DIGITAL MEDIA
ADVERTISING PRICES HAVE FORCED
THE PRICE OF THE DIGITAL
MARKETING TO RECORD LEVELS
ACROSS THE STATE AND THE NATION
AND A FORTY C. H. P. DIGITAL
MARKETING PROGRAM SIX ASSISTS
WITH THE- SUCCESSFULLY ORGANISED
TIME WE'VE REACHED OVER THREE
POINT. ONE MILLION POTENTIAL
APPLE AS AN ARTIST BY FOR
PROCESSING. EIGHTY PER OF THE
TWO APPLE WE SUPPOSED TO VERY
AND- AND VERY VERY- SUCCESSFUL
WAY FOR US TO ADVERTISE AND
RECRUIT AS OF THESE PROGRAMS WE
KNOW THEY'VE EEN PROVEN TO BE
THE BEST AND MOST EFFICIENT USE
OF OUR RESOURCES AND PROVIDE FOR
THE HIGHEST RETURN. ON
INVESTMENT IN THE FORM OF
CANDIDATE APPLICATIONS SO
FINALLY THE REQUESTED BUDGET.
INCREASE WAS SUPPORTED BRINGING
OFFICERS AND SUPPORT PERSONNEL
INTO THE DEPARTMENT THEREBY
REDUCING THE NEED FOR OVERTIME
TO MAINTAIN SERVICE LEVELS TO
THE COMMUNITIES WE SERVE. THANK
YOU. LATOKEN CAN I IF YOU SEE IN
ARE WITH THE LEGISLATIVE AND
OFFICE WE HAVE NO CONCERT THIS
FOR APARTMENT OF FINANCE. KATHY
MACLEOD OF FINANCE. THE OF
FINANCE NEW. THANK YOU A MISS
BENNETT. A TO REQUEST ONE YOU.
SEND ME- THAT TO SET TO STICKS
FOR THE HIGHWAY PATROL- BOTH IN
TERMS OF THE TOTAL THE TOTAL
FORCE A AND- ALSO FOR THE RECENT
HIRES IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS-
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR ME AND
THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE IS- I
REALLY UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE
WE'VE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR THE TWENTY
YEARS- OF ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ALSO- IN RECRUITMENT
CAMPAIGNS REALLY DO- WORK AND
THEIR EFFECTIVE- SO I APPRECIATE
THIS REQUEST AND THE CHALLENGES.
BUT TO WHAT EXTENT- ARE WE
HAVING DIFFICULTY FINDING
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES IN OTHER
WORDS PUT STATISTICS DO YOU HAVE
OF THE NO OF PEOPLE OF WHO AND
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THEM MAY IT
THROUGH THE BACKGROUND CHECK LET
- IN TERMS OF THIS COULD YOU
PROVIDE ME. AT LEAST MY OFFICE
AND NOT THE WHOLE COMMITTEE- THE
WITH THAT INFORMATION ALSO
PLEASE THANK YOU. YES SIR WE
WILL WILL DO THE BUT I'M IF I
CAN I WOULD JUST TELL YOU YOU
KNOW THAT- RIGHT NOW OUR CURRENT
TOTAL VACANCIES FOR THE C. H. P.
AS IN A UNIFORM RANKS READ- ONE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND SEVEN.
WHICH IS SIGNIFICANT IN HAS BEEN
DECLINING STEADILY FOR THE PAST-
OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS YOU
KNOW I WOULD SAY THOSE YEARS
HAVE BEEN THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
BUT I'M REALLY REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT THE ONE IN ONE THOUSAND
CAMPAIGN THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO LAUNCH. THESE MONIES YOU
KNOW THAT ARE GOING TO ALLOW US
TO OUR EFFORTS TO BE ABLE TO
RECRUIT A THOUSAND NEW
APPLICANTS YOU KNOW WHAT THEY
AND THE NEXT YEAR WHICH WOULD
BE. A 50% I MEAN THAT WOULD JUST
BE. DO REALLY SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO. INCREASE THE
AVERAGE NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS
WHERE WE'RE AT THIRTEEN THOUSAND
NOW AND WE WANT TO BRING THAT UP
TO AT LEAST TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
PER YEAR. TO BE ABLE TO CLAIM-
pTHAT WILL BE ABLE TO GO OUT
THERE AND PROVIDE US PUBLIC WITH
THE SERVICE THAT THEY DESERVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. SIR
OF- OF A COMMISSIONER FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE LEGIONS OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE WATCHING THIS- THIS
HEARING BOB CAN YOU DESCRIBE THE
IDEAL CANDIDATE TO BE A CHP
OFFICER- YES I THINK YOU SITTING
NEXT TO ME CLOSER. AND YOU KNOW
I'D BE AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT QUESTION AND THANK YOU FOR
IT AND I WOULD TELL YOU THAT'S
THE BEST A BIG PART OF OUR
CAMPAIGN IS YOU ARE THE C. H. P.
BECAUSE WHEN WE WENT BACK AND WE
LOOK AT THE TYPE OF PEOPLE THAT
WE HIRE WE HAVE JANITORS WE HAVE
PEOPLE WORK AT COSTCO WE HAVE
PEOPLE WHO WORK IN THE FOOD
SERVICE INDUSTRY AND SOMETIMES
PEOPLE ARE THINKING THAT HEY I
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
THAT BUT WHAT WE WANT FOR PEOPLE
WHO HAVE A HEART OF SERVICE YOU
KNOW IF YOU HAVE A HARD TO
SERVICE AND YOU WANT TO GO OUT
AND MAKE A DIFFERENCE. THEN YOU
ARE THE C. H. P. IF YOU MEET THE
AGE QUALIFICATIONS M. IN A
MINIMAL AND YOU KNOW WE DON'T-
YOU YOU HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL
DEGREE AND A HIGH SCHOOL- YOU
KNOW- DIPLOMA YOU'RE THE PERSON
WE'RE LOOKING FOR WE WANT YOU TO
COME OUT AND WE'LL TEACH YOU HOW
TO WEAR THE UNIFORM AND HOW TO
YOU KNOW BE A MEMBER TO SEE
THESE PEOPLE THAT YOU KNOW THE
PUBLIC THAT'S THE PEOPLE WE WANT
PEOPLE WITH A HEART OF SERVICE
AND PEOPLE WHO WANT TO GO OUT
THERE AND MAKE A DIFFERENCE SO-
WE REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
THIS CAMPAIGN AND GETTING OUT
THERE AND- SIZING THAT AND-
LETTING PEOPLE SEE THAT YOU KNOW
MYSELF. YOUR GROUP IN THE INNER
CITY. AND- YEAH KNOW. M. I HOPE
. THOSE ARE. THAT PEOPLE SEE YOU
KNOW THAT. I CAN BE SEEN AS
BEING YOUR ME. WE CAN ALL BE A
PART OF THIS- SOMETHING BIGGER
THAN YOURSELF AND BEING ABLE TO
SERVE THE PUBLIC. THAT'S GREAT
THANK THANK YOU- FOR THAT AND-
LOOK DON'T FORGET YOUR CAMPAIGN
GOT STARTED RIGHT HERE. IN THE
STATE NUMBER THREE. YOU WANT TO-
ARE- NEXT ITEM WHICH IS- ISSUE
NUMBER TWELVE- A FAR MORE- I
WELL A VERY IMPORTANT- ISSUE A
LITTLE BIT MORE SERIOUS- THEN-
AT THE END AND THEN MANDATE- AN
ISSUE THAT'S COME UP TO THE FOUR
REALLY IN THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
COMBATING. ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT AND I KNOW- THAT- THE CHP
HAS BEEN- REALLY- WORKING HARD
ON THAT. YES SIR AND I'M REALLY
PROUD OF OUR EFFORTS BUT I AND I
HOPEFULLY AND I KNOW OF TALKING
A LITTLE BIT IN A MINUTE BUT
THAT YOU SEE THE CORRELATION
BETWEEN THE RECRUITMENT EFFORTS.
AND HAVING THE PERSONNEL TO BE
ABLE TO THE TAKE ON THIS NEW-
ASPECT IN AND WITH ORGANIZED
RETAIL CRIME TEST WITH OUR
REBEKAH TASK FORCE. AND FOR THAT
REASON AND- TO SEE IF YOU WERE
REQUESTING- SIX MILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND THROUGH THE FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TO
TWENTY FIVE. YOU'RE REQUESTING
TEN POINT FIVE MILLION IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY FIVE TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX AND THEN FIFTEEN
MILLION FOR PERMANENT
AUGMENTATION BEGINNING IN YEARS
TWENTY TWENTY SIX AND TWENTY
SEVEN. TO MAKE OUR ORGANIZED
RETAIL CRIME TASK FORCE
OPERATIONS PERMANENT AND THIS
FUNDING HAS BEEN ALLOWED TO
SEIZE HE TO FULFILL OUR
LEGISLATIVELY. REQUIREMENTS
UNDER ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THIRTY
ONE WHICH WAS AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOICE ALL YEAR.
AND MAKE PERMANENT THE CHP'S
EFFORTS TO COMBAT ORGANIZED
RETAIL CRIME STATE WHITE.
DEPARTMENT WE PREVIOUSLY AND
TWENTY IF YOU'RE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY RECEIVE. A FIVE POINT
SEVENTY SIX BILLION TO ESTABLISH
OUR RETAIL CRIMES TASK FORCE
TEAMS IN THREE. INDIVIDUALS
WHICH INCLUDED GOLDEN GATE WHICH
IS THE BAY AREA BORDER I'M WHICH
IS DOWN SOUTH IN THIS- SAN DIEGO
AREA. AND SOUTHERN DIVISION
WHICH INCLUDES THE GREATER LOS
ANGELES AREA. AT LEAST THE THREE
TASK FORCE TEAMS THAT. HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL AND COLLABORATING
WITH RETAILERS ALLIED AGENCY LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL AND THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S TO IDENTIFY
AND PROSECUTE ORGANIZED
GATHERINGS. RECOVER FILES MARGIN
. AND REDUCES. CRIME AND THEIR
RESTRAINING OF THE HARD WORK OF
THE OFFICERS ASSIGNED TO THESE
TEAMS THAT THEY'VE DONE IT AND
THE SUCCESS THAT THEY'VE HAD IN
COMBATING THIS GROWING PROBLEM.
ASSIST OUR TASK FORCE WAS
LEGISLATIVELY AUTHORIZED TWENTY
NINETEEN WE PARTICIPATED IN AND
AS THOUSAND RETAIL CRIME CASES.
A MONSTER WE DO REACHED THIS
WEEK ARE WE COVERED OVER TO ONE
TUNE ESTO EMERGENT. AND HAVE
MADE NEARLY FOUR IF ARRESTS.
IT'S A BIG FOR YOU FIVE AS A
COME IN THE HOUSE. AND TO TALK
TO YOU. ALTHOUGH I FEEL LIKE
STATISTICS ARE. I ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE IS A NEED TO EXPAND
OUR RETAIL THEFT INVESTIGATIONS
IN EDUCATION. TO OTHER AREAS
EXPERIENCING ORGANIZED RETAIL
CRIME TO INCLUDE A GREATER
SACRAMENTO AREA AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. AND SO THE PROPOSAL IS
SEEKING SIX MILLION THROUGH.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE FOR PROACTIVE ENFORCEMENT.
BY EXISTING CHP DETECTIVES
INVESTIGATORS AND ROPA CHAU
OFFICERS. IN OUR VALUES CENTER
DIVISIONS AND THE TEN POINT FIVE
MILLION WILL BE TO AUGMENT
EXISTING TASK FORCE BINDING. AND
THEN THE FIFTEEN MILLION THERE
WILL BE BEGINNING IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN WOULD BE
TO PROVIDE PERMANENT FUNDING.
FOR THE FIVE CT DIVISION IS
EXPERIENCING THE HIGHEST
ORGANIZED ORGANIZED RETAIL
CRIME. AND ADDITIONALLY- THIS
PROPOSAL WILL ALLOW TO SEIZE P.
TO PURCHASE ADDITIONAL EQUIPMENT
AND TECHNOLOGY BASED PLATFORMS
FOR INVESTIGATIVE USE. AND THESE
TOOLS BY DESIGNER GOING TO
ASSIST THE DEPARTMENT- WITH CORN
. THE STATEWIDE. TO THE RETAIL
AT PROBLEMS THROUGH DATA
COLLECTION AND EDUCATION THE
EVALUATION. LOOKING AT ANALYTICS
AND THE DISSEMINATION TO CHP
INVESTIGATORS. AND ALLIED
AGENCIES ALIKE- FOR EXAMPLE ARE
ALL RIGHT BYE- SCANNERS. I WILL
ALLOW EASIER DIDN'T. OF STOLEN
OR- AND ALLOW FOR US TO RETURN
THE PROPERTY TO THE RETAILER
VICTIMS. OTHER EQUIPMENT SUCH AS
SPECIALIZED COMPUTERS AND LARGE
CAPACITY HARD DRIVES ARE GOING
TO. ARE GOING TO HELP US TO BE
ABLE TO PROCESS AND STORED LARGE
AMOUNTS OF DATA VIDEO AUDIO AND
OTHER DIGITAL MEDIA EVIDENCE.
THAT ARE CRITICAL TO THESE TYPES
OF COMPLEX INVESTIGATIONS SO THE
TRACKING DATA AND TRENDS
ASSOCIATED WITH RETAIL THEFT.
CAN ALSO ASSISTED DETECTION AND
INVESTIGATION AFFILIATED CRIMES-
SO. MANY EXAMPLES IN THE INCLUDE
VEHICLE BURGLARY AND THERE'S A
LOT OF SOLICITING CRIME TO COME
A RETAIL THEFT BURGLARY IDENTITY
THEFT CREDIT CARD. FRAUD FORGERY
SEE THAT IS THE ONLY PROP AND
ASSOCIATE CYBER. TO USE TAKEN.
AND HOW TO LIVE WILL ALLOW THE
SIEGE. AT THE STATE OFFICE MAY.
TO IDEAL. REAL TIME. RATES TRY.
AND THEN USE THESE TRENDS AND
PATTERNS TO DRIVE FUTURE
DEPLOYMENT STRATEGIES AND THE
DISTRIBUTION OF RESOURCES. SO
LIMITED IF YOU CAN LIVE A LONG
BEFORE I CLOSE THIS ONE TAKE ONE
MOMENT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
PREVENTATIVE WORK. THAT WE'VE
DONE IN EDUCATION- BECAUSE NOT
JUST ENFORCEMENT EDUCATION IS
IMPORTANT AND WE PARTNER WITH
VARIOUS RETAILERS AT A RETAIL
ASSOCIATION TO PROVIDE SAFETY
AND SECURITY TRAINING- SO THAT
THE RETAILERS BOTH SMALL AND
LARGE THEY KNOW HOW TO BETTER
PROTECT THEMSELVES. AGAINST
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT AND
CLOSING IN A RELATIVELY SHORT
TIME HAS A STATED AT THE
BEGINNING- WE SUCCESSFULLY
DEMONSTRATED THE ABILITY TO
EFFECTIVELY COMBAT ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT CRIME IN
CALIFORNIA. USING BOTH EDUCATION
AND ENFORCEMENT AND FOR THAT
REASON RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING
SUPPORT. THIS PROPOSAL TO ALLOW
THE EXPANSION OF THE PROGRAM
INTO OTHER AREAS CURRENTLY
UNDERSERVED AND. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU L. A. O.
ECONOMY. AT THANK CHAIR UNITS
ROAD LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. AT SO THIS PROPOSAL IS
ONE OF NINE THAT MAKES UP THE
GOVERNOR'S UP PROPOSED PUBLIC
SAFETY PACKAGE- OVERALL WE FOUND
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PACKAGE
LACKS CLEAR OBJECTIVES FOR
ACHIEVING THE INTENDED PUBLIC
SAFETY GOALS AND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE- MAY DETERMINE THAT
THERE ARE OTHER. PUBLIC SAFETY
GOALS THAT ARE OF HIGHER
PRIORITY- ADDITIONALLY WE FOUND
THAT CERTAIN PROPOSALS INCLUDING
THIS ONE MAY NOT BE STRUCTURED
TO. ACHIEVE ITS DESIRED
OUTCOMES- IN REDUCING ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT CRIME. UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL THE ADMINISTRATION IS
REQUESTING TO STAFF THE
EXPANSION OF THE TASK FORCE WITH
OVERTIME AS C. H. B. CURRENTLY
DOES NOT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DEDICATE FULL TIME OFFICERS TO
THE NEW PROPOSED TASK FORCES DUE
TO A HIGH VACANCY RATE. S. WITH
OVERTIME COULD FACE CHALLENGES
AND CAN IMPACT THE- OUTCOMES
ACHIEVED- IN ADDITION WE NOTE
THAT DOJ WITH ITS EXISTING
EXPERTISE WITH DEDICATED TASK
FORCES AS WELL AS MANAGING TASK
FORCES WITH. VARIOUS PARTNERS
COULD BE A BETTER ENTITY TO
ADMINISTER ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT TASK FORCES PARTICULARLY
IF THE STATE IS INTERESTED IN
THOSE COORDINATED BY CRIMINAL
GANGS AND THAT WORKS- DOJ ALSO
EMPLOYS BOTH LAW ENFORCEMENT
INVESTIGATIVE PERSONNEL AND
ATTORNEYS WHICH CAN MAKE IT
EASIER FOR THEM TO WORK
TOGETHER. TO SUCCESSFULLY
INVESTIGATE AND PROSECUTE CASES.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR COMMENTS AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THANK U. S. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- DO YOU HAVE- A
REPORT AND OR A RESPONSE TO THE
L. A. O.'S COMMENTS. CATHY
MCLEOD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
I'M. C. H. P. WAS PASSED WITH
ORGANIZED RETAIL TASK FORCE MADE
DONE A PHENOMENAL JOB. AND I'M
SORRY AND THEY DONE A PHENOMENAL
JOB AND. I DON'T SEE IT
NECESSARY TO MOVE IT AWAY FROM
THEM. ALL RIGHT- THANK YOU I'M A
COMMISSIONER I HAVE A QUESTION
FOR YOU ABOUT THE I MEAN YOU YOU
DID DESCRIBE THE- THE- ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT- AS HAVING A VERY
VERY BROAD- A FORTY OVER A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT- CRIMES AND
HOW IT EXPANDS OUTWARD INTO
VARIOUS AREAS- DOES IT ALSO
INCLUDE- DIFFERENT AREAS WHERE
ORGANIZED THEFT BUT PERHAPS NOT
RETAIL THEFT- IS INVOLVED IN
WHAT COMES TO MIND- FOR ME IS-
ORGANIZED AUTOMOBILE THEFT AND
THE- CATALYTIC CONVERTER. THIS
IS SOMETHING I AM KEENLY AWARE
OF BECAUSE I'VE HAD TWO OF THEM
STOLEN- CATALYTIC CONVERTER
THEFT. YOU MISTER I THINK WOULD
AGREE IT WITH REGARD TO CASH OUT
OF BATH AND CAL THE CONVERTER
YOU KNOW WE ARE THE LEADING
AGENCY WITH- IDLE FAST AND
CALIFORNIA WITH A BONAFIDE.
MEMBER CORRECTLY I THINK WE HAVE
ABOUT A NINETY FOUR PERCENT- YOU
KNOW- RETENTION RATE WHERE WE
WERE WE ABLE TO RECOVER THOSE
VEHICLES THAT INVEST OLD AND- IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT IS SOMETHING
WHERE- WE DO HAVE A OUTSTANDING
PROGRAM FOR THAT. THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS YES OR BIG CONCERN
AND- YOU KNOW I THINK THAT IS
THAT THAT'S A THAT'S A PART OF
OUR HER NORMAL DUTIES I WOULD
TELL YOU WITHOUT F. AND BECAUSE
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE DO.
THE CALIFORNIA N. AS WELL AS IN
AS A PUBLIC SERVICE AGENCY BUT
AS A POST IT WITH WITH THIS WITH
I WAS A RETAIL. AND THEN I DON'T
HAVE I WILL SEE THEIR THERE TO
THEIR LANES YOU KNOW BUT YES
BECAUSE THEY COULD LINES MASS SO
THEY DO THE- IN THE CASE WE JUST
DID RECENTLY YES I WOULD SAY THE
CARS THE VEHICLES THAT THEY WERE
IN WERE STOLEN SO. THEY OFTEN DO
IN. SOMETHING THOSE ARE
STATISTICS THAT WE. WE KEEP AS
WELL. WELL OKAY I JUST WANT-
PERHAPS THE DEFINITION THAT WE
USE FOR ORGAN- AFTER. IS CAN. BY
ADDING THE WORD RETAIL WHEREAS-
YOU KNOW THERE ARE. THERE ARE
PROBABLY MANY OTHER PLACES WHERE
THERE ARE- UNHAPPY HAD A
QUALITIES OF ORGANIZED AFTER.
AND WE WANT TO PAY ATTENTION TO
ALL OF THEM. YES SIR WE DO I
JUST THINK WITH RETAIL THEFT I
THINK THAT'S JUST BASICALLY USE
MATCH ABOUT SOME OF THE OTHER
ORGANIZED CRIME RINGS I THINK
THEY HAVE TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS
ON. PARTICULARLY JUST THOSE ARE
WORKING WITH OUR ALLIED PARTNERS
IN AND US TO LIKE WITH SOME OF
THE TASK FORCE WITH DOJ WE
PARTICIPATE ON THOSE TASK FORCES
WELL AND MAKE SURE THOSE
RESOURCES ARE ARE CENTERED ON
THOSE CRIMES BUT YES LIKE I SAID
THEY HAVE TENTACLES. AND THEY DO
REACH OUT AND TOUCH OTHER AREAS
THAT WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR I
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO PULL
YOUR FOCUS AWAY FROM- THE RETAIL
ASPECT OF THIS MY DISTRICT- HAS
BEEN PARTICULARLY HARD HIT. BY A
BY ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT AND
SITE A COMMAND HERE- AGUIRRE. OF
FOCUS ON THE ON ON ON THAT
ISSUE. MISTER BENNETT AND THE
QUESTIONS RIGHT GETTING. OF CAN
GO ON TO ISSUE FOR. ANOTHER
SERIOUS TOPIC THE- VIOLENCE.
SPORES YES IT IS A THIS- VERY
PROUD OF THIS FOR AND THE CAL
HIGHWAY. IS REQUESTING A ONE
TIME FUNDING FROM THE GENERAL
FUND OF FOUR MILLION AT THIRTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
THREE MILLION THREE HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN THOUSAND IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND
THREE MILLION THREE HUNDRED
FOURTEEN THOUSAND AND FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. TO
ADDRESS THE INCREASE IN VIOLENT
CRIMES OCCURRING ON STATE
HIGHWAYS. AT THESE VIOLENT
CRIMES THE INCLUDE FREEWAY
SHOOTINGS HOMICIDES ASSAULTS
RAPES. BATTERIES AND- AND ALLOW
CRIMES INVOLVING OBJECTS THROWN
OR CITED VEHICLES AND DUE TO THE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN VIOLENT
CRIMES COMMITTED ON STATE
HIGHWAYS IN RECENT YEARS AS HE'S
BE CREATED A HIGHWAY VIOLENCE
TASK FORCE. ALTHOUGH STILL IN
ITS INFANCY STAGES THE FUNDING
IDENTIFIED IN THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD PROVIDE INVESTIGATIVE AND
ENFORCEMENT EQUIPMENT
INVESTIGATIVE TECHNOLOGY NEEDS
AND OPERATIONAL EXPENSES NEEDED
TO SUPPORT THE TASK FORCE- THE
PROPOSAL ALSO WILL FACILITATE.
CONCENTRATED ENFORCEMENT DETAILS
TO VERY IMPORTANT AND UTILIZED
INVESTIGATIVE TOOLS TO BOTH
APPREHEND VIOLATORS AND CURB
FUTURE INCIDENTS. I WANT OF
SPECIFIC CONCERN FOR US IS-
PARTICULARLY WITHIN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE COMMUNITIES
WE SERVE OUR FREEWAY SHOOTINGS
YOU KNOW THIS PROPOSAL WILL
ASSIST THE CHP REDUCING INCREASE
VIOLENCE SOME CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAYS. BY ADDRESSING
EMERGENCY EMERGING MEET. FOR
INCREASED LAW ENFORCEMENT
PRESENCE AS WELL AS
INVESTIGATIVE TOOLS TO ASSIST IN
APPREHENSION AND. PROSECUTION IN
YOU PUT ALL CONCEPT ENFORCEMENT
IDENTIFY OKAY. OF CRIME
INTENSELY. IS UNKNOWN EFFECTIVE
CA. AND PROACTIVELY CRIMINAL ACT
IT WORKS YOU KNOW THERE'S
NOTHING LIKE SEEING A BLACK AND
WHITE. ON THE ROAD AND THAT WILL
HELP DETER CRIME. THIS PROPOSAL
IS SIX TWO MILLION ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY THOUSAND AN OVERTIME
FUNDING FOR THE CONCENTRATED
ENFORCEMENT DETAILS THROUGHOUT
THE CHP FIELD DIVISIONS MOST
AFFECTED BY HIGHWAY VIOLENCE. IN
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
A NEED FOR COMPREHENSIVE CRIME
ANALYTICS AND A DEDICATED
ANALYTICAL PERSONNEL TO. COLLATE
AGGREGATE AND ANALYZE TO CRIME
DATA AND THESE RESOURCES THEY
TELL YOU THEY'RE GOING TO ALLOW
US TO CLOSE THE CURRENT GAP IN
STATE RIGHT ANALYTICAL TOOLS.
AND ALLOW TO SEIZE P.
INVESTIGATORS TO IDENTIFY REAL
TIME CRIME RATES TRANSCEND
PATTERNS. AND TO ADDRESS THIS
NEED THE PROPOSAL REQUESTING
FIVE HUNDRED ELEVEN THOUSAND
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO FIND
SALARIES AND BENEFITS FOR SEVEN
ANALYST POSITIONS TO ANALYZE
THESE CRIME DATA AND CONDUCT
CRIMINAL ANALYTIC AND RESEARCH-
THIS PROPOSAL WE ALSO REQUEST
THE NINE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND TO PROVIDE FREE
TRAINING I T. AND EQUIPMENT
COSTS. ULTIMATELY EACH ASPECT OF
THIS PROPOSAL WAS SUPPORTED C.
H. P.'S WORK TOWARDS REDUCTION
OF VIOLENT CRIMES ON CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAYS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LOL THANK YOU CHAIR AT EUNICE
ROW AT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AT. SO WE HAVE A COUPLE
OF COMMENTS WITH REGARDS TO THIS
PROPOSAL M. TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDERS
HIGHWAY VIOLENCE A PRIORITY I
WANT TO DEDICATE THIS THEME
OVERALL AMOUNT OF RESOURCES AT
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES WE
RECOMMEND MODIFYING THE PER-
PROPOSAL IN WAYS TO ENSURE THE
FUNDED ACTIVITIES WILL BE MOST
EFFECTIVE IN MEETING THEIR
OBJECTIVES. FIRST WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER OTHER
ACTIVITIES TO REDUCE HIGHWAY
VIOLENCE AS MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY
C. H. P. IS CURRENTLY FACING A
HIGH VACANCY RATE AND AS A
RESULT SIMILAR TO THE RETAIL
THEFT TASK FORCE AT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
STAFF THIS HAS FIRST WITH
OVERTIME AS WELL SINCE HE'S P.
DOES NOT HAVE THE- THAT A FULL
TIME. OFFICERS TO THE PROPOSED
TASK FORCE STAFFING- THAT WITH
OVERTIME AND WITHOUT DEDICATED
POSITIONS CAN BE CHALLENGING AND
POTENTIALLY IMPACT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE TASK FORCE
UNTIL SEIZE P. ADDRESSES THEIR
VACANCY ISSUES THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WANT TO CONSIDER OTHER
ALTERNATIVES THAT COULD. HELP
REDUCE CRIME SUCH AS THE
INSTALLATION OF CAMERAS ARE
LIGHTING SECOND WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
PROPOSED FUNDING FOR THE SEVEN
ASSOCIATE- GOVERNOR IN A PROGRAM
ANALYST POSITIONS AS WELL AS THE
TRAINING I. T. AND EQUIPMENT
COSTS TO SUPPORT CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS WE FIND THAT
THESE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES COULD
HELP PROVIDE THAT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
ASSOCIATED FACTORS OF HIGHWAY
SHOOTINGS. AND HELP INFORM
FUTURE LEGISLATIVE POLICY AND
FUNDING DECISIONS REGARDING THE
TASK FORCE. AT THIRD WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CHANGED THE FUNDS SOURCE FOR OF
THIS PROPOSAL FROM GENERAL FUND
TO THE MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT
GIVEN THAT THIS PROPOSAL IS
INTENDED TO DIRECTLY BENEFIT YOU
THERE'S OF THE STATE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM IT WOULD BE MORE
APPROPRIATE TO USE MBA FOR THESE
ACTIVITIES. AND FINALLY WE
RECOMMEND REQUIRING THAT SEES P.
TO REPORT ON THE NUMBER AND
LOCATIONS OF HIGHWAY SHOOTINGS
DISSOCIATED FACTORS IN THE
SHOOTINGS AS WELL AS THE
OUTCOMES. OF THE INVESTIGATIVE
RESOURCES- THE REPORT COULD
ALLOW THE LED TO DID. WHETHER
FUTURE RESOURCES- ARE NEEDED TO
CONTINUE THE TASK FORCE AFTER
THE EXPIRATION OF THE PROPOSED
LIMIT TERM FUNDING. AND THAT
CONCLUDES OUR COMMENTS HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
COMMENTS. THANK YOU CHAIR CATHY
MCLEOD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M
ON THE GENERAL FUND VERSES THE
NBA WE JUST LIKE TO KNOW THAT
YOU KNOW WELL THIS IS AN
ADMINISTRATION PRIORITY AND- AT
THIS TIME OF THE GENERAL FUND
SURPLUS. AND GIVEN IT'S A THREE
YEAR LIMITED TERM PROPOSAL WE
FELT THAT WAS A GOOD FIT FOR
GENERAL FUND. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. IT IT SOUNDS LIKE A THIS
IS- AN ISSUE THAT IS- GONNA NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED LONG TERM- AND
DATA SO WHY OF. THE FILL THESE
POSITIONS WITH OVERTIME VERSUS
PERMANENT POSITIONS. WELL SIR
THAT IS THE PLAN MOVING FORWARD
IS THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO- PUT
PERMANENT MEMBERS ON A TASK
FORCE AS WE FILL OUR CURRENT
VACANCIES BUT RIGHT NOW I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE ME THIS PROBLEM
EXISTS TODAY SO I HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT I AM I AM PUSHING
RESOURCES TOWARDS THE ISSUES
THAT ARE OCCURRING WHERE THEY'RE
CARRYING YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
TRACKING THE LOCATIONS IN USING.
ALL THESE MLAS CURRENTLY THIS IS
GOING TO MAKE US IS A LOT MORE
EFFICIENT IN DOING THAT BUT
RIGHT NOW WE ARE DOING IT AND
USING WHAT WITH THE RESOURCES
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE IS THIS
YOU KNOW THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
IS ONGOING AND WE WILL ASK YOU
KNOW WHAT I'M SORRY NUMBERS GO
UP- HER VACANCY RATE GOES DOWN
AND WE WOULD DEFINITELY BE
PUTTING IN PERMANENT. BODIES IN
THESE POSITIONS- THANK YOU FOR
THAT. QUESTION THE RELIGION JUST
YOU KNOW THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
CHALLENGES THEY THEY HAVE LOTS
OF VACANCIES I THINK L. A. O.
WAS VERY VERY APPROPRIATE TO
POINT OUT BEING STRETCHED I'D
REALLY APPRECIATE FROM THE
HIGHWAY PATROL STANDPOINT-
SOMEBODY'S GETTING WE WERE
HAVING A OF A VIOLENT CRIME
PROBLEM. PUBLIC CERTAINLY
DOESN'T WANT TO HEAR AND IT'S
NOT THE PUBLIC'S INTEREST TO SAY
WELL WE'RE JUST NOT GONNA DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT BUT- IT.
REALLY EMPHASIZES THE IMPORTANCE
OF GETTING THESE THOUSAND
POSITIONS- IT'S RECRUITED AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND TRAINED
UP AND IMPLEMENT THAT- AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE IF THERE'S
NO GOOD SOLUTION BECAUSE-
CERTAINLY IF WERE BURNING OVER
TIME WITH LOTS OF PEOPLE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF INVESTIGATIONS
AND EVERYTHING ELSE DOES SUFFER.
AS WELL AS A LONG TERM MORALE IF
YOU'RE BRINGING OVER TIME ON ON
THE- ON THE HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICERS. FOR ANY SIGNIFICANT
PERIOD OF TIME THANK YOU. OKAY
SIR THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENT
AND ALSO JUST KNOWING THAT WE
ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE TO OF SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ELIADES- TALKED
ABOUT- INCLUDING CAMERAS AND
OTHER THINGS THAT WILL BE ABLE
TO USE TO. TO AUGMENT. OUR OUR
OFFICER POSITIONS THAT ARE OUT
THERE AS WELL. YOU KNOW USING
TECHNOLOGY WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS AT THE DOT AND EVERYONE
ELSE. DEFINITELY A JOINT EFFORT
. GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THAT TAKES US TO ISSUE FOURTEEN-
WHICH IS- STAFFING FOR- GRANT
PROGRAMS SET OUT OF THE CAMPUS
TAX BUT- YES SIR- THE CHP WERE
REQUESTING AUTHORITY TO HIRE
NINE ADDITIONAL POSITIONS TO
PROVIDE HE NECESSARY OVERSIGHT
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
CANNABIS TAX GRANT FROM PROGRAM.
AS REQUIRED BY THE PASSAGE OF
BOTH THE CONTROL REGULATE
REGULATORY AND TAX ADULT USE OF
MARIJUANA ACT IN THE MEDICINAL
AND ADULT USE OF CANNABIS
REGULATION AND SAFETY ACT THERE
WAS A LOT SORRY. AND AS
SPECIFIED IN THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION COOLED THE PORTION OF
THE CANNABIS TAXES ARE
DISTRIBUTED TO THE C. H. P. FOR
THE PURPOSES OF COORDINATING
RESEARCH EFFORTS RELATED TO
IMPAIRED DRIVING. CONDUCTING
TRAINING FOR C. H. P. AND OTHER
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES ASSISTING YOU IN
EXISTING IMPAIRED DRIVING
ENFORCEMENT TECHNOLOGIES AND
ADMINISTERING IMPAIRED DRIVING
GRANTS AND TO DATE THE CHP HAS
UNDERTAKEN SEVERAL SIGNIFICANT
CANNABIS RELATED PROJECTS AND
HAS GREATLY EXPANDED EXISTING
CANNABIS RELATED PROGRAMS.
DISEASE PEOPLE RECEIVE AN
APPROPRIATION OF FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND THIS
WILL CREATE ADDITIONAL GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE. VERTICAL PROSECUTION
PROGRAMS AND CONTINUE TOXICOLOGY
LABORATORY DEVELOPMENT- WITH THE
ANTICIPATED WORKLOAD INCREASE
THE ORIGINAL PERSONNEL RESOURCES
PROVIDED WILL BE INSUFFICIENT AS
THE PROGRAM CONTINUES TO EXPAND
WITH INCREASE FUNDING AND GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES AS SUCH. THE
DEPARTMENT REQUEST THE AUTHORITY
TO HIRE NINE ADDITIONAL
PERSONNEL TO EFFECTIVELY
ADMINISTER AND MANAGE MANDATE IT
CANNABIS PROGRAMS. THE FUNDING
FOR THE NINE ADDITIONAL
PERSONNEL WILL COME FROM THE
CANNABIS TAX FINE. IF APPROVED.
IS PICKING CONTINUE TO DEVELOP
NEW IMPAIRED DRIVING RESEARCH
AND TECHNOLOGY VALUATION
PROJECTS INCLUDING THOSE RELATED
TO CANNABIS THE EMPLOYMENT AT
AND IMPLEMENT BEST PRACTICES THE
BETTER HE'S UNIFIED IMPAIRED
DRIVERS ESPECIALLY THOSE
IMPAIRED BY CANNABIS. AND REMOVE
THEM FROM OUR ROADWAYS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU L. L. I UNITS RODE
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. BERMAN OF FIVE
FINANCE- DO YOU HAVE A REPORT
AND MAKE A NOTE THAT THERE- THE
STAFF COMMENTS- POSE A QUESTION
ABOUT TO- THE DECISION MAKING
FOR ALLOCATIONS- ONE TWO AND
THREE FROM. A FOR THE FOR THE
TAX FUND AND HOW LEGISLATURE CAN
HAVE INFLUENCE ON THOSE
ALLOCATIONS IF YOU COULD RESPOND
TO THAT HAVE A GREAT. CATHY
MCLEOD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
YEAH AS NOTED IN PROP SIXTY FOUR
STARTING JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT. THE BUDGETING FOR
ALLOCATION ONE GOES TO A MORE
STANDARD MODEL WHERE. WE PROPOSE
IN THE LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATES
AND UNTIL THAT TIME IT WE WORK
WITH DEPARTMENTS AND THOSE
AFFECTED AND BUDGET BASED ON THE
SETS NEED AND THEN KEEP THE
LEGISLATURE INFORMED. THAT'S
ALLOCATION ONE- THAT'S THAT IS
ALLOCATION ONE. OF MY ALLOCATION
THREE WHICH IS WHAT THE CHP USES
THEIR FUNDS ARE USED FOR
RESEARCH AND ACTIVITIES RELATED
TO THE LEGALIZATION OF CANNABIS
AND THE AFFECTS ON ITS
CRIMINALIZATION- THEY ARE CALLED
OUT. IN STATUTES THAT 60% TO
EDUCATION PREVENTION AND
TREATMENT 20% THE CLEAN UP
REMEDIATION AND ENFORCEMENT. OF
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS IN THE 20%
TO PUBLIC SAFETY RELATED
ACTIVITIES AFTER JANUARY THE
WHIMS JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT THEN THE LEGISLATURE WILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO. MODIFY
STATUTE IF THEY SO CHOOSE. AND
THAT LEAVES- ALLOCATION NUMBER
TWO I THINK. I AM I AM I CAN GET
BACK TO YOU ON THAT I DON'T HAVE
ANY ALLOCATION TO POT SO I DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY HOW THAT IS
ALLOCATED OUT. YEAH THAT BE
GREAT IF YOU COULD DO THAT WOULD
APPRECIATE WILL DO THAT. AND SIR
IF I MAY UM INCLUDING THE BODIES
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ARE
GOING TO BE- BODIES THAT ARE
GONNA BE TO OUR PROFESSIONAL
STAFF SO THIS DOESN'T IMPACT
SOME OF THE OTHER PROGRAMS AS
MUCH AS- YOU KNOW THE- IT WOULD.
AS BEING DISCUSSED AS WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU REALIZE THAT
THEIR BODIES THEY WERE ADDING OR
MORE TO DEAL WITH THE- WITH THE
PROGRAMMATIC SIDE OF. OF
DISTRIBUTING THE FUNDS IN THE
FUNDS THAT WE HAVE COMING IN.
UNDERSTOOD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. LESSONS NOPE ALL RIGHT THAT
TAKES US WE'RE GETTING DOWN TO
THE HOME STRETCH HERE- FIFTEEN.
HE IS TO FIFTEEN- THIS IS
CENTRALIZED HISTORIAN OF RECORDS
AND THE CHP IS REQUESTING A TWO
YEAR LIMITED TERM FUNDING OF SIX
HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX THOUSAND-
FROM THE MOTOR VEHICLE COUNT IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. AND FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR FOR SIX
POSITIONS TO ESTABLISH A
CENTRALIZED CUSTODIAN OF RECORDS
UNIT WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT'S
COMMUNICATIONS CENTER THE
SUPPORT SECTION I WITH THE
PASSING OF THE NEW LAWS RELATIVE
TO PUBLIC RECORDS ACTS. ESTATE
WHY PERRY REQUEST CONTINUE TO
INCREASE- ESTABLISHING CUSTODIAN
OF RECORDS UNIT WILL INCREASE
THE SPEED EFFICIENCY ACCURACY
AND TRANSPARENCY OF THIS HUGE
PIECE RESPONSES TO PR RACE. AS A
QUICK BACKGROUND THE CHP
OPERATES TWENTY FIVE
COMMUNICATIONS CENTERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THE UNIT
PROPOSED IN THIS B. C. P. WOULD
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR P. R. A
REQUEST SUBMITTED TO THE FOUR
LARGEST COMMUNICATIONS CENTERS
WHICH ARE BORDER COMMUNICATIONS
WHICH IS A SAN DIEGO AS A STATE
GOLDEN GATE COMMUNICATIONS WHICH
IS IN THE BAY AREA. LOS ANGELES
COMMUNICATIONS AND ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNICATIONS CENTERS I THE
UNIT WILL ASSUME ALL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR RESPONDING TO
VARIOUS REQUESTS AS WELL AS
REQUESTS FOR COMMUNICATIONS LOGS
AUDIO AND AUDIO RECORDINGS WHICH
WE GET MANY MANY OF. AND AS A
MEASURE OF THE UNITS OUTCOMES
AND ACCOUNTABILITY PRIOR TO THE
CONCLUSION OF THE TWO YEAR
PERIOD OF THIS PROPOSAL WILL
EVALUATE THE PROGRAM'S
EFFECTIVENESS AT. THESE
INDETERMINATE NO COMMUNICATION
CENTERS CAN BE ADDED TO THE.
FOUR I JUST IDENTIFIED. I THE
AMOUNT. WILLING A REVIEW OF
STATE WORKING. THE TOTAL REQUEST
. AN AVERAGE PROCESSING TIME THE
TIMELY RELEASE OF POLICE RECORDS
IS VITAL IN MAINTAINING TRUST
AND LEGITIMACY WITH BOTH THE
PUBLIC AND THE LEGISLATURE AND
WE KNOW THAT IT'S NECESSARY TO
MAINTAIN COMPLIANCE WITH LAW.
ULTIMATELY IT IS OUR INTENT%
AFTER SHOWING THE EFFECTIVENESS
AND EFFICIENCY OF THE UNIT TO
RETURN EVERY QUEST TO MAKE THE
CUSTODIAN OF RECORDS UNITS ARE
PROMINENT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
L. A- COMMENTS I UNITS WROTE THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU CHAIR CATHY
MCLEOD'S DEPARTMENT FINANCE WE
HAVE NOTHING ELSE TO ADD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I GUESS- MY
QUESTION ON THIS HAS TO DO WITH-
THE- IT WOULD STRIKE ME THAT-
THE SMALLER- UNITS AROUND THE
STATE WOULD- BENEFIT FROM HAVING
A CENTRALIZED SYSTEM SINCE IT
PROBABLY TAKES A GREATER
PERCENTAGE OF THEIR TIME TO
REQUEST TO RESPOND OR A PR REYES
SO WHY NOT INCLUDE SOME OR ALL
OF THEM. FROM THE GET GO. I
THINK THERE IS ISSUE WITH WHEN
WE LOOKED AT OUR STRUCTURE THE
WAY IT WAS STRUCTURED IN MOST
THINGS ARE HERE AT THE
HEADQUARTERS IN SACRAMENTO WE
WANTED TO TEST WE ALWAYS KIND OF
ROLLED IT OUT AND BY TESTING
SOME OF OUR LARGER. I'M CENTERS
AND THEN IT'S EASIER FOR US TO
PUSH IT OUT IN THE END AND DEAL
WITH THOSE ISSUES THAT MAY BE IN
OUR LARGER CENTERS AND THEN WE I
MEAN THIS IT WON'T BE LONG
BEFORE WE INCLUDE THEM BUT IT
JUST AT THE BEGINNING YOU KNOW
JUST BEING ABLE TO HAVE
OVERSIGHT OVER THE FOUR. AND
THEN PUSHING IT OUT BECAUSE WE
KNOW THE SYSTEM THAT WE'RE USING
RIGHT NOW IS OVERLOADED BUT- WE
IS WE KNOW IT. SO WE JUST WANTED
TO TRY THIS FIRST BY BRINGING
THE PERSONNEL AND- BECAUSE WE
HAD TO GET THEM TRAINED WE HAVE
TO GET ALL THESE THINGS. AND SO
WE ROLLED IT OUT. IN THOSE
PHASES TO ENSURE. THAT YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE STILL BEING
RESPONSIVE. TO THESE REQUESTS.
WHEN YOU USE THE TERM- IT WON'T
BE A HONK. JUST AND I AM NOT
GONNA HOLD YOU TO A PARTICULAR
DATE BUT- WHAT KIND OF A TIME
FRAME DO YOU HAVE IN MIND. WHEN
YOU. YEAH I GOTCHA. THANK. YOU
ARE THAT WOULD. I DO I DID AND I
WAS LUCKY. A DAY YOU AND I
DIDN'T I EVEN IMAGINE THAT THE
REQUESTED WE GET FOR P. REYES
RIGHT NOW HAVE GOT TO THE THAT
IT IS NOW BUT IT IS. IT IS IN.
PROBABLY A HUNDRED FOLD WHAT
USED TO GO ESTHER PRESS WE GET
NOW SO BY BEING ABLE TO
SEGREGATE THEM AND HAVE THE ONES
THAT ARE FOR- FOR OUR
COMMUNICATION CENTERS. I REALLY
DON'T THINK IT WOULD BE AS LONG
AS IT WOULD BE FOR RECORDS FOR
RIO FOR SHOOTINGS OR ANY OF
THOSE KIND OF THINGS OR ANY
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE MORE FOR
SMITH RELATED SO THESE RECORDS
ARE EASIER A LITTLE BIT EASIER
TO- OBTAIN AND- TO PRODUCE. I
DON'T GET A DAY BUT I PROMISE
WE'RE GOING TO WORK VERY HARD
TO. AND WITH THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
OVER THIS ARE GOING TO WORK HARD
TO MAKE SURE WE ROLLED OUT AS
FAST AS WE CAN. RIGHT AT IT
SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING THAT- WILL
CREATE GREATER EFFICIENCIES. AND
WEALTH YES S. C. H. B. SO ARE-
FINAL ISSUE MR BENNETT DOESN'T
HAVE A QUESTION LOOKS LIKE HE
DOESN'T- IS- ISSUE FIFTEEN.
BASELINE COST INCREASES FOR IT.
AND I THINK THIS ONE KIND OF
BRING SAID KIND OF SUMMARIZES
EVERYTHING ALMOST AND I'VE
TALKED ABOUT TODAY BECAUSE IT
ALL KIND OF CULMINATES HERE WITH
OUR- INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY BASS
LINE WHERE WE ARE REQUESTING A
ONE TIME FUNDING OF FIFTEEN
MILLION- IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE FOR THE MOTOR
VEHICLE COW ACCOUNT TO COVER
INCREASED TECHNOLOGY COSTS-
OVERALL BECAUSE AS A C. H. P.
CONTINUES TO IMPROVE OUR
SERVICE. AND SAFETY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES THROUGH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND PROGRAMS THAT
APARTMENT HAS EXPERIENCE IN
NINETY AN INCREASE IN ALL OF OUR
IT COSTS MORE SPECIFICALLY THE
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO LEVERAGE
NEW TECHNOLOGIES TO ENHANCE
EFFICIENCIES AND BETTER MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE PUBLIC. THESE NEW
TECH SOLUTIONS THEY RESULT IN
IMPROVED DELIVERY OF PUBLIC
SAFETY AND SERVICE TO THOSE
RESIDING TRAVEL WITHIN
CALIFORNIA. THE BASELINE COSTS
FOR THESE TECHNOLOGIES IN THE
INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT NECESSARILY
LIMITED TO AN APARTMENT-
COMPUTER AIDED DISPATCH SYSTEMS.
THE STATE WIDE NETWORK UPGRADES
SOFTWARE LICENSING STATE WHY
WIRELESS INSTALLATIONS OF MODEM
REPLACEMENTS. I DISASTER
RECOVERY FOR EXAMPLE- MICROSOFT
AZURE CLOUD SERVICES. WE ALLOW
THE DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE
PERFORMING HIS MISSION CRITICAL
DUTIES DURING AND AFTER A
CATASTROPHIC EVENT. PRIVACY RISK
MANAGEMENT CYBERSECURITY THREAT
ASSESSMENT AND CLOUD COMPUTING
SO IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT STRATEGIC PLAN AND TO
MEET THE CURRENT FEDERAL ESTATE
TECHNOLOGY REQUIREMENTS THE CHP
IS CONTINUALLY UPDATING OUR IT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ORDER TO
INCREASE OUR NETWORK SECURITY.
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL ONLINE
SERVICES TO THE PUBLIC AND TO
PROVIDE OFFICERS WITH TECHNOLOGY
BASED TOOLS THAT ENABLE THEM TO
DEDICATE MORE TIME TO MISSION
CRITICAL DUTIES FOR EXAMPLE- FOR
EXAMPLE TO ALLOW OFFICERS TO
EFFECTIVELY PERFORM PATROL
DUTIES. THE DEPARTMENT IS
SUPPLIED OFFICES WITH TABLETS-
TO ASSIST TO ASSIST THEM WITH
THE AUTOMATION OF MANUAL PAPER
BASED TASKS. SUCH AS CITATIONS
IN THOSE THINGS THAT AND ALLOW
THE OFFICERS TO PERFORM A
VARIETY OF DUTIES MORE
EFFICIENTLY AT THE SCENE. AT THE
BUZZER THIS BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS
WILL ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO
COVER INCREASED COMPUTING
SUPPORT COSTS AND COMPLETE
NECESSARY IT PROJECTS WITH
PROVEN PUBLIC SAFETY SERVICES.
SO ALTHOUGH RIGHT THE SERVER.
RIGHT IT BY THE BCPS. WE NAY
UNDERSTAND THAT REFLECTS IN IN
OF UP. THIRTEEN POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS. AND BASS LINE
BECAUSE OVER THE LAST DECADE AND
THE TABLE IN THE B. C. P.
HOWEVER IT DOES NOT INCLUDE
CRITICAL UPGRADES TO AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE OUR FUTURE
PROJECTS UNDER DEVELOPMENT WHICH
ARE ESTIMATED TO COST AN
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION. AND ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION WE'LL FIND THE
MODERNIZATION OF THE ACADEMY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
VIRTUALIZATION OF DIVISION AND
OFFICE. SO ULTIMATELY THIS
PROPOSAL SUPPORTS OUR IS OUR
STRATEGIC PLAN TO PROVIDE
QUALITY SERVICE TO THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES ENHANCE
TRANSPORTATION SAFETY AND OBTAIN
TRANSPARENCY AND EFFECTIVE
REPORTING ON PERFORMANCE
OUTCOMES. THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU L. A. O. TO HAVE REPORT. AT
THANK YOU CHERRY A UNITS FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
KATHY MACLEOD DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME I'M TO. OKAY THAT'S MY JOB
SHE. OF AWAY FROM ME WHEN WE GOT
A FEW MONTHS. THANK YOU. YEAH
YOU'RE WELCOME- COME A UGH LET
ME- I JUST- THANK YOU- AND- ALL
OF THE- CIVILIAN AND SWORN
OFFICERS WHO- MAKE UP THE CHP
FOR THEIR DEDICATION AND
PROFESSIONALISM AND- ASSISTANCE
TO THE- RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIAN
THOSE WHO WHO VISITORS AS WELL-
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I THANK
YOU FOR THAT MISTER CHAIR I
WOULD DEFINITELY PASS IT ALONG
AND THANK YOU TO EVERYONE IN THE
ROOM PREACHING TO HEAR IN THIS
TODAY YOU'RE WELCOME AND I ALSO
SHOULD COMPLEMENT TO- THE TWO OF
YOU- ON THAT BE COLOR
COORDINATED. TO AND THE
BACKGROUND IT'S PRETTY AMAZING-
I'VE- ON MY PART HERE TO. AND IT
YOU TAKE CARE SIR HAVE A GREAT
DAY THANK YOU I THANK YOU WE
WILL MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT
NOW WE ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC
COMMENT TO- BOTH THE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE
WILL TAKE A HEARING ROOM-
TESTIMONY FIRST THE PHONE NUMBER
TO CONNECT IS- ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE SHOULD ALSO BE ON YOUR
SCREEN IF YOU'RE WATCHING OVER
THE INTERNET. THE PHONE NUMBER
IS. 877-692-8957 AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE ONE. TWO SIX- PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
STAFF. PLEASED TO BE HERE MY
NAME IS MARC WATTS I'M HERE ON
BEHALF TODAY FOR OF
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA. AND
WANT TO SPEAK BRIEFLY ON TWO
ITEMS- ISSUE NUMBER FOR FLEET
REPLACEMENT. WE HAVE A LONG
HISTORY OF TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA BEING SUPPORT OF
CALTRANS AND THEIR FLEET. NEEDS
WE DID SPONSORED LEGISLATION
THAT- ALLOWED BEST VALUE.
PURCHASING FOR SOME OF THE FLEET
THAT ALLOWED. LONGER LIFETIME
PURCHASE PRICES AND- IT THIS
POINT IN TIME WE HAVE A- CONCERN
WE JUST WANT TO EXPRESS. YOU SEE
THAT THE PROPOSAL SPENDS A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR OVER. TWICE
TWO YEARS IN A ROW- FROM STATE
HIGHWAY COUNT AND IN THIS PERIOD
WHERE WE DO HAVE A LARGE
SURPLUS. IT SEEMS LIKE THAT'S A-
EXPENSIVE WAY TO GO A DEPLETING
STATE HIGHWAY RESOURCES WE
ALREADY HAVE A PROPOSAL BY THE
GOVERNOR ON THE TABLE TO-
AFFECTIVELY- LUMINATE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT.THIS ADDS
TO THAT ANOTHER THREE AND A
FIFTY OVER TWO YEARS AND WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE. RETHINKING THAT
AND I'LL LEAVE THAT AT THAT
POINT THE OTHER ITEM. IS THE
ROAD USER CHARGE PILOT AGAIN. WE
WERE- SPONSORS OF THE ORIGINAL
TO SIGN A LEGISLATION. SB TEN
SEVENTY SEVEN IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN- AND WE'VE WORKED VERY
CLOSELY IN THE EARLY YEARS WITH
THE- CTC THE- SECRETARY'S OFFICE
AND IN THE RIVER DEVELOPMENT OF
THE TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE
WE ALSO SPONSOR MR BELL'S
EXTENSION OF THE THC. AND WE
URGE THE RESOLUTION OF THE US
FUNDING DISCREPANCY THE STAFF
IDENTIFIED. AND IF WE CAN BE
HELPFUL WE'D LIKE TO BE SO I
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND SUPPORT-
THE EVENTUAL APPROVAL OF THIS
ITEM AS WELL AS- ISSUE FOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU AND OF
COURSE I NEGLECTED TO- AS IT.
NORMALLY DO A LET EVERYONE KNOW
THAT WERE RESTRICTED TO ONE
MINUTE TO- ONE TIME FRAMES HE
GOT AWAY WITH A FEW MORE SECONDS
THERE- BUT FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
ARE GOING TO BE TESTIFYING BY
PHONE I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANYONE. LEFT HERE IN THE WRITTEN
TO- GIVE PUBLIC COMMENT- ONE
MINUTE BE THAT AND LIMIT- UPPER
. ARE YOU. READY I AM READY AND
AGAIN IF YOU HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND OUR FIRST
COMMENT WILL COME FROM THE LINE
LINE NUMBER NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR HEARING MEMBERS-
COMMITTEE GRAND LEGISLATIVE AND
REGULATORY ADVOCATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
I'M HERE TODAY TO COMMENT ON
ISSUE ONE REGARDING SUPPLY CHAIN
RESILIENCE AND PORT
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. WHILE IT
MAY APPEAR AUDIT BIRTH LESS THAN
PROVIDING COMMENTS ON THIS ISSUE
I DO WANT TO ELEVATE FOR
LEGISLATORS CONSIDERATION THAT
THE COMMERCIAL DRIVER'S LICENSE
CAPACITY ISSUE THAT HAS STYMIED
THE HIRING OF TRUCKERS TO
SUPPORT PORT OPERATIONS. ALSO
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED TRANSIT
AGENCIES AND THEY'RE HIRING A
BUS OPERATORS IN A RECENT SURVEY
OF OUR MEMBERS WE FOUND THAT 60%
OF RESPONDENTS ATTESTED TO
CHALLENGES RELATED TO COMMERCIAL
DRIVER'S LICENSING BUT A PORTION
OF THOSE CHALLENGES ASCRIBED TO
DMB. AT THE LEGISLATURE
CONTEMPLATE PROVIDING IT IS
RESEARCH VIDEO FOR BUILDING
COMMERCIAL DRIVER'S LICENSE.
CAPACITY ASK SPENDING IS THAT
DIRECTION BE FLEXIBLE ENOUGH TO
ALSO THE NEEDS OF CHIU AGENTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
COMMENTATORS FROM LINE CAN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
HERE IN MEMBERS MY NAME IS LAURA
LANE AND I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PORT AUTHORITIES WHICH
REPRESENTS CALIFORNIA'S ELEVEN
PUBLIC COURT KAPPA IS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING
DISCUSSION ISSUE ONE THE ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND SPENDING
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WILL PROVIDE A SOUND
INVESTMENT TO IMPROVE SUPPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ENSURE FUTURE
SUPPLY CHAIN RESILIENCY. BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY TWENTY
CONTAINERISED CARGO VOLUMES IN
CALIFORNIA GREW BY 80% THIS
INTENSE GROWTH HAS HAD IMPACT ON
SUPPLY CHAIN CALIFORNIA PORTLAND
PROACTIVELY TAKEN STEPS TO
ALLEVIATE SUPPLY CHAIN
CONGESTION HOWEVER AND TO
CONTINUE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS TODAY AND IN THE
FUTURE AND DIGITAL. INVESTMENT
IS NEEDED. UNTIL OUR TO GROW
TRADE VOLUME. IMPROVE THE
PORTABLE. AN INCREASE THE COULD
TO GOODS EFFICIENT. AS NOTED IN
FOR FUTURE FUND OUR FOURTH
EXCEEDS THE REQUESTED. AND WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
OUR PORTS TO ENSURE RESILIENCE
AND FUTURE DEMANDS CAN BE MET.
THE INITIAL FORTY MILLION IN
FUNDING FOR INCREASING CAPACITY
FOR THE ISSUANCE OF COMMERCIAL
DRIVER'S LICENSE IS ALSO
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND IS
SUPPORTED BY KAPPA. KAPPA KAPPA
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT OF
ITS BUDGET PROPOSAL AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS ON THE TOPIC. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THE NEXT TIME IT
WILL BE FROM LINE SIXTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU L. I AND MY
NAME IS OLIVIA SIDEMEN WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY I WOULD LIKE
TO COMMENT ON IF FOR THE FLEET
REPLACEMENT AND CALTRAIN PLAN TO
REPLACE THE EXISTING FLEET OF
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS WITH NEW
DIESEL TRUCK OVER THE NEXT TWO
YEARS THE PROBLEMATIC. AS IT
MEANS THAT YOU DIESEL TRUCKS
WILL CONTINUE TO POLITICALLY
DAMAGE COMMUNITIES FOR EVEN MORE
YEARS TO COME I THINK WHICH ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY CLOSE
DIFFERENT CORRIDORS AND A
DISPROPORTIONATELY. POLLUTION AT
THE- WITH. THE TRUCK AND THE CAR
THE NEGATIVE HOW EFFECTS. THE
TECH. FOR HEAVY DUTY EV'S
ALREADY. THE FIVE L. IS EXPECTED
INCREASE IN TWENTY. I THANK WITH
. URGE CALTRAIN TO RETURN THEIR
TO FULLY. HAVE DUTY TRUCK IN
THEIR FLEET WITH NEW PEOPLE
TRUCK OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS. I
THINK THAT PRETTY HAVE YOU GET
BE EASY FOR EVER POSSIBLE. MANY
POINT TO THE EACH. THE ON THE
ACCELERATED TIMELINE CLIMATE
DEMAND. WITH THE RIGHT. IN THAT
IN PUBLIC THAT NO IN THE NOT BE.
RESEARCH DIRECT IT. FLEET THE
IT'S ALL IN FACT SHOULD BE
EXTRA. OUR THE EASY PART. THAT I
. BEAT PURCHASE BETWEEN. SO THE
THING THESE ARE PLACES THAT HAVE
YOU VEHICLES WE ARE GLAD. EVEN
BYRON HEALTH AND CHECK IS THAT
ALREADY PERCENT HEALTH. WE ALSO
THAT WE HOW CAN YOU THINK. FOR
THE- BILLING AND TRACKING FIRST
. TO PRIORITIZE RECORDER IN. THE
DANISH CAN YOU.
THIS COMMENT IS FROM THE LINE
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MELISSA I YOU
ON BEHALF OF THE HOME DEPOT AND
TARGET I'M HERE TO COMMENT ON
ISSUE. TWELVE AND BOTH THE HOME
DEPOT AND TARGET SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
COMBATING ORGANIZED RETAIL YEAH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
THE NEXT FIVE MINUTES FROM LINE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS NEED
SOUL OF ON BEHALF OF THE PORT OF
LOS ANGELES AND STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S INVESTMENT
AND- TO ADDRESS THE GOODS
MOVEMENT ISSUES AND COURT
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES WE'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE- FOR SEVERAL MONTHS NOW TO
ADDRESSTHE SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS.
OTHER STATES WOULD PROVIDE
ANNUAL FUNDING THAT ARE
DEDICATED TO PORTS AND ALSO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
HISTORICALLY- BEEN INVESTING IN
THE EAST AND GULF COAST PORTS AT
AT AT A RATE OF ELEVEN COMPARED
CALIFORNIA VESTMENTS TO
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORICALLY BEEN
UNDER FUNDED SO WE DO THISIS
LONG OVERDUE FUNDING TO HELP
ADDRESS. OUR SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES
. FINALLY WILL MAKE IT AND ON
ALLOWING A- TO- CONSTRUCT
PROJECTS TO ADDRESS YOU KNOW
FUTURE ISSUES AND WILL WILL BE
ABLE DO THAT VERY QUICKLY AND SO
TO MAKE A REAL IMPACT IN
ADDITION THE ZERO EMISSION-
COMPONENT WILL MAKE A HUGE.
IMPACT AS WE TRANSITION TO ZERO
EMISSION DRAYAGE TRUCKS AND ALSO
OUR WORKFORCE TRAINING CENTER IS
A BIG COMPONENT AS WELL CHIU AND
TO ENSURE THAT THE WORK FORCE IS
READY TO HANDLE THESE ADDITIONAL
FLEXUOUS USED AND THE FUTURE- WE
ALSO SUPPORT- YOU KNOW THE
OPERATIONAL PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS
AS WELL AND I APPRECIATE. YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH. THAT
WAS THE LAST COMMENT THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
COMMENTS THIS BRINGS US TO THE
CONCLUSION OF TODAY'S HEARING
AND WE WILL BE ADJOURNED UNTIL
NEXT WEEK. TWO WEEKS THREE WEEKS
AFTER AFTER THE SPRING BREAK YES
SO- ENJOY THE BREAK EVERYONE AND
WE'LL SEE YOU IN A FEW WEEKS.